T two.
Yeah,
we're live ladies and gentlemen.
Eddie Bravo.
Fresh out of fucking
surgeries here looking good.
Too gangster as fuck.
Very few people would do that.
I'd be in bed.
My feet up filled out of my mind.
Just spine surgeries.
Nothing.
Yeah,
no big deal.
Dude.
Got a disc replacement,
titanium disk.
The incredible Brian Count of course
is here popping wine as we speak.
That's not organic.
Okay.
It wasn't orchestrated,
although if it like Brian Cowen had a
character and his opening in a sitcom,
it's like a Kramer slide.
Then Brian would have
a nice bottle of wine.
He would pop it and then he would
explain the vineyard and Fros and grows.
This is about
telling me I had him because he's so good.
You know
Fenocchio he said my favorite,
my favorite Pelu one.
I know dod funding,
not to bring them.
I realized as I was
pulling into the driveway,
but Brendan motherfucking job is here
with a powerful young Chamie tee shirt
fresh out of the box and Jamie,
where does that motherfucker get?
A Y N g m like run DMC young and sure
that young jimmy.com hung Jamie Dotcom
bitches.
People are going to get mad at you.
He full sold out.
[inaudible] people want to vote.
He's sold out.
Don't change the seating,
Jamie.
Folks,
you don't have to buy it,
but it is a dope shirt.
What's wrong with you?
How could you not?
How could you not at the throw it on.
I had a nice stylish shirt.
I thought,
you know what?
I appreciate it.
Jellies.
It's,
he's got his own shirt on,
which is a strong move.
That's like a bold,
that's almost when a rapping,
but it's almost a wrap.
Yeah.
You gotta you gotta shirt with your
name up good and fit good and all that.
That is one thing a standup
comic cannot pull off.
You cannot walk around with
shirt with your own face on.
It literally cannot be done.
Now in Jujitsu,
it's,
it's a weird thing too because it's very,
like there was one shirt that was
like an Eddie Bravo scramble shirt.
I could never wear it.
I can't wear,
I can wear a 10th planet shit all day.
Yeah.
But something that says Eddie Bravo,
Jujitsu or some,
I don't know,
I'd like to get Jiu Jitsu
shirts made with my name.
Just says he used to be a blue belt of
definitely wore run jre shirts before,
but it was almost like nobody
knew what the fuck it meant.
You know,
it's also a Bray and it's not like,
you know like you don't say Joe Rogan,
but my all time that it feel like when
you get to a certain amount of fame and
then you'd like see anyone doing it,
do it.
Like I,
I wore a finding the kid's shirt for
some picture and Whitney Kelvin's let,
don't ever
post a picture of you
and your old shirt again.
Yeah.
You are the fighter and
the kid like he can't,
yeah,
it's,
it's weird.
You know,
we tend to promote it.
You can't be on America's got talent
and where in America's got talent tee
shirt.
You know what I'm saying?
I own,
America's has got talent,
if you will.
We're like the host of star search and
you had a stern shirts everywhere you go
to close those doors.
What did Johnny Depp,
what does giant dad wore a shirt that
said parts of China again are just Johnny.
That Kanye West.
Weird,
right?
Yeah,
but this is designed that's different.
If I design something cool,
I'd wear it.
Yeah,
dude,
his look,
I think Kanye West is quite
silly in a lot of ways,
but it's fucking sneakers.
Look,
they're bad ass.
He's a great designer.
He's got a good mind for things.
He sets the trends for fashion,
but he's an interesting
cat and a lot of ways.
He's got a lot of,
sure.
For sure.
But who the fuck is and you are too bitch.
Oh hell yeah.
I am as well.
Everybody is rooms crazy.
He's awesome.
He's also a prolific,
I bought all this music cause I was,
I told you I was hating
on him and I went home.
I had this hedge picking.
Yeah.
I listened to everything.
I literally bought all his
music and he's so prolific,
man.
I don't know.
He's a bad motherfucker for sure.
No doubt about it.
Kanye West,
but you know,
you know who fucking makes
me feel lazy as shit.
Is Kevin Hart,
Kim and the Rock,
the two of them together,
will they just take it down a notch?
Can I relax?
Well,
I'm on Instagram,
dude.
Kevin Hart's one in 10 days.
He sponsored by Nike Shoe.
Oh,
speaking of,
speaking of someone
who makes me feel lazy,
my friend Cameron Hanes is
in a 24 hour race right now.
He called,
he texted me seven hours in.
He had already ran 50 miles.
She said,
he said,
but he's hurting.
He's going to keep hammering.
So at that pace,
just stop and think about this.
He's not gonna be able
to keep up that pace.
Cause that paces is insane.
Seven hours for 50 miles.
It's a hundred miles in 14 hours.
Nobody does that.
It's usually like 24 hours.
Like the law.
He did 106 last time in
24 hours and he came in,
I wanna say like fifth place
and that's a crazy thing.
It was a woman in front of them.
There was a woman who was just a monster.
What's the east of a woman I can't read.
Yeah,
you're rolling camera
and 106 miles I believe.
And I think the guy who won,
I do not remember his name,
but I believe he was north
of one 13 [inaudible] 14
his build like was he skinny
or was he like a fucking well
cam was too big at the time.
Cam was up to like one 80 he lifts a lot
of weights and he's up to like one huge
for a long distance for a guy who
runs a hundred it's real crazy.
But he runs a half a marathon literally
every day cause he's preparing for the
big foot 200 in August.
So this hundred mile race that he's doing,
his 24 hour race is just to prepare
him for a 200 mile race in August.
Like dude fucking relapsed the on
this guy and he's got a full time job.
So Department of Water
and power in Oregon.
Fucking what are you trying to do?
The most successful bow hunter
in the world runs marathons.
Like,
what is he?
He beat Lance Armstrong and
the Boston marathon is true.
Yes.
Not on a bike though.
Waning.
What does he want the greatest
athletes of world's ever known,
but what?
What does he,
what does he do for maintenance?
How does he keep his body?
He's a savage.
It's hundred percent savage.
You guys are just,
all he does is eat elk,
elk,
and bear,
and he runs and he lifts and
he works an eight hour day job.
I'm tired.
Just looking at his Facebook feed.
I am exhausted.
I got to start up in my,
my are trying to run it on the game.
Species exhausted.
Let's talk about the first fight.
This fight,
he's going to be fucking bad ass.
These chicks are down.
Valerie Laterno.
So this is a flyweight fight.
This is the first,
I think.
Is this the first UFC flyweight fight?
Is that,
is that what it is?
It's 25 what does sw a straw weight.
She's the number five
strawweight contender.
But this is not a strong way to fight.
This is a flyweight fight.
I think.
If I'm not,
I could totally be wrong.
The fucking nerds are
going crazy right now.
Let's check it you piece of shit
and fucking Poland.
I love you guys.
Relax.
Everybody relax.
Everybody calmed down that refugees shit.
[inaudible] that's a beautiful name.
I think she's cute.
Show us the card,
Jamie on the other screen
so we could see what,
uh,
what fights are so fun card for sure.
I think she's cute too.
Was the first one yet right?
And you think,
well,
I'm old.
So all any girl in her twenties,
he's adorable.
And you're like the creepy
guy from family like dot.
Merera I said,
he's like,
she could have a goat head.
She's in her twenties so it's a Calder
one and Latino and Latino just had a
fucking amazing fight where you honor
you and Jay check really five round war
and Australia.
She went to war dude for five rounds with
this beast of a Moyie Thai fighter and
she lost the fight,
but she more than held
her own the champion.
Wow.
Valerie Laterno.
She got down to one 25 which I think
is too much of a struggle for now.
Or excuse me.
Yes,
thank you.
And now she's at one 25 this is their
first fight at one 25 but I believe she's
fought at one 35 to say Yolanda is the
best pound for pound female fighter.
Oh yeah,
she's right.
He Dude,
she's,
she scares me.
Her striking is so clean,
but I got to say her fight with Claudia.
Good day.
It was super,
super close,
man.
It was real close.
Really close.
She dropped her though with a
big fucking uppercut a little,
little while ago though.
That little while the code should be,
I think so too.
The Claudia is a straight 200 dime piece.
I didn't realize it.
So I started watching
the ultimate fighter.
She's very pretty.
She react to,
she's so strong.
She's so strong.
Double digits.
Who's nasty man?
Her like top pressure.
She's very tough to escape
from really strong technical,
Jujitsu and her,
her kickboxing.
Not bad either,
man.
No,
she,
she's very all rounded.
Very well rounded.
If anyone's going to beat you on,
it's her.
If you watch the ultimate fighter,
I thought she came off
better than y'all on a shoot.
One more fans.
You know they had a full on fist fight
while taping that they were throwing head
kicks at each other and everything.
Who throws head kicks and look at this.
Meanwhile Calderwood he's about
to get caught in this valley with
the Toronto Armbar.
Her arms are in a good position.
Her left arm is not in a good position.
She didn't have good grades.
She just kind of holding
on that big right hand.
Calderwood's nasty man.
She fights hard,
real aggressive.
Oh,
Valerie goes for it again.
But this time,
not even close edge to care
to comment on the control,
the posture.
It's old school style.
You know,
doing Jujitsu against that fence.
It's a,
it's tough.
Squashed and Jujitsu practitioners
generally aren't used to that.
Yeah.
You're really kind of have to
fight or train with one of those,
Huh?
You got to learn how to use the fence
to your benefit and that takes a lot of
practice.
I'm not that good at that.
You know,
man,
I was really surprised when
we used to roll a legends.
How much it hurts the case for it.
Yeah.
The first thing that drives me,
no,
your head,
the word,
like when your head gets banged into
it and your head gets pushed into it,
fucking hurt doesn't give that
much and you need your fingers.
It doesn't feel good.
It's not fun if they rub up.
No,
I mean if you're going to do like
straight Jujitsu and you just want to do
Jujitsu and never get involved in MMA,
you really should have like a padded wall.
Hell yeah.
Fuck.
Because the cake,
but the cage looks good.
If someone's going to sign up walking,
do you want to be like Brennan jump?
Yeah,
Bro.
We got a cage full cage.
Okay.
To man train and replaced
with a full cage,
bro.
I used to,
I'm serious as a fucking total poser.
I used to like to walk into that cage.
Oh,
called the wind.
Oh No.
All over.
The maternal is hurting.
You know,
you're a bad bitch if you
got a shaved head turns.
She's scrambling.
They could easily stop that.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Thank God they didn't see,
wow,
they didn't,
she got that spinning elbow right in the
writing the old jaw and looking at the
whole card.
She got tagged again.
Valley of the turn.
It was so tough,
man.
Beaus
you know she has a good
striking background.
I think she's just used
to getting hit man,
but she's just tough to,
oh shit.
I'll do it with a big elbow.
Oh,
we should tell you guys one
13 if you want to sync up.
It's 1110 nine eight seven six five.
That's probably the best way to do it,
right?
For sure.
A first round.
Joanna Calderwood.
[inaudible] hard though,
man.
It is a very good car.
Did you see the Tam to
Mcroy fight earlier?
What happened?
Which was when I was talking to him to
see that Tim didn't got starched with one
straight left hand.
Damn.
I didn't see it.
I saw a homeboy or easy Joe Soto.
Damn Squirrel.
Oh Damn.
I see a little Damien
Maia and mad pressure too.
He was leaning that fight.
He was losing that fight,
but they weren't giving him enough credit
for the pressure that he was putting
on his cause.
He's getting tagged.
I think he's getting lit up.
I thought he was getting up getting hit.
I thought,
I thought the second round he won,
so we wanted,
the second record was this
guys look at this fight.
When Kenny was saying that he
was down two rounds to one,
I was like,
oh,
not see how it could have lost one one,
this
girl,
this girl was taking shot at one one and
then third was up in the air until we
took him down.
It was,
see,
what I was seeing though is
a lot of pressure control.
Soto Christian.
Chris was definitely hitting him,
but he didn't have them
hurt in any point though,
and soda was constantly doing this.
Constantly pressure.
Now what a fight.
Very good fight and then in
the third Sodo started tag him.
Soto started to really
put that pressure on them.
In public.
It's fucking hard as hell.
They want us to tell you to
back up while you're striking.
Backing up and striking is so much harder.
What do you mean backing on?
I ever move backwards.
I never moves backwards.
Your real life,
you run forward,
right?
So wanting to run backwards
all the time like that,
it's exhausting.
It's way harder to move backwards.
That's why Thompson so
special and who the ODA,
when the auto was at its best,
you couldn't even get near him.
But that's just a,
it's a thing that you could get good
at in Muhammad Ali's to run miles
backwards.
It's over years.
We've been doing it since.
He was like,
yeah,
you got to do it.
You got to do it.
It's like,
it's a really important part of footwork.
The backing up thing can't be exhausting
queue because the moving forward things
easy for everybody.
So if a guy has just
sort of walking you down,
you can't hurt him.
His walking forward is relaxed and easy.
Natural.
Yes.
Especially if he has good blocking,
but you're constantly
springing your body backwards.
Springy body backwards.
Different muscles for openings.
It's exhausting.
It takes like 30% more.
Watch this,
watch this,
this,
this is crazy.
Oh,
what's this?
it's perfect.
Oh,
she's out.
She's hurting for sure.
She definitely wasn't out.
I'm a Joe.
Think about the guys and girl,
that group successful are some of the,
Oh,
for sure.
The worst to deal with.
They're hard because you can't mimic it.
Really.
That's one of the things interesting
about this fight tonight is that Rory
brought in one of the best
guys in the world at it.
He brought in Raymond Daniels,
Raymond Daniels,
that bad ass karate guy,
glory who throws those three 60 turning
side kicks and his dad's face with them.
He's wild.
Man is kicking is insane.
So Rory is going to be working with a
guy who can kick arguably as good as
Wonderboy or in the neighborhood.
At least God,
I would say better at his level,
especially professionally.
Um,
as a kickboxer kickbox it's,
it's good to make that argument.
Yeah.
Well the thing is Wonderboy has a
kickboxer was absolutely perfect.
57 no.
Yeah.
And Raymond's loss.
Some tough fights.
But did Raymond lose to guys
like val to lean and did,
did,
did he lose to those guys?
Cause they were just so
worldclass for competition.
Wonderboy,
I'd never faced something like that.
Is that the case?
Oh Damn.
She's tagging or the turnout was so tough
when talks about so much shit through
this awesome fight.
Such a good fight.
The watch the Turner,
she's just jacking off to this way.
This is a very good fight.
Damn.
It's a good fight and she's,
Oh get I'm caught host turtles.
Just throwing and and
connecting every time.
Will it turn out like
you see her striking?
It's real tactical.
Nice.
Right upper cut and you saw
that in the UN j check fight.
That's the only way you could survive
striking with you and Jay check.
But I do to say,
do you want to
broke her hand in that fight?
That's right.
Oh that's a big factor way.
Still throwing bombs.
Hit the tone bum,
throw him bonds are broken when they
say she would don't the golden glory and
just do work against Duke.
Oh,
I could use just some monster.
I can imagine.
I could imagine thinking on
intimidating this being plus size,
you don't a golden glory.
Super impressed with her background.
Is She a striker?
First to striker?
She's an att girl.
Trains at American top team,
which she cannot wear shorts.
And then weird.
Even in boxing,
you'd have Cronk on your shorts.
They should have their
fucking gym on the shore.
She got out of your gym in the
short one on top of Reebok.
You should definitely have your
gym and your shorts and respect.
Right.
I agree.
Why don't Laura firefighters
practice running backwards?
It's because it takes too long.
It's hard.
Anytime I've ever heard of this.
Well Eddie,
you know how a lot of dudes
don't like to be on the bottom.
Same thing.
Yeah,
but things people don't,
they want it.
Don't,
don't want to do things that they
don't like to do in training.
And especially like running backwards.
It's not fun.
It's also going to take a while
to get a good stretch out,
dude.
We now run backwards just for your cardio.
I realized real early,
uh,
in doing taekwondo,
how exhausting it is to
try to move backwards.
Cause I used to spar with this kid.
It was a really good boxer
and he used to beat my ass,
but I was always moving
backwards from him.
I was always moving backwards
and I would get exhausted.
I was like,
why am I getting so fucking tired?
And then after a while I realize
like it's gotta be connected,
not just to his pressure,
but also the fact that I'm
moving backwards so much.
It's not just a physical thing.
And then as I get better at boxing,
I definitely found it.
That was the kid.
He's like a lot more energy.
Like your shit.
Like when I move forward,
if I move forward near the counter
punch and you're going backwards,
you're taking way more steps than
I am deaf for doing way more work.
Definite of Muhammad Ali was doing it.
I think that everybody would do that,
right?
But,
and he used to run,
oh,
the running backwards thing.
Men turn.
So there's a lot of coaches,
a lot of coaches work on that stuff now.
They even do it on treadmills.
They do like sprints on
treadmills running backwards.
Also less,
uh,
wear and tear on your knees.
Is it really backwards?
Well,
I guess you kind of have to
go on your balls of your foot.
Run it backwards.
Yeah.
Can you can't go heal.
You'll fucking go flipping backwards.
Football players practice running back.
Yeah,
definitely.
Cornerback certain positions.
Yeah.
I want to ask you,
you want to ask this
question before I forget it.
You trained at Jake Glaser's place,
Huh?
Dude,
that was watching Instagram of that today.
This is a joint.
Did Jay Glazer just set
that up all himself?
Uh,
I mean he's definitely the captain of
that ship to what a fucking huge move that
is for him.
That's a great fifth.
Spell it too.
Right off sunset there.
But Pink Taco reason I brought it up.
They had these football players
doing these exact same drills.
They were running forwards and backwards
and doing all this crazy sprinting shit
where it's all like,
you know,
the,
the coach could tell you backwards.
Go forward,
back and they working on this stuff out.
I'm all reaction stuff.
Oh,
look at this.
This is heavy duty Shit.
Well,
you
guys obviously didn't
see that there's a trail,
almost,
almost all of their sports
practice going backwards.
Yeah.
Well now that I think of the quarter,
lots of a lot of fighters do.
Obviously Connor does.
Connor is really good at moving
backwards and moving forward,
but there's no doubt as we both nice
moving backwards costs more energy.
And Connor,
Connor Five,
that movement coach.
Huh?
Did he?
Yeah,
he was like,
ah,
looking back on it,
I think any of you born in the gym
instead of climbing fucking law
from what I heard that you know what?
I'm good on climbing trees and shit
cause you to defense the other guys,
the law guy or woman,
the core
Hula hoops and okay,
I disagree.
There's a lot of merit
in the movement movement.
I'm just saying the guy who was the
head of this movement movement was like,
I'm good.
I got some shit to folks site.
Here's why.
I think there's some merit to it.
Two reasons.
One break dancers.
One of the things in Jujitsu and
Eddie Bravo old test to this.
We had a bunch of breakdancers
start training and uh,
Eddie was like the first to comment on it.
Like how crazy strongly are and weird
way they can move their body so well
it wasn't just one or two of them.
They all got good and then I've
got a couple more sense there's,
they'd come in and they're
really good right away.
They well their motor skills
too with that movement.
So fucking strong.
So much shit from their bodies and
memorizing stuff been on my head and slow
motion dude.
For sure.
I do.
I do one hand,
one hand handstands.
Those guys were ridiculous like this.
You guys have met,
they're doing back flips.
They're doing one hand to hand sand.
They're jumping on one hand.
They do.
I mean have you ever seen his black belt?
Richard Martinez?
No.
Tell him and Geo Jail Martinez called
Richie Martinez brothers that been break
dancing their whole lot and tell him,
tell him Tom Eddy.
Ridiculous.
Cause I know as an instructor,
no instructor wants to
give black belts early.
Nobody does.
It isn't something that you wanted to
because that's a reflection on you.
Yes.
And if you give it too
early and they get crushed,
you look back,
you're like,
I'm not going to give you a black belt
until I could make sure that you don't
embarrass me.
I know what I mean.
Right.
So last thing we wanted to,
we're back on the fight here real quick
because there was a some sort of a
change.
We explain what happened.
Jimmy,
we had a change challenge from Fox sports
two to Fox sports one why we do the
Nascar race.
Oh,
it just took over and so fox
changed it and mid fight.
This is a bra like confusing.
What?
They changed your fire
Jetson that's hired.
Who the fuck changes a fight like
this and mid fight that just happened.
That is so crazy.
People are going to miss this.
They're going to not go to Fox sports
one and they're going to miss this.
They go to take a piss.
They come back or they're
talking like I was missed it.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Thank you Jamie for being so on.
You don't have a young
Jamie living with you.
Screw Jamie's something else.
Anyway,
anyway,
I got to step up my dance
case coaches or break dancing,
but,
but to these guys it'll pour towel.
That guy that's soup.
Extreme movement of movement got extreme.
It would be what these guys are doing
to music and he's this super crazy,
like the ultimate uh,
uh,
that movement should,
that you could possibly do.
I wish I could break.
Oh,
hello.
she kicked him right in the solar plexus.
Goddamn Latino's.
Tough.
So tough.
Oh my God.
It's cops.
Fire needs it.
She gets cracked with an elbow.
Gosh,
she's called it.
What is a beast but tells
the turnout Matt's fault are,
Oh my God.
Ooh.
Shovel Hook.
Oh,
cool.
you're not allowed to
kick the what happened?
I guess you're not allowed
to kick there in the table.
You definitely know.
It's like the nuts
that can't be tried girl.
That can't be true.
Which can be kicked me there man.
It's
very good.
Fight a minute.
That's not true.
Is it spoke to him.
No hitting in the clan.
You fucks get kicked me.
Sure.
Taking that titty titties.
You can't do it.
Can't.
What happened?
What?
You punted the,
those are really big,
really nice.
Blake and Brandon,
they showed the rape.
A girl kicked another go right in the
ground with they shut the written the show
with guys.
They do it in slow motion.
Super Slow Mo.
Oh
God damn it.
Oh my God.
That was a crazy ending.
Tell there was a beast that
wasn't a titty shows a body shot.
I think she broke her rib
with that one shot earlier.
I think I need the replay
or somewhere in that fund.
That was a beast of a fight.
Could Lord,
she went relentless elbow.
This is the day where people online go,
hey,
you fucks occasionally watched the fight.
This was crazy.
This is a crazy fight.
My Dad,
oh my God,
she's so tough.
That girl.
Let me see this fucking
spartan kicked to the tit.
This was tough.
Boom.
That's right.
That's right in the stomach.
That's the second time she did that too.
She comes,
she's going to stop this and
she comes erection to the thigh.
That's her opening move.
That's beautiful.
You see the first one?
Watch this,
boom out,
but check this out.
Run need of the thigh.
Why would she try spinning back jacked?
I mean,
you mean Valerie?
You can't use her.
She started drop to the ground.
Can't turn your back.
She got,
she got hurt with a bad shot to
the body earlier in that round.
I think she was really hurt.
Oh yeah.
I think she's so fucking tough.
I think she was really,
really her son.
She's weird.
She's tough.
My God,
she's tough.
That is the first time I've ever seen
someone run at someone who is hurt and
open with a need of the thigh
and then a spinning back.
Fist girl's got a complete Moitai game,
man.
That's a complete game.
Like she's thinking and
all these different angles.
She doesn't have a gun fight.
Yeah,
she doesn't have like a limited approach,
bro.
Speaking of fun fights,
Anthony Rumble Johnson
out against what happen?
I don't fucking know.
Ruined my day.
What happened?
No idea.
Injury.
Do you know Jamie?
The injury for sure.
He pulled out a little far
out to pull out though.
Huh?
They can't break a leg or some
shit or something really wrong.
Pull out this early is nuts,
right?
God Damn.
I wanted to see that.
Fine.
It's my number one fight
this year from the day.
Make Gustafson versus Glover.
They just gave Gustin some bullshit.
Then I'm saying dog,
Bro.
Let's get it moving.
Let's chill.
Let's roll.
Let's get back to an Oh shit
fund out that bats is the sun.
That's an old weeding shit fight.
[inaudible]
very much in the game.
He's been real quiet.
I just announced the fight.
One of the best.
He's right up there.
Look,
you went five hard rounds of John Jones.
Five hard rounds of DC.
He's amazing.
He's seeing the world for sure.
He lost to rumble,
but guess what?
Everybody who rumbled hits
like that goes night night,
but do you,
did you see that they
played it over and over?
He did get headbutted two magazines.
What looks like it?
Yeah,
it looks like it.
It looks like it.
It's sorry.
It's hard to see.
Like I've looked at it and thought
that it didn't look like a head,
but then I've looked at it.
I said the punch land at first for sure,
but it looked like definitely collided.
Yes,
it's tough.
It's just weapon thing touches.
Anyone like that though I
think they fight 10 times.
You're going a different result each time.
Maybe that's a good
breakdown of it in slow mo,
but it was hard to see like if the
right hand landed first or the the head
Butler,
what did we think?
What did we do?
Headbutt and you didn't
and but the more replayed,
it almost starts siding with you.
I,
I always thought it was a headbutt.
I got so high once I watched
the big foot footage,
I thought it was real.
I was so hot.
I was like,
maybe I've been making
fun of me all the time.
So she just took some shots in my stomach,
but I am wow.
It cm punk,
the new a Tarzan.
See if he fails every water test.
Cm punk is a very
reasonable looking athlete.
You know what I mean?
Looking at the WWE guys kind of small,
not yeah.
Dot.
I'm just saying,
not like good luck and yeah,
not a bad looking guy is handsome,
but what I'm saying his body.
Yeah.
It's like a guy works out a lot.
He doesn't look like Battista.
Exactly.
Exact steroid guild.
Who's the,
who's the other Bobby Lashley.
That's another one.
Like Jesus Louise's how
he's fighting for the door.
Those fighting,
a lot of events were built or,
oh,
we'll leave that Friday.
Oh,
so you know what it was?
No,
no.
It was face and then she pulled her,
brought her,
her boob,
popped out of the Bra.
Wow.
Respect.
Respect to call the Woodford.
She's like,
what happened?
Look at this.
And then that.
But there was another one to
the stomach that was that,
that she buckled.
There was another shot and
to the stomach before that,
that made her buckle.
So there was more than one shot to the
stomach that had Valerie and trouble.
I'm pretty sure me and her
have the exact same fade.
Not Weird.
Had the same year,
same year above
c getting good at this.
Sometimes it's nothing.
Sometimes better to say nothing.
I'm a big fan.
I think she's cute.
She's gangsters.
Fucked with a spinning
back fist off the cage.
Back door.
It would look unrealistic.
I know,
right?
Her combinations were beautiful too.
So technical needed the butt and then
she threw a right and a left elbow and
then a spinning back to
stay close as a thigh.
It was a knee to the thigh,
so she tees off in her.
This is the first one,
right?
This is the first knocked out.
Now watch his shot to the bike.
That's the one that's
the one turned around.
Oh my goodness.
That's fight club.
What a combination.
Well,
she just got hurt real bad there,
man.
She had people get hurt all the time.
You never turn your back and run.
Well listen man,
I'm not forgiving it.
I'm just saying,
I think our guts were on fire,
you know,
drop to the ground.
It's one of those things,
man.
It's like she's just
turning in that moment.
She got hurt bad then fade or melodyne.
No,
fuck man.
What the fuck happened?
I don't auto caught him with a swift
left hook and he was on queer street bell
on social in that fight.
And what happened?
I mean you're in Russia.
Russian judges.
It was,
I mean they would have
stopped it if it was here.
Federal loses that fight was
kidding with the Bella Donna.
But no,
Maldonado was a good boxer man.
He caught him with that right hand,
caught him with a nice short right
hand and beat him up on the ground.
He was out there,
was out on the Ct.
He looked bad and then he got up at one
point in time and Fabio hit him with a
bomb and had his legs wobbling and he
did the chicken dance across the octagon
and he still lost a decision.
Yep.
It's the rush.
I mean,
but does the second two rounds?
He didn't do a lot,
but still that first rounds,
ten eight if not,
can I give a head for,
it might be ten seven it might be
ten seven at least tense because he,
he had him like,
well,
I don't know man.
When did someone get a ten seven
that would be so close to a stop.
If that's in the u s that fight stops.
I think,
well just say that,
but then there's like Frankie
Edgar Gray Maynard [inaudible] God,
he's the ref or whatever
the fuck did I say Tarzan?
Tarzan.
Tarzan trailer guys.
This movie.
So realistic.
Yeah,
because last guy who with a
white man like wait a minute,
back up.
Is that fucking Snoop Dogg?
Nah Man.
Samuel Jackson.
Your highest fun.
I looked at it the very
last second and I said,
look at this.
What is this?
Oh my God,
he's dead.
He just jumped to the air and
he's going to collide with a,
Oh,
the chimp,
right?
I see.
I can't watch it.
Was that a chimp or a gorilla?
Gorilla.
Okay.
He's dead.
That's like,
why don't you just like
Headbutt an airplane?
They just tackled a grill.
Yeah,
cause it's a 600 pound animal or to
send me the Jackson five or confused it.
Very young sandwich.
Fucking look at this
gorilla visitor graphic.
He's going to go to war with this girl.
Bitch.
Know what real is going towards for him.
Oh,
for him?
Why did they collide then?
Different Grill?
Uh,
no,
I think it's a,
they're trying to stake their
territory for the hot grill.
You know what man is,
he picked the wrong primate
to have a war with her.
Fucking scary man.
Yeah.
Those things are just way too big.
Like the idea of an 800
pound human is terrifying,
but an 800 pound gorilla.
What's the like,
is that like the biggest thing yet?
We've gone over this.
I think it was like 500 I think we
decided about five 606 six 30 that was the
issue,
right?
There was quite a few different nations.
Like one of them said 801 of them said
500 or a couple of big ones I think are
like that big
fucking average.
What's the outlier though?
Like the mountain,
but who was the mountain back,
right?
Yeah,
the King Kong out there in this bitch.
Do you watch game of Thrones?
I don't.
I'm 33 there's Dragon Mountain.
You get to a certain age and
dragons no longer become fun
and cool and I'm like,
oh no,
I never missed.
I've never missed an episode.
I never miss an episode bearish.
My fine.
It's awesome.
Dare.
I used to look forward to it.
Like I shut everything
down and by the way,
how many seasons?
Don't even know.
Six.
I've seen every one of them.
The mother of dragons,
dude,
it's called ABC shows and
I've seen every one of them.
Dude,
she can,
she can step in a fire and be fine.
425 six foot tall.
Yeah,
that's one.
But if you go to another one
or like you go to Wikipedia
mountain rose got up to
600 pounds for 25 what?
I want you to Google please.
What is the largest gorilla?
Biggest Grill of all time?
It's over six.
What's the Brock Lesnar?
Cause there's a mighty mouse.
Johnson is a Brock Lesnar.
Well this is tricky because
that can be a realist.
Jamie was it said Jamie,
Jamie,
600 pounds,
man,
I can't read him.
That's him.
He's out of shape though.
Was it?
Say Jamie doesn't say his weight.
Bull Shit dear there.
Biggest grill ever found in the world.
I'll tell you what.
I'd rather fuck with that
grill in a crocodile.
Yeah,
dude,
I am so not in the fucking [inaudible].
I used to be into alligators.
Not Anymore.
What we were talking
about that that thing,
shoulders,
two year old kid that got sucked
into the water and Orlando.
I blame the parents a little bit.
It's Florida Sun.
Yeah,
just maybe they're not from Florida,
Nebraska,
Nebraska.
Oh Man,
look,
if you don't,
if you're not around
those goddamn monsters,
you don't know.
Hey Disney,
let's go ahead and put up some
crocodiles side and just be safe.
If they had signs that
said don't know swimming,
but they didn't have signs that said,
beware of alligators.
By the way,
in one of my more retarded
moments on the show,
we were trying to figure out a how a
crocodile is not the biggest lizard when
there's so much bigger than
Komodo dragons were like,
why is a Komodo dragon not
nearly as big as a crocodile,
but they called the biggest
loser is crocodiles,
arm reptiles,
reptiles.
Lizards,
but lizard is a very specific testing.
Elizabeth.
It is a little bit,
no,
I definitely did when we were doing that.
Those are on board.
Raise a reptile.
Oh listen,
I definitely,
definitely got cropped out.
It's not a,
I wouldn't even think that.
Well,
it lizards,
definitely reptile.
Oh,
crocodile is not a lizard,
which is the sales rep.
Dot.
That's what we're saying.
Different species,
different species.
Yeah.
So,
but it's like one of
those things like monkeys,
like saying monkeys or chimps.
Yeah.
What?
I just got it wrong.
You know,
they're,
they're obviously the same kind of thing,
you know,
classification.
Right.
So apes don't have tails,
right.
So you have,
you have baboons,
Gibbons.
He's not real though.
It's not even a real word that
the issue is like monkeys,
not a scientific term
to chip it to Sydney.
Simeon's there's all sorts
of different primates.
Right.
But,
but the way it's described now,
like the way it's being accepted,
there was an article about it
mean maybe you could find it,
Jamie,
that all apes or monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes.
All apes or monkeys.
Not all.
Not all marketers,
so you could call it makes sense.
This is in the classification.
This is the way there.
They were going off in this article.
Like you could call a chimp or a person.
You can call it a monkey,
but you can never call like
one of those spider monkeys.
You can never call that an eight test.
Not An ape.
I wonder.
Yeah.
What's an orangutan?
That's an SNA.
That's an a chimpanzee mountain gorilla.
Orangutan Gibbon,
which is smaller that it looked
just as small as a lot of monkeys.
And then um,
uh,
the Banaba,
the,
these are all apes and I think
baboons are apes right there.
They're a weird one though.
It's got a monkey to fuck the dog.
Oh yeah,
it doesn't,
it I boots.
Yeah,
dude,
we shot something with a dog on,
remember we shot that thing with a Batman.
The guy was missing fingers
are bit his fingers off.
What you've been trainer.
Yeah,
he's missed two fingers that ripped his
fingers off because I'm male basil's
deep and Bam nailed that into him.
Hey.
He goes,
hey,
you know,
he said,
he goes,
don't look him in the eye,
don't.
And he goes,
who wants a picture on it?
Not me.
But then dudes were lining up
and when dudes would line up,
I swear to God the bathroom
take pictures like this.
I got her fucking strong on that bitch
grabber and just like hold on their TV.
Yes.
And I went home video of this.
That's me dressed as a warm girlfriend.
100.
His Dick was out the entire time.
That's me dressed as a
woman with my baboons.
Shine Boehner the entire time
I'm sending it to myself
before he forgets.
And by the way,
those things are,
um,
teeth like for all the
shit teeth like this.
The males
will test you.
The males will,
will kind of go,
you're,
you're being dominant right now.
I'm going to have to sink my teeth into,
did the guy say to you all the guys,
he goes,
do not look this thing in
the go find me on your phone.
Yeah,
you looked that thing.
He's gonna rip you.
Fuck those things.
Those things scare the shit out of me.
They're not good.
You know what though?
It's kind of small.
I felt like I could fuck them up.
I felt like I could fuck them up,
dude.
Fuck that.
No,
no,
no.
Well you could,
but not her damage damage,
but the biting.
Hey Bro,
that's not the one I saw her.
Fuck.
You're not gonna be
able to deal with that.
No.
Fuck No.
Okay.
That's a special top.
Oh my God.
Screened is everybody at home.
Get to see this.
This is not what we're looking at.
Let's not.
We have fun when that thing is sinking.
It's fucking case.
Going to bite your neck apart.
It's going to raise your neck a post.
I had some water down.
Fucking he was on meth
or something real skinny.
That's all done.
I'll take a bite from a German shepherd
over that fucking thing I will do.
There's some of the most ferocious
priming their asses all pink.
That's what they show you bitches.
What time would they fight?
They fight the leopards.
Anymore questions you fox?
Not well.
Not only that dude,
they trained dogs.
Baboons are strange as
they're very intelligent.
Some weird way that train fucking
dog with your other phone.
Would you rather fuck with
that thing or a chimpanzee?
Oh Man,
I don't want to fuck with me.
And he's conversations,
conversations.
Pry him over a chimp though.
No,
I don't know.
You gotta go.
It's gotta be,
it's gotta be bigger.
Well,
he's probably pretty fucking
strong to in unload of those guys.
Bring up the goddamn chimps.
Chimps will change your whole life.
Chips,
potato chips will will free you
have your face and your genitals.
Yeah,
I think.
Okay.
I think,
I think I could come
over this fucking thing.
That's what I'm saying.
And Joe monkeys back and you think you
could choke a monkey out of me back for
sure.
Well,
they're too little.
A monkey monkeys,
a little
paints that picture of guns take on them.
He got a dick on him there though.
He does have a tick on him.
Jeez.
Look at that.
But it's not skip leg day.
That's kind of a dog.
It's kind of a dog thing,
right?
Yeah,
it is.
It's weird.
That's like all wet.
It's like real sticky and
what's like a werewolf?
Kind of tight tummy.
Tight tummy though.
Whoa.
Do you think that that was like that
the werewolf came from like baboons,
rob,
one of those?
It has to be fucking huge.
Don't in order for someone
to think it was that big.
Well just boom person.
The biggest Babylon you get baboons that
are 115 hundred and I think Jamie was
the biggest baboons we've ever seen.
Let's take a guess.
I'm going to go with Brian.
I think that sounds right to me.
The math,
how many males?
Hundred and 10 pounds.
I'm going to go ahead and say there's
a big boy out there about 180 pounds.
Just diesel.
Diabetes.
Yeah,
me with 10 pounds of teeth.
Apes get diabetes.
They get diabetes.
They have problems.
Yes.
Why did they eat at insulin resistance?
I see and cause then in Sue's I'm
always appalled and zoos I've read,
they don't feed their
there apes very well.
This kid is a sturdy,
sturdy young man.
He is friends with my
friends who own Joe beef,
which is one of the best restaurants on
the planet earth and it's in Montreal,
Canada,
Quebec,
Tristar,
I'll bone merciay.
He fought in Montreal when we were
there and then came to the restaurant
afterwards.
What a Nice Guy,
right?
Like a genuine sweetheart of a guy.
Really Good Jujitsu,
super fucking strong,
but bodied,
bought up speaking,
speaking of chimps bodied,
but a super,
super friendly,
not like if you wanted to ask for like
someone to represent MMA to someone who
thinks that MMA fighters were all thugs
and assholes like this young man is so
polite and well spoken and smart and
just such a good guy and a really good
fighter to the really good,
you know,
good final blew my mind is I got a chance
to kind of hang out with Paul Felder a
little bit.
Oh,
great.
Great Guy.
And a theater major in college.
Thank you very much.
Smart.
Super Smart.
Tough Shit.
Oh my God.
It's like he's all of
185 pounds right now.
Dude.
He looks,
so I said to him,
I go,
he looks like he's made like his
bones are made us woody gather Jamie,
what'd we got?
Jamie Chakma shock my at the,
it says it's the one of the heaviest
and at most weighs about 99 pounds.
Get the thing of my fucking face.
99 [inaudible] 99 pound male baboons name
here and a peep out and here in a peep
out of you.
And,
and good luck keeping that mouth and that,
that non neck away from your face.
And you definitely don't want
any of that because believe me,
I had a pit bull that was 90
pounds and he was a giant problem.
This job he wanted to get at this dog.
So he bent the bars on my house,
the wrought iron bars.
I had to get a bar welded across the
perimeter of my fence because he realized
that if he slams his
fucking fire hydrant head
in between the bars,
he can get them like
that watch fucking head.
Right?
So with dog,
like that's all head.
So once they get their head through his
and his body got through,
he bent the fucking bars like the hook.
So I had this,
why did you ask that thing?
He's my best friend.
His name was frank.
He was a great name.
Frank Sinatra.
Frankie.
He was a beast.
I had to have a bar installed all
around the perimeter of my yard and a,
this Israeli guy comes over to install it.
He goes,
what happened here?
I said,
the dog did it.
He goes,
the dog.
how do they do?
I go,
he did it with his head.
It's like,
get the fuck out of here.
He looks over the dog,
loose over the pellet.
What the fund?
The dog just sitting there.
He would hunt.
Lizards passed away.
He would just hunting lizard
bees all God damn day on it.
On the map.
It was a beast is,
look,
I am not a fan of dog fighting.
I think it's a terrible,
horrible thing.
But what they did is they
engineered a super dog.
Yeah,
and that's what those things are.
They are not like regular dogs.
Fuck.
I got him from a breeder.
We like him creatine all times.
Shit.
No,
I didn't have to do anything with him,
man.
He was a super genetic freak.
Those dogs are,
those dogs are different than any income,
any other dog,
a manmade dog.
They're so goddamn smart and loyal and
they're so loyal and they love you so
much.
The game
and the game bred dogs,
you know,
animals fight out of fear
of dominance came bred.
Dogs fight.
Cause they literally enjoy it.
They're covered in blood,
ripping each other apart and
they're wagging their tails.
Man,
I had a runny nose,
man.
I love pit bulls to,
I don't want one now that you,
but we'll figure it.
I've come home to dead
dogs before God damn.
Well they fought to the death killing
things to female and female named squeaky
Fromme.
Remember what was the founder,
Brian Brian's founder fee
table with jaws rescue dog.
And she was so sweet and I call it
a squeaky Fromme cause she'd been,
there's a la shelter
that does not kill dogs.
They try not to.
It's awesome.
And so,
uh,
Brian told me,
dude,
you got to get this dog.
You're retarded.
I know you're retarded.
Avatar to come get this dog
out of a story of a fuck.
I'll be right over and do
the minute you saw her.
I drove down there,
went down to the shelter,
Olivier,
Obama,
RCA with the takedown.
Real close.
Good defense.
This is that.
This is another rough,
why the Dow?
So anyway,
I go there and she's,
she's so sweet.
She's such a sweet dog and she's literally
chewed most of her bottom teeth out
because she was trying to get out of this
cage and had around him and she didn't
have any or very little teeth
at the bottom of her mouth.
So I go,
fuck this.
And stocks coming home with me.
How old was she?
She was about eight months old.
She was a beautiful dog.
We were like an alligator with,
with legs.
She was so sweet,
man.
She was such a sweet,
sweet dog.
Like she was so kind to people,
but she killed two dogs.
Kills,
kills,
happens.
That kind of dog.
You never hear about a
female killing a male dog.
That never happens.
But I can't go to the
dog pen and away with 17.
Dot.
Exactly.
I love today and I went to one those
puppy mills with your kids at the mall.
Yeah.
We walked in and you buy one?
No,
no,
you don't want to buy one.
But it's disturbing,
you know.
And just like,
uh,
maybe like 20 yards away
from the puppy mill.
They had a protest sign and a table set
up to not buy puppies from puppy mills.
You know,
this field was next to that.
How does that help?
That gets confusing
fucking to view things
like that.
It's like fucking Baskin Robbins.
There's a fucking bear table.
Save the email.
Say the way I was mended.
Pretzels become so popular.
I don't fucking like pretzels.
Cinnabon.
It's like if one type of food that you
can guaranteed always fine at the mall.
Pretzels,
Panda Express,
Cinnabon,
Mrs. Fields,
he's buttery ass pretzels.
Oh,
they show Kido kids in that
fucking malty there right now.
All this shit that people aren't
really that into Olivia eyeball.
Merciay but,
but you know what?
Walk,
kill zone.
This is one thing though.
People might ice back control.
Um,
but people might not
be into it,
but the smell is super powerful.
I lost it.
Oh God.
Oh custom.
Ah Fuck Man.
My cousin,
the round,
he's trying to keep it together.
This dude can ground and
Scott at the time though,
it's got a little time here and it does.
That was a good escape.
Escape.
He didn't have constructed that idea.
He let him spin out.
Wow.
Nice.
Get up.
How often it commentators call the truck?
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't think so.
This one of those weird positions.
Very few people.
Uzi Play
that game.
Oh Shit.
Oof.
Okay.
You had Alan Belcher
almost twist during Paris.
That and then Korean Zombie.
This dude is like,
yeah,
he's very thick.
What way does the 70 [inaudible] wow.
No lightweight.
What?
55 wow.
That's a giant 50 fiber.
That's ridiculous.
He must be for one.
But those two fights,
those two fights weren't
battles in the trunk.
Yeah.
There was no truck battles it,
they went straight to the twister.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
Don't,
don't go straight back.
Oh county with the series.
Tom's good.
Goudis at killer.
Piss out.
It's bad.
Damn fight.
Jesus.
This is good.
That's my boy.
Frank Grillo.
Purge three.
They're doing another PR.
You love the purge.
The purge grilled.
Glenn Criticizes the
game of death or Thrones,
whatever it is.
Hi.
Sure.
Came
a week.
You would love the purge.
Purge could Ratchye happen.
There are no fucking dragon go piece.
We can talk shit about you.
My boy right there.
Frank Grillo.
Go see Frank Grillo in the purge.
Oh my God.
I'm not thrilled with this season at all.
Man Thrones.
Oh my God.
The setting it up,
dude.
They said,
listen to this,
I'll call it.
There's these long on it,
but there's going to be some long periods
where they're setting up some chaos.
It's like the red wedding when
they went through the red,
where they set everything up and be like,
where's this going to
the Jesus when an Ngo,
like what and the rock.
Well,
no,
it's going down.
They only have two more episodes,
right?
Yes.
Two more episodes.
I liked it that the girl who,
the girl who has no name.
Yes,
she's becoming a savior.
She's gone through,
she's gone through the fire,
lit up,
says she heals up from getting stabbed.
Oh,
me too.
Me Too.
I can't take that many shots at the
stock came out after my surgery.
I'm thinking,
yeah,
bullshit.
Listen.
All I'm asking is just try a little magic.
That's when you give her a little match.
All got the actress had some fucking
magic dust and she had laying around.
They
took some huge,
huge steps.
John Snow coming back from the day.
That's,
that's,
that's almost show suicide.
They get away with it and here's why.
There's a rumor that Jon snow might be,
Hey,
easy with the fucking,
I want any spoilers.
No,
no,
no.
I don't want to hear it.
God Damn word.
You're saying no,
no,
no.
Don't you spoiled it.
You're right.
Yeah.
You son of,
I heard it.
I want to hear shit.
That's what,
that's what tell you something.
He's a good,
a good example of why
spoiler alerts fucking suck.
You know what I saw the other night,
man,
10 Cloverfield lane.
Good.
I say tweet up.
Shit.
It's fucking crazy.
Really?
Fuck the reviewers.
That movie was crazy.
I want to see,
because I saw it and loved it.
I loved it.
John Goodman's in that to John
Goodman is one of the best actors.
Amazing.
He's a boy.
Crazy motherfucker.
Think about him from the big Lebowski.
Think about him from this movie.
King rast to when he plays crazy.
He plays crazy at a level where I go,
this mother fucker knows what that means.
Remember him and Barney,
uh,
what was the movie?
The cones on the stones.
So not party Barton Fink,
Nice Barbie,
but Barton Fink,
he was an amazing party
ups crunk about that.
I love that movie.
Flintstone.
Barney rubble areas.
But he's,
he's a bad motherfucker,
dude.
I'm telling you,
he gets to this crazy place,
this edge of reality that you go,
wow,
damn,
I want to watch it.
To me,
he's so,
he seems so crazy that you like,
man,
you have to really be craziest.
This crazy.
This guy's ever,
he's felt those thoughts in his head.
Right?
You know,
that's the issue with that Brad Pitt,
like he plays like bad guys,
but I don't think he has
a bad thought in his head.
John Goodman does.
Johnny Johnny Depp too.
Obviously we all,
we should all hope that John Goodman
does very well in life and never fails.
It never gets to the point because it's
going to be in a position where he's in
a position where he's got nothing to
lose and he decides he wants to kill you.
That's right.
Because here's a thing that that guy
knows about and he puts it in these
characters that exists in his head.
He has has to water it.
He's got,
he's got a spree spree shooter
just dying to get size.
I'll just run.
Unless he's got a gun.
You gotta see this movie,
man.
He's still,
I'm posting it now.
I'm still marveling over Obama nfcs body.
I wasn't that thrilled
about the ending though,
man.
That was what?
Out of nowhere.
Let's not say a word about it
because I don't want it yet.
I'll thank you,
sir.
I'm all over that.
I want to see the [inaudible]
worried about this.
The other movies and Dale's Maxine,
Maxine,
Max Cina my tracing.
Right.
That's great.
I just saw Prometheans for the first time.
The movie's fucking dealt.
It's been out for,
so she
left me feeling like,
I don't know man.
The movie was so good.
Alien was so good.
The first one with Ridley
Scott and Tim Work of art.
Yes.
Yeah,
but aliens the best.
One of the best movies of all time.
But that's what I'm saying.
Set a high standard.
My man,
I know Bush,
I'd be entertained.
It was so good.
It was so good that like if you think of
this one as being like the prologue to
aliens,
is that what it is?
What's it called?
No,
it was pre previewed it a prequel.
The prequel.
What was it?
A prequel.
They're making another one to call.
Log is the right word.
No problems.
The end.
Yeah.
Well what happened in that
Dan was Prometheans set
before the alien movie guys.
It ended,
it was before,
right?
Because the got an alien.
Oh yeah.
Cause the aliens was
still fucking remember,
anytime we have those aliens,
those were some of the scariest
monsters the world's ever known.
God,
because when you think about bugs,
man,
you think about like a wasp,
like there was a fucking a yellow
jacket by my pool the other day.
I outweigh that thing by 1000000%.
He still terrified.
I was so scared.
I was horrified.
My kids are screaming,
pull up,
pull up the Japanese,
yellow wasp.
Brian told me about some wasp Pepsi walls,
but Pepsis
melt your face off the hawk,
the traditional hawk.
It's to trench the heart.
It's called the trash in
the Hawk because they,
they kill any trash.
If you get stung,
it is the most,
it's the most painful sting
in the animal kingdom.
Oh,
full down.
Yeah.
You're going to fall down.
You'll fall down.
You'll fall down that night.
It's like getting shot with a 45 I heard
a Guy Tarantula Hawk [inaudible] going
to be and they go back to that form
there in La and they're in Los Angeles.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Why?
Aha.
Brian talk about the guy died.
They're indigenous to la.
To Arizona.
Yes sir.
To Utah.
They're all over the
Americas in the trenches here
too.
That killed the trench on
my yard once accidentally.
I got out of my house
once is at nighttime.
I was walking towards my car and I heard
a crunch and I looked down and I had a
torrential this size of a
fucking blue crab under my foot.
I was like,
you gotta be
okay.
It was a huge tranche and
I'm barely exaggerate.
They're everywhere.
I'm barely exactly Laurie.
A little bit
bring up Japanese yellow wasp.
I'm telling you dog,
like some guy died from a
Pepsi was Pepsis Pepsi Cola,
Pepsi.
Oh Man.
He's allowed to change it.
Of course.
Junk on it.
Who Decides?
Here's names.
Here's the,
here's the NAC patty.
The fuck that's a Japanese yellow moss.
We get the syringes off their APP.
They'll melt your face.
Chappy knees,
yellow.
What?
The guy was doing a
weed whacker off walks.
A guy was using a weed wacker.
They thought he,
they were like,
that guy's a threat.
Six of them landed on his face,
melted.
His old face is fat.
Jay and he died.
He died.
Melted.
I went to heaven.
What do you mean by melted?
That melted.
Apparently the look
what it does to your it.
Each year.
Flesh.
They're going to have
any more questions.
Let's read this.
The Asian Horn
is nearly two inches long
with a three inch wingspan,
slightly smaller than the European Hornet,
but much more aggressive can
kill 40 bees in a minute.
Oh my God.
One Asian Hornet can
kill 40 bees in a minute.
A handful can destroy a hive of
30,000 bees in a couple of hours.
Any more questions by the way?
Five,
five Hundo.
Hey,
Thalie five Hondo to a nest.
Fuck these things.
They only live 55 days.
Have you ever seen if you ever seen the
video of them going through a bee colony
and chopping off all their heads?
You know what's weird?
I have to look at this.
I'm going to say they scare up intruders
by sending a lone worker horn to warn
them.
If that fails,
the workers attack on Mohs,
which is French for as masking group.
Do you know how bees figured
out how to kill them?
When one of those,
uh,
one of those workers gets into
their nest with bees will do.
Because now they know
what's going to happen.
They cover them and they overheat them.
Yeah.
They cover him and they beat their wings.
Smart little basket until they die.
Oh fucker.
They cook him.
Yeah.
Look at that poor person right there.
You can stylize that.
They have to do it.
They realize that that's the only
way to them to stop the assault.
God,
look at her.
Isn't that crazy?
Like somehow they got that information
that one of these fuckers comes in here.
You have to cover it and
heated up some iron man.
Three Shit.
Yeah,
it's nuts man.
Do you think that they fit?
Whoa,
I'll buy Marcy with the rear naked.
Do you think they figured that out?
Barely paid it.
Whoa.
Do you think or figure that out?
Because they just know that that's their
natural enemy and they just kill in
when they see him.
And if there's not a bunch of them,
they just do what they have
to do to try to kill it.
Or do you think they need to?
Yeah.
Do you think they know well?
Do you think they know that if
they don't kill it more coming?
I would imagine.
How the fuck did they
have to have learned?
They learned that.
Right?
So,
so when you kill crocodiles,
if they want to clear an area,
crocodiles,
if you,
this is really weird.
If you kill a crocodile and you kill
every crocodile that comes in that area,
after awhile crocodiles
will avoid that area.
They,
they will pass it down.
They'll pass that information
down to their brethren.
Yeah.
We don't even know.
They communicate.
They communicate well.
There's something going on.
Genetically passed elephants.
Elephants will remember watering holes
and droughts that they were exposed to
his babies 60 years ago.
So they'll,
they'll lead the entire herd to a
watering hole some 20 miles away.
That's insane.
Did you guys hear?
They're saying octopus of the smartest
animal now on earth more than us.
Not.
Hey,
easy.
I'll we're number one.
But they still Octopi?
No sharing the smarter than Dolphin.
He got it.
Why?
If they're smarter than Donald,
I'm really proud of we are.
They probably,
well,
I definitely saw the
[inaudible] see finding dory.
Fuck no,
I didn't see that.
But I did say to dad about how,
how powerful they are and how unusual
they are and that they're like,
they're almost alien.
They have more chromosomes in any
other animal that we've ever read.
Hearts what a fight.
And they can read the
attitude of personal,
like what they're trying to do
to him.
I heard they also can regenerate limbs.
They're smart.
Their eyeballs are like ours.
And the truth is,
I know they can read faces
on the podcast before know?
I'm just saying that the smartest animal.
Oh Wow.
She's getting strangle this human.
Oh Dude.
Like Nice segue to strong bomb RCA.
He's also very skillful,
super skill.
He's got the fatty or the
other guy's very strong.
Two biggest fears I've
ever seen in my life.
I was watching a video of a guy,
he's a human now.
I was watching video of a guy draining
a cauliflower ear and I was oppressed up
until I saw the syringe that they
pull that Eddie Bravo's body.
I'm like,
okay,
where'd they stick that?
They went through my stomach,
opened up my stomach,
pulled my guts to the side,
worked on my,
no,
when they do drains you,
I mean when they drain you.
Well,
when they sewed me up a week later,
it started swelling man,
and got really big.
I thought,
fuck man.
Maybe there's a 10 on the
last day and look at the name.
Maybe I had a hernia.
What is it,
black.
You went into the doctor.
I'm like,
something's wrong.
I got this massive swelling on the scar.
The scar healed,
but under it it was massive swelling.
That's fat.
It's all Koch Institute.
But that was all right,
right in my,
uh,
right above my desk.
Any serious question?
You got any more painkillers or,
I'm broke so many rules and
they're not even that good.
Oh Shit.
They didn't give you the right guy.
They didn't give you the good shit.
Norcos that's what's the norcos
that's like biking under some shit.
That ox council.
That's the goodest shit ever
chop up.
Y'All snort it.
Did.
A lot of people are texting me,
dude.
Be careful about those.
Oxies dome.
Horrible.
Terrible for your bond.
Worried about it.
Like fuck yeah.
Brendan governor not going to get
most addictive thing in the world.
Yeah.
Really?
I don't have a physically addictive body.
I don't get addicted to shit.
Cut down to Eddie was
shooting his eyes,
rolled back the oxy get you man.
You think I'd be a raging alcoholic.
I mean I've been,
I've been drinking since I was yeah.
Yeah,
that'd be good
for science.
I'm an alcoholic.
If you've been drinking
every day since you're a kid,
you didn't say every day.
Well that's what,
so you added every day and it made its
way to do it for comedy.
It's the way to do it.
I like to exaggerate.
Yeah,
no,
it's um,
it's definitely,
for some people it's obviously
like a biological thing.
Like when you can't sleep at night because
you can't get comfortable because you
got back surgery and you can't get,
you can't get,
it sucks.
You want to take whatever
the fuck I was taking.
Stars a death.
That shit work better than anything.
Joey,
Joey came by,
dropped me off a bag and
it doesn't kill the pain.
I never thought we'd kill pain for me.
I've never,
you know,
people say that all the time for me and
like it doesn't kill painting makes me
focus on the pain,
but then holy shit,
what happens is the pain still there,
but you're so,
you're so stoned that
you don't give a shit.
You just want to nap.
I'm like,
that ain't shit.
Then I started thinking,
what the fuck am I complaining about?
There's refugees that are sleeping on
cement and asphalt and fucking Ecuador and
shift.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I'm like,
all of a sudden I'm a king right here.
Has Right out.
Doesn't.
We'd make you feel like really thankful.
Yes.
Weed makes me feel super thankful.
Do you know what?
I think they buy every show better.
I can watch teen mom be blown away or not.
I can't believe you smoked
weed down that's there.
There's that night.
There are two things.
One is getting into,
it was only allowed to
talk over each other.
This is never going to work.
I like when I get into
a warm bed and I and I,
I know that nobody's going to be
knocking on my door to take me for a walk
because of my political point of view.
I feel lucky that I get
to sleep and then fuck.
This is what happens when you grow up
with like a super conservative family.
I ain't go night night Fox
News on right by your bed.
This is your favorite to be steeped in.
His big governments have always done
what they wanted to their people and we
live in America.
We walked in the Megan Kelly shows
on wake me up in a gated community in
Calgary,
but,
and then when I feed my kids,
I know it sounds weird,
but I have enough food.
I Brian waiting for it to end.
He,
he used to stay up because remember
we'll how TV's at one point in time,
they would just,
the TV would start,
they would know more shows.
Yeah.
It would just end and they would play
the fucking star spangled banner.
Brian would stay awake.
I can hold my heart.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you what I did.
Very good.
Rich.
I never used some CT.
He does.
Yeah.
Unfortunately.
They're saying,
hey,
a cool right there.
You know what he said?
Uh,
he said he got most of his real
damage from fighting in k one.
Yeah,
no shit,
Sherlock.
I mean,
he fought a lot of fights in k one and
he fought them really close together to
try and head real tough fights.
Man.
He fought some really
tough guys killing me.
Jerry Goodrich Goodrich fought the guy
who is the Krav Maga instructor for the
Israeli special forces.
New says big stud with Blue Eyes.
Is that the UFC?
Is that multi horrible,
awful memory to look at
this fucking bribing.
Anybody says about fucking
pot ruining your members.
How is Brock Lesnar going
to come back and fight?
Mark Hunt.
Isn't that insane?
I think.
I almost feel,
I really do almost feel
like UFC 200 is too insane.
I almost feel like it's so insane.
It's almost too much.
It's almost,
to me,
it's almost too much to
handle my weak ass bitch.
Hold school prides,
bitch heart can't handle it.
I agree.
It's too,
It's too much on twice a year.
Make a super bowl type car.
No,
that's almost too much slice.
Even the super ball.
It's telling you what if third lesson,
UFC history,
55% takedown accuracy.
Yeah.
If he takes,
if he grabs mark on his back.
That's true.
But still that's true.
That's like a percentage.
He's not,
not really.
No,
no,
no.
He's absolutely going to get tested,
but he's not a four week.
No,
no,
no.
He's exempt from the four
months in advance rule,
which means you have to be tested
up until four months in advance.
This deal came together so
quickly that they didn't make the,
they just,
just no way they could have that because
they weren't even talking to him four
months ago.
No,
it's true.
They weren't talking to them for doing
this fight for a month and you think
Brock literally went from zero saying
that zero chain didn't think he was in a
fight at all until four
weeks before we were like,
I'll take it.
I'm ta.
I'm saying that this deal,
like him getting signed to fight
did not happen until recently.
It was a very recent thing.
They were trying to make UFC 200
crazier after Connor and Nate fell off.
True.
This is where all this came from,
so they had to make this look.
I can't talk about it because I know too
much of the inside stuff of what they
had to do to make it work out,
but it was an ordeal.
This was an ordeal to pull
off the Nate Connor thing,
this Brock Lesnar thing,
isn't he?
Because he's still,
he's still wrestling for the WWE.
This is a,
this is a crazy deal.
It was not an easy thing to pull off,
so he's not going to get tested.
Why?
He's tested,
tested now,
like they're not going to test.
They weren't testing for months ago.
He's had like every
other person in the Zack,
he hadn't,
he's the exception.
But why did,
can I ask you,
why did Bryan,
I feel good point.
If you're going to make
exceptions for him,
he has to do it for other guys.
Well,
here's the deal,
right?
Here's the,
this is,
this is the argument against it.
The argument against it is you got to say,
listen,
if you want to make this legitimate,
you should have no question whatsoever
that your athletes are clean and
compliant,
and that means four months out.
But how are you not
going to make this fight?
Like if you were a promoter and there's
no way you can test the guy from four
months ago,
but you say,
listen,
we can test them right now.
We tested right now,
do we have an exemption queen?
Okay,
if he's on steroids right now,
we're fucked and we're done.
And his deals over,
right?
But if he's clean,
he says,
he's clean.
Let's fucking do it.
I get it for for entertainment
and pay per view,
it makes 100% but if you're going to say,
are you saying,
hey Connor,
we don't make it summons for anyone.
Brock Lesnar,
here's when exception and brother,
well that's it for the WWE battery,
but it's a different kind of essential,
make an exception though
because you're doing,
you're making an exception to what
happened in the past before the deal.
You're not making an exception as far
as like what you have to do from here on
out in terms of promotion and in terms
of what's agreed upon by the promoter and
the AF true.
But if every other what's agreed
to put buses just talking to him,
tell her what,
let's say I want to come back right now,
I have to give them a four month
advanced and they have to test me.
Or you are a big enough star
where they use their exemption.
So then so then the
fighter in the keynote,
no,
if you don't know that you're going to
fight until right before you're going to
fight,
like let's put it this way.
You don't think I would know before.
I'm not necessarily in favor.
You might be an impulsive person.
I don't know.
Okay.
Let's,
let's just say you're like Brendan Schaub.
You're,
you're a pretty crazy guy.
Yeah.
If someone came along and maybe
a year and a half from now,
you're fucking still Quito it up and you,
you and Tony Jeffries or hitting the
pads every day and you're feeling frisky
when you're rolling with Hanan Barao
and Gracie Hanan Barao that'd be fun.
Fuck mixing up my Brazilian.
Awesome dude.
So if you did that and you just said,
fuck it man,
I want to come back.
If the fighter and the kid blows up and
you're getting 20 million downloads a
month and everything is,
everything is,
everything is happy and
fascinating and you just go,
I need something else I need,
I need a fucking challenge.
I want to fight.
And then Dana white calls you
up and he's smoking a cigar.
The phone,
listen,
Hey Brendan,
crazy deal.
And then you just say,
fuck it.
I'm going,
I'm crazy.
Don't make that exemption.
Maybe they would if you
were famous as Brock Lesnar.
Yeah.
You listening to me,
Bro.
Fucking left it.
You got to make it.
I'm telling you are batshit crazy.
If you think Brockton,
oh,
he's gonna fight for it.
You might be correct also and
also Wue were guys on the torso.
He known for taking steroids.
It's a little fishy.
It is.
Well,
prove this.
It's definitely not ideal when you're
trying to promote this sport as being
absolutely tested,
right,
because you have this little weird
gray area that you'd introduced.
It's when I say entertainment
and sport as a fan,
it's all door.
No,
to not make this fight.
It is criminal.
I want to see it,
but I feel you my concern and tested,
yes he has.
I understand you for and I agree with
you and not mad at certain exceptions.
Then we it.
It's a weird gray area,
but why would Brock Lesnar,
I mean we all do have to diverse specs.
Let's take a moment aside.
How about a fucking round maybe log.
I'm not going to have a real life.
You're right.
There was a real man.
You got the script and
he was a real good dude.
Great Guy.
I always enjoy talking Kimbo.
Who's going to play Kimbo?
Annandale,
Robert Downey Jr and spray paint my face.
You could do like Jurassic Park.
You just get a computer to make images
of Kimbo and you get some duties were
really good at doing Kimbos.
You don't can't have an actor now.
You don't think so?
Got You.
Use a real computer
generated Chenko shy white.
No Perth.
How dare you?
No,
that's a good call out.
Nothing like that.
Last doctor in the world,
Michael Jackey pull it off.
Pulled up.
He pulled up Tyson.
He's tough.
He's good.
Pulled off.
Tyson.
Come on.
You don't think you pulled
off the types of spawn.
How dare he was fun.
I liked him in spawn deaf and by the way,
my
mind,
your p's and q's around in,
please
throw some bones.
Hey,
let's stop all that nonsense.
Michael Jai white is a cool motherfucker.
I'm a big fan.
Emma's a person and as an activist spawn.
He's a great dude or some
other guys couldn't do it.
He's built for it.
Certainly built for giant.
He's jacked as fuck.
Hey,
mind your p's and q's
around.
Fuck you.
I said,
man,
he's a good dude and a
real legit martial artists.
Yeah.
Michael Jai white came to legend
through a hopping side kick at the back.
Granted this bag,
the chain would break
all attorney turned shit.
No,
this one,
I don't even think it was a tough,
he's tough dude.
He's,
he's like you.
Sure?
I thought it was a hopping size.
Big Guy around either way,
whatever the,
the kick it was.
Don't say his name.
Scott.
Perfect technique.
Michael Jai white has
perfect kicking techniques.
His sidekick is like laser sharp.
He extends his foot.
He holds it out there and
pulls it back like legit.
Very high level black belts.
You kicked it off him.
Don't kill him.
So you mind a PS and qs.
If you see him in a bar,
you buy him a drink and
you thank him for his word.
Thanked them for snakes.
No,
you think forever.
Wait a minute.
Hold on a second.
Brian,
let me ask you this.
Do you think to you at 170
pounds of supple glory?
And I'm suppose I'm a leopard that
you can kick as hard as Shab Ken,
even though shove doesn't kick.
No.
I tried to
shop and I tried to,
yesterday,
yesterday I said to Brendan
shop and I was Kinda,
I was half serious.
We came out,
we did this real fun,
uh,
it's press thing and he grabbed
me around my torso and I said,
oh,
my back,
my back please.
And I tapped immediately and then I said,
I got something happened.
Maybe it was too much coffee,
maybe it's too much coffee.
And I said,
and I was half serious,
maybe even 70% of years
ago I was a wrestler.
I don't like the way,
I don't want like the way it came out
in the middle of the [inaudible] the way
it came out to me,
by the way.
Yeah.
I'm a man and by the way,
who's shaped my box.
I played tennis.
I said,
if I didn't want you to,
you're not getting me in a,
in a body lock.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Well.
Well Mike,
tell me what you do with your thought.
Hey,
he put his phone and wallet on top of
his car on top of my car and I can go in
the top.
I put my phone on my
wallet on top of the car,
Joe.
And then we engage,
we engage.
I tried a couple of arm drags.
I I get some risks.
Control,
I get some risk control.
Yup.
He,
he tries to,
he tries to head head me.
He tries to kind of throw a headlock.
Ami.
I pull my neck,
I bowl my neck and then,
and then he got two on one on my wrist.
He got both his hands.
And when I say look,
I see,
cause he goes,
Ooh,
let me get to I one.
That's a big mistake.
He whispered.
And then I felt,
I felt his explosive power and he put
me into a body and then I began to
immediately squeal like a pig.
This is the best part.
And then I go light bro,
I'll meet you at the lunch place.
He drives off,
leaves his phone and on top of his
car and he ran over to his IFO.
See this thing I sure did
it as an objective person.
This is why this is so disturbing to me.
I know what I can do to you and
then I know what he can do to me.
That doesn't,
that doesn't make sense to me.
Well,
I'm a good,
I'm like,
I've gotten a hold of you before.
Relatively helpless.
Good rest
the apple and they charge them
a thousand dollar mistake.
He goes,
Bro,
it's worth $1,000 worth five grand.
You got hustled and iPhone.
I mean,
how could you really think
to you who grapple with it?
Because I'm a good cause I'm,
I'm good on my feet and this is weird.
I know it is sad.
Do this.
I'm going to stick to my guns and I'm
going to say a time when you tried to pull
my bow back
though,
you know that bow that I
shoot a hundred arrows.
Who is that?
There was a brick wall that like,
God,
it just,
it just was not moving it.
But listen,
Bro,
I don't matter.
I'm having a line.
I don't remember.
What you're talking about
is a strangeness to this humor
because I know part of it is humorous,
but the strangeness is
There's a Whisper of truth.
Like this one,
I am 100% convinced that shop is too big
and too strong for me to grapple with
him.
But you're not.
No,
no,
no.
I have
a little bit,
see if me and Shabazz,
Roland,
I'm thinking how long can I,
your phone?
Yeah.
And whether or not I can,
if it's impossible to get him so tired
and to survive long enough that I could
catch him.
Yeah.
So getting him to get,
I'm so tired because he's so much bigger.
Yeah.
And he's so strong.
And by the way,
I like to stick my finger in
the cage and poke the bear.
I think that's what,
that's weird.
But that's the weird thing is like,
I don't think you're totally aware
and I am what you can and can't.
No,
I'm very well might be like,
no,
it's not true.
No,
no,
nope.
I'm very aware of how badly I
could get beat up and I felt it.
I felt that I'd been putting
bad positions by him,
by other guys,
by boxing,
all that.
Like hugged Dan Henderson.
Oh,
awesome.
Very uncomfortable
feeling he's made of wood.
Shake him.
So funny that you say that.
That's exactly what Ryan Parson
who trained him forever said,
he said he would have to do like deep
tissue on like rub them down after a
fight.
He said he'd beaks hostage.
He's like,
he's made out of a different thing.
He's got a semi,
he's got a simian strength.
There's nobody more.
Uh,
he's just,
he's got his head,
everything about him before.
Fucking Hector Lumbar,
the guy,
he just fought that guy at hand.
I actually think Dan Henderson,
you get a title shot.
Oh,
I hope so.
And believe me,
the kid was not,
I'm not the kid.
You're the kid.
That kind of the kid.
What?
What did I know?
It's key to meet me person.
I was lobbying for me.
I called Dana Up.
I said,
dude,
let's talk about this.
Really come on and then I text you.
Is that for real?
No,
I'm just trying to hype this thing up.
What could be a better,
more exciting fight?
Bisping Hendo too.
And they both walk away.
They both walk away.
You got Wyman.
Rockhold I feel like Jocko Ray
as a fan is disappointing
me that he doesn't just step
aside and let this way as
a God damn.
Get the fuck out the way.
I agree.
Chuck array,
your Nax Bro.
100% you sit down for lift weights.
I probably won't be like drug tests.
You felt like,
oh well he's got to have sworn that
dude fucking yoga to
fucking whatever you lose.
Just let this fight happened please.
And then your next.
I agree.
And then Weidman and
Rockhold have a rematch.
Come on belt.
Both guys just lost Weidman
wanted Rockhold wants it.
Come on.
Some no interim belts to be thrown away.
Too many interim Butano busy Dan.
They both retire after
that fight for the belt.
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
Jocko Array Weidman.
This guy's Chakra.
This guy looked at stained glass
and got a tattoo or statues of all,
he's a radio guy.
Really?
Yeah.
Full time.
He's got a morning show,
I believe,
by the way.
Seen really good guy.
Really Nice guy and fucking tough guy.
And you know who he is?
He's a the hockey enforcer.
This mother fucker's had like 270 hockey.
Wow.
Cocky though.
It was in the NHL either
when talking about not NHL.
Really?
No,
I don't think.
Are you sure?
I'm almost positive.
Yeah.
Okay.
Evan,
the cub is balls deep in hockey.
And he said he never played Nhl.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
So either way.
Either way.
A hockey hockey's insane.
He's been winning fights.
This guys the worst.
How many fights in the UFC so far?
Jamie?
No,
he just two in one,
right?
You've got knocked out his first one.
Then what?
His last one.
He took his first fight on
short notice and got stopped.
Start someone who stopped him.
Oh,
Tiago Santos.
Telco Santos.
He's one in one in the,
but then he beat change to
Hoonah to Hoonah is legit man.
Knocked them out.
Not Fast.
52 seconds.
Look at his fucking fights.
30 strides.
52 boom.
Oh,
this one's someone's getting knocked
out and O'connell's gangster.
It's got power.
Hit Him with the stain glass son.
O'Connell got pals.
The stained glass in the cities use the
holy ghost power and he stays in the
pocket of Tada.
I don't like what he's doing.
This pull up his,
his very Jane.
Very Roman Catholic.
That stained glass tat too.
I've never seen before.
The problem.
It's an issue.
Let's go ahead and get the tans sick.
Let's go ahead and tell him the US.
Celebrate that Shit.
Yeah.
One guy's got a tan that's
someone's getting knocked out.
This fighting going past this.
That gets geyser.
Someone's going to get tired.
Does that is an odd choice of tattoos,
but that's coming from a guy who has odd
fucking
sang glass
dude.
How tough is boss?
Wow.
It's hanging in there.
[inaudible] hand boss,
Beautiful Tan.
Fucking 10 and then candidates here.
Let him back up and do it again.
100% oh man.
Keep beating on him.
We talked about this guys almost done it.
Just in my experience in the octagon,
you don't have stained glass tattoos.
Bride come out against the character.
When you're up,
you got a chance.
When you're down,
you're only punching up,
right?
God,
that guys,
it's hard.
Then we can recover.
The pause is tough.
He just took Sue's O'connell,
man.
Oh,
Kyle's got a nasty you left hand,
man.
He's just tough as shit.
He's just one of those Irish fucks that
just doesn't want to use of stained
glass tattoos and the toughest fuck.
You don't get that stuff
very is it?
I seen his name wrong.
Bossy,
Bossy boss has got some big legs.
Why am I thinking it's boasting?
The sercos.
Maybe we should change it.
Powerful.
10 boxes.
Let's go ahead and look at
the thoughts on this kid.
Look at bossy size.
Let's call them the Bosi.
The boats.
Just call him the boss.
No,
it was common.
His real name or who get mad?
You think just double leg.
I'm jail.
Oh God you can't.
Those are some big legs.
That's hard to look at.
How big his likes to tell you
right now if this fight was on ice,
your boy's phone.
That is an interesting thing,
man.
About hockey players.
Man,
they develop some serious bowels.
Tags him again.
Oh.
Cosmin doing.
Oh he's,
he's ending his combinations with
that left hand and that's where balls,
he's getting caught.
Yeah.
He's,
he's stolen in a nice lunches
in bunches and it's land.
It's also is his accuracy is really good.
My boss,
he's moving,
catching,
moving back.
Catching.
Yeah.
Catching him moving back.
That's,
you know,
that's not easy to do.
That's how the timing,
his tattoo artist might
want to call up Aaron dove,
Adobo Guru Tattoo San Diego.
My clean the shit up.
More colored dog.
Like a Crayola box on that bites skin.
That's one good thing
that white people have.
I know I can't do color.
White people could do some
amazing people like look,
if you are working a serious albino,
you could have some beautiful
colors and I know I have no cure.
A white piece of paper,
you know,
like blank canvas,
black twos.
They could,
well they can put tattoos
everywhere though.
And around somehow or another it's,
it's like a subtle thing.
They should do white ink though.
It just doesn't take the
skin and it doesn't work.
Now it looks sick.
Oh,
I see what he asked you
left hands to the body.
But you know,
it's interesting that the black guy
covered in tattoos is a fairly new thing
culturally in this country,
right?
Rappers.
Athletes.
Yeah.
I mean,
but it's so common now.
It's interesting how it took off.
Like if you looked at black guys
from like Muhammad Ali's error,
Joe Frazier,
but then look at like Deontay wilder.
Yeah,
you're right.
So many guys like that.
How many gang tattoos were subversive
up until really the nineties saint?
I mean,
you know,
yeah.
Body art was always considered subversive
and weird decoration and you had to
be,
you know,
kind of on and you had to be a criminal
or like something or something.
You know,
you had to be on the outskirts
of society to have a tattoo.
Even in the hearing.
I remember I told my dad,
I got an earring as a joke when I
was 65 I'm on the phone like it go.
I didn't parental,
he thought it was,
he's a bully that we're talking about.
You're trampling on my sensibilities.
It's used sometimes when people
just arguing with each other.
If one person's right,
he's a bully.
Damn boss,
boss take down.
That's when he knows shit.
Hit the fan.
I don't know man.
He's kind of mix it up.
Let's try and mix it up.
These guys taking crazy shots to the head.
Bullies.
Damn that Tattoo.
So color white people.
White fucking peak off of campuses.
Do I love tattoos?
A lot of white people get the Red Tet,
the the red ink these days.
I see girls with reading
because that's iconography.
That shit.
God Damn boss,
man,
there's that left look,
Sam,
Jesus Christ God and he's super dorm.
Incredible,
incredible,
powerful.
Tam.
God Damn it.
Look at it isn't though is it's so,
but he can't breathe.
That left hook broke.
That knows for sure.
I don't know.
Hockey might have done that.
I probably hockey right?
Hockey's some rough fucking dude's
thinking about how many games they play,
the cardio I used to,
I used to train with some
professional hockey players.
They are fucking gangster.
They also party harder than
any professional athlete.
I know.
Think about how stupid noses are.
So weak ass little structure and how
stupid all someone has to do is smash it
and you,
you're like down to like 60% strength.
All they have to do is destroy that thing.
Do you think our noses are
meant to be smashed though?
Well why is there like that and this
world full jazz shows chimpanzees they got
strong knows it's trap
punching a giraffe bitch.
It's odd.
Eyes.
Eyes are wide and kip
really break a cat's nose.
Can you know he could punch a
house cat right in the face.
It will kill you and your sleep made made
to kill you with its face and they're
no.
Well their noses are all wet.
Hold these guys.
Oh my God.
It's funny.
He's fucking boys.
Oh.
Cobbles basketballs in trail.
Coddles about to go O'Connell.
And when one of these guys
shoots where I take down,
it's,
you know,
it's go time.
But college took a big deep breath too.
That was,
he looked at shots not good for his head.
Please don't go to them.
That's either these guys grabble.
It's interesting when you see a guy
come back while he's hurt because like
that's what you find out,
what kind of condition.
You're really correct.
How quickly can you come
back while you're hurt?
Yeah.
Do you ever see the training fatal
you do you like to drink wobbled?
No.
He would fly around in circles like use
punch and then spar or do running and
shook.
It was nuts.
Hey Man,
but he needed that.
He needed get that shit
off against Maldonado.
Well,
you know he's a tough guy that paid off,
but I don't like the way
he approached that fight.
This is a guy who went
toe to toe with cop.
Okay.
I don't know what kind of
testing they had him under.
Do you do your yeah.
None.
Yes sir.
Now you fucking kidding me right there.
Kay.
It looks,
it's like Novitsky likes
it called the smell test.
He didn't,
he smelled like Beo
and kettle bells to me.
Yeah,
it does smell like any steroids.
I still like cabbage and potatoes.
He looked like shit,
man.
He's so close.
Come to the UFC.
I don't give a fuck.
It's not 2007 you get eight
the fuck up before this fight,
I would have argued with you or no.
Maldonado exposed him
in in a bit of a way,
but it also could be that he hasn't.
What was the last time you competed?
How long ago was his last fight?
Not that far.
Fargo Hoodie fife out that
chump and beat the fuck out.
I'm like right.
They beat up some scrub.
Right.
So was it a scrub you
thought make you work in,
in Russia,
but he got paid to go
down the line in the show.
Oh yeah.
He was to fight.
Get to fucking fights.
Yeah.
Before that is old.
But he should know.
He took that guy down and
punched him until he tapped.
It was in December.
Yeah.
It was a terrible fucking fight.
He's not fighting anyone.
So you come to come to the UFC,
hey,
we're going to test you unless your bank
colors and these guys are to get fucked
up.
So a boss,
he's got,
oh,
call my ground or all
them I got bottle's fine.
Oh my God.
This fights crazy.
Oh Wow.
Oh Oh.
Meaning he's gonna Finish him.
I think it come calm.
Strong.
It keeps that half card will keep
it to half guys got the under hook.
Oh,
bossy with his own under
hook on the legs stops.
It stops a pass.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
okay.
Oh Shit.
What?
Bossy willing.
This fucking fight.
Damn.
Bossy is tough.
It's dude so fucked up.
This is a war.
The Tan Jeremiah Wallace is the one it
looks like he should be hopping out of a
cares.
Bossy looks like it's not bossy wash.
Don't fucking do it.
I said,
did you say what keeps me?
Cake boss is the one with
the whole Kogan skin.
The hot dog skin.
Yeah.
That's him on top.
Hot Dog skin is hilarious,
man.
His best looking guys have hot dogs.
They all have hot dogs.
Whole cloak.
Ian Looks like dude.
Hot,
dark skins.
The best expression ever.
Why did you come up with
that for a while ago?
A while ago.
It's beautiful.
There's a few a few descriptions in
my life that have really sunk home.
Oh Shit.
Oh bossy with the hammer fist.
Connell's in trouble,
man.
Yeah,
he's in trouble.
Carl's losing this fight.
Toss these in a lot of trouble right here.
Exhausts for sure.
One and one.
I mean you say he's losing his fight,
but this is a draw.
I mean he's in trouble.
No,
I agree.
I think if someone said,
hey shot bet on this fight,
I got bossy.
Okay.
[inaudible] fucking never know
what the dude local O'Connell.
He's just so God damn tough.
It's a way to survive
either one of these guys.
Well posses one and
one one 32nd knock out,
one 59 second knocked out and the
way he survived that onslaught,
I mean his head snapped back,
his eyes rolled back and bounced off
the ground and you still got back up,
but she'd be jumping out of the cake.
Authorization for Lumbar.
This hill is not a lot of Jujitsu.
Jujitsu here.
He just went to the hundred
percent control the puzzle.
It's just,
I wish they would stand up and
blast each other in the face.
It sound like a fan of the tab out.
He's got giant.
Here we go.
What's the new tap out
shirt firing the kid.
Oh my God.
You're right.
They're everywhere.
They are everywhere.
I see him all the time on my shows.
Oh Shit.
[inaudible] needed the body.
This dude,
you got that fucking
coward guy wearing one.
Yeah.
Calling card that he loves us.
I know he loved the series.
He liked the three these hearings
is that guy's a big deal.
I know.
Or to support his name.
Colin cowherd and he's a good guy,
man.
Famous to talk.
Look,
if I know who you are,
you're famous and you watch
that show religiously,
right?
Yeah.
He's my favorite.
He's good man.
Guest ask good questions.
Just smart guys.
Objective gun.
Yeah.
I can't believe you posted,
but that other guy that's like
a really famous guy there.
Skip Bayless.
There's a CEO guy,
Neil Patrick.
Yeah.
I think that guy's show recently.
Really?
I'm surprised you did that show.
Well,
I was doing like a tour for the UFC.
It just seemed like a nice guy too,
but he definitely didn't
seem like he knows a lot.
I don't know shit about fighting.
No.
Well,
you know,
you ask good questions.
He's a professional.
Yeah.
Oh,
super professional.
He's one of the best,
a lot of them bring on UFC because
they realize it gets ratings,
but they don't know about the sport.
But he was asking me questions like,
what's,
who's the most legendary
MMA fighter of all time?
Well,
excuse me,
so it's pretty general.
I said,
well,
I know,
but I said,
I went with [inaudible].
I said like,
he was straight.
Who was the most important
one of those things?
Who's the biggest star?
Like I said,
he's crazy because he was the original,
cause he changed everything about Ms. Dot.
Pioneer who's the Bruce Lee of a sport,
change everything about martial arts with
his victories because everybody had to
go,
wow,
what is he doing?
And then we had to learn it.
Correct.
Changed it.
That's fair.
Yeah.
I mean obviously it was his whole family
and his is his uncle and his dad and
yeah,
dude,
I,
I had to do a short,
I had to do a,
uh,
a tribute showed us,
Kimbo slice for spike dude.
They were,
they would ask me like the,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm only t I'm going to get flack for
this with asking me for the Mount Rushmore
and I see can't be up there without
Kimbo slice for what he did on Youtube.
Stuff like that kick to the body.
Dude,
I started crying so bad is fucking,
I don't know if they're going to
what they're going to do with it but,
well I wouldn't agree with that
as far as I'm Mount Rushmore,
but I would definitely agree with it as
far as like a guy who is super important
for the overall picture,
MMA is end.
The difference between like fighters in
a May fighters and then a guy like Kimbo
who was a backyard fighter with
den became a legit MMA fights.
There is a significance is the idea that
you can be somebody in your backyard
and if you,
if you have the skills or
the personality or something,
the magic,
you can make it to
knock them out.
Spinning back fist,
the candles on queer.
Oh Wow.
Oh my God.
Crazy fucking white people,
man.
Fuck.
Keep going.
Don't take it up a breather here.
Yeah,
don't do that chaos.
Oh my God,
this is crazy.
Oh,
nice left.
It's got a very nice left hand.
Yeah,
he does.
He's been landed on the mixes it up
between like a half a jab and a hook.
It's like Michael Jai Smith or whatever.
He said sharp white Chai White.
I met John Michael J.
Smith.
Tom Smith is my name.
Hey Dude.
Hey Dude,
dude.
I'm about Jason's dude.
Mind your p's and q's around.
When is Tony Baltimore fight
and Hubby even over men off.
No,
Ferguson.
Ferguson different.
You fucking get the wrong right.
Oh Shit.
That's good.
I kept,
oh,
we're throwing spinning shit.
Huh?
Greatest Nick Diaz quotes of all time or,
oh,
we're throwing spinning shit.
Oh my God.
They were going to high five again.
Bossy is like loving function,
high fiving and kill it.
He's enjoying himself.
This is the time it was my boys.
He can't keep high fiving.
He looked,
dude,
that guy looks fucking fresh.
Look how good a shape he is.
In third round.
He's moving light on his feet
and he's eight some shots.
Who calls noses in pieces.
It's a mess,
but look at Bossy.
He's nice movement.
He was moving around.
He's also catching his breath right?
Oh Man.
He's punching.
Well,
fight is fucking crazy.
Some rock 'em sock.
'Em Dude,
this guy's Kennedy for fight of the year.
My wrong,
my God.
There's like rocky fairly brawler.
I'm swimming.
I'm three wines deep.
I don't know Joe,
but from the three wine glasses.
Yes,
you're right.
Certainly the brawl here.
Oh,
when was Roy Rory,
Rory and fucking,
that was a while ago though.
That was a year ago.
I think this fights like this.
I think we should all have a
button at home that we can press.
We just say no decision.
No one can lose.
This can lose this fight we're
going to make America just spoke.
Neither one of you guys.
There's no way.
The night bonus for sure.
Unless someone stops someone.
If this fight ends right now,
the way this is going,
how the fuck do you pick a winner?
This God damn fight.
It's not fair.
I don't know how easy life within fair.
It's a draw.
How do you feel that he
cut?
It's easy.
You've got to do any money,
man.
Wow.
God,
I don't want to hear
you say Michael's here.
White again.
Don't bring it.
Don't put his mouth.
Put his name in your mouth cause
you just mind your p's and q's.
Throw strikes.
You could look at total strikes,
obviously.
Round one and round two.
One,
one.
[inaudible].
One,
one for Bossy,
but you can't just calculate
all the strikes all together.
Oh,
that's a store that's right there.
He should both make an agreement.
No wrestlers still gangster in it.
Look at this.
Get this out on the break.
Look at what the cloud boss.
Hey boss.
Say 50 50 seconds left here.
I'm going to both set enough can stop it.
Now these guys are friends after this.
This is not an ironic,
every time they see each other,
they hug each other for
the rest of their lives.
Eh?
It depends who wins.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
nobody's winning.
Oh No,
the one.
I bet you money.
Boston wins this fight.
Really?
You want to bet?
Oh con terminate I believe.
I believe.
I believe that I bought say won,
but he's fighting in Canada
should be going to bed over there.
Eddie,
you're pretty quiet.
Oh you want to bet right now?
Yeah,
I got best bet right now.
Ten thousand fifteen thousand
truckloads a shirt on,
bro.
I think that surgery's only
give you the free pass.
This is
my God.
Oh fuck.
Now he got buzzed a well fuck.
I got by say too,
cause I cause the peer
pressure back to Kimball.
All I was saying is what he did because
he brought in the average fan from
youtube to mixed martial arts.
That's why he's a big deal.
Even when I fight,
my mom knew who Kimbo was
from the youtube videos.
I definitely see that.
That's all I'm saying.
I definitely see he's an important figure.
I just wouldn't say it's
only like four or five.
No,
my Mt.
Rush voice.
Oh horses.
One boy's supposed to be five I think.
I believe so.
Yeah.
I forget who was supposed to be number.
Fuck.
How about we put Ronald motherfucking
Reagan and it and say it's done.
I'm not mad at that.
Oh man,
man,
Ronald Reagan Bitch,
you in a movie with a monkey.
We kind of like just say no,
I'm a Reagan Fan.
I don't care what anybody says.
He's right.
He's a [inaudible] news.
Put me off to sleep when he was a ties.
Tim Fox News Guy.
I'm just,
I'm a real is for right.
I love saying that,
but I thought there might have been a
fifth or maybe they were thinking about
that name.
The four Brian,
you fucking better be
and named the 40 years at
Mount Rushmore.
What does is this Johnny
Depp and a motorcycle?
No,
John Depths off everything,
man.
I can't be him bitches and do commercials.
There's no clip of Ronald.
I'm going to go with Washington.
They blink him.
That's not him.
Joe.
I'm going to go totally times like
I don't think that you can't have
Teddy Roosevelt.
That's four.
There's only four and Lincoln.
Is that right?
I think he's right.
You guys.
Ancient
history doesn't matter.
I can't believe I got it.
I got lucky on that one guy.
So if you're like an MMA,
you got hoists,
Gracie,
for sure.
Chuck Liddell.
Um,
have you got shocked to Dale?
Do you have to have rampage?
See that's why he can't have a,
you can't have a t.
Dot.
Anderson Silva.
Mandy contempt of Randy.
You have to PSP.
You have to have GSP.
And he got an answer in Silva.
Bj Penn got Kimbo got a Bj Penn
gotta be so he got a lot of,
how many guys are though?
That's too many.
Let's say there's no way I'm going
to have fatal on the cro cop.
Oh yeah.
You got to have faith or for all time.
Wanderly on that bitch.
100%.
Fuck you.
And Megan my shoulder.
I was just going to say
that and maybe even Ninja.
How dare you come on.
Really.
Joplin legends Ninja for,
we tried to fight surgery Keratan off.
It was a bad motherfucker.
Years to probably compared to Shogun.
That's true.
His preface,
it shows this is crazy.
Accomplished.
Oh,
Boson text.
That's awesome.
Hard loss.
Yeah.
You know what man,
we Canada,
that's a hard loss,
man.
That's a hard loss.
At least you see that sweet
tattoo kind of was a bad month.
Europe you or mean
being dead shit is sick.
I wish my brownness could get that color.
I feel very uncomfortable
about coming here and this.
That's how I look at this.
That's a caramel.
Rob Did not want a fifth face to be
carved in 1936 can be handled by the Susan
B.
Anthony should be out a bunch of
fucking guys trying to get laid.
But Susan B.
Anthony that Mount Rushmore,
she was a suffragette
look.
Terrible people.
That's what's wrong with them.
But she was the first feminist.
This boom,
boom.
You can't have her look at this.
Boom,
look at this one left and then this
is the one that shuts the lights off.
You got to,
yeah,
I mean the dude one lounge to him.
Is that a ten eight round?
He's so tough.
And so he said,
that's gotta be ten eight
it has to be attending.
Well,
I don't know what is and isn't anymore,
man.
I don't know.
Who knows what these fucking rafts judges,
but it's,
I don't think it's done.
I don't think it's done the right way.
I don't think we should
have a 10 point system.
I think it should be like a hundred
points or something like that,
or 30 points or this should be a bunch
of points where it's not ten nine and
half,
10 at night.
Especially with the
grappling and the submission,
it doesn't make sense.
Especially if I'm get off my back and
I'm constantly having the guy in danger,
or if I'm a counter restaurant is not
saying we disagree with this decision.
Right.
I'm not going to disagree with it.
You know?
Like I said,
it was an awesome fight.
Winds deep.
I don't know,
could easily finish only MMA.
There's no submission.
Do you feel wait,
grow.
What if you had,
what if you had grappling
judges and striking Joe?
How much of MMA judges fuck all that.
Right,
but what if you had x fighters as judges?
That's what you have.
Here's what you want.
You Want Matt who judged for pride?
Yeah.
Matt Hume is who you should have judging.
Yeah,
you should have gotten his own.
It's a handful.
Understand like Dwayne,
Dwayne Ludwig is another great example.
You know,
and have people that have a
full understanding of MMA.
Bj Penn was the judge of his knowledge
of anatomy or all think of amazing rich
Franklin,
rich Franklin,
Jens Pulver.
Think about how many great
fighters that don't fight anymore,
but have a deep knowledge
of MMA would be judging.
Why are they not?
Why did they,
he's better than who data.
Why don't they,
why don't they reach out to those guys?
Well,
there's commission
that's part of the [inaudible]
some mother fucker.
This was a date with my boyfriend,
right?
That's big and hits hardest.
Does Jujitsu man underrating
two as of lately.
But I was impressed when he fought Ben
when he fought Ben and almost caught him
in an arm bar from the bottom.
And I was thinking that [inaudible]
is a crafty guy that doesn't sit still
fighting a long time,
but he keeps getting better.
That's hard as fuck.
Definitely does.
He doesn't rest on his laurels.
And if you watch him fight now
he fights much more technical.
He doesn't unload like big bombs.
So because of that,
well he does.
We'll still has that with Ben.
He caught Ben and he hit
him with like a sauna.
Upper cuts.
Yeah,
but he's been fighting more technical
but then he's harnessing that tower.
Yeah,
he's getting,
he's up that trend now.
Fought for title Anderson in his prime
fun was my boyfriend so he can squat shut
up.
It is a tough really is.
It's a tough fight for both guys.
Donald is no joke at one
70 like him has more tools.
Yup.
He's,
he's nasty off of his back.
His kickboxing is legit as fuck.
He wants to see what steers kicks.
You know what scares me is Donald,
when he fights good boxers,
struggles cause cause and even Donald,
Mitzi,
he goes,
I go forward or backwards.
I don't take any angles.
And when you're facing a
guy who has good boxing,
you're in trouble,
man.
I hear a guy like him say that and I
got to assume that he's working on that.
I've got a suit hope telling you that,
that he's trying to get better at it,
but you always got to,
you got to kind of guess where a guys
that based on his previous performances.
So if you look at his
previous performance,
like Nate Diaz was a really
troublesome fight for him.
He had a really hard time,
particularly in the first round.
What can they do?
Bosses actually well,
but I also think there was some emotional
stuff going on in that because Nate
talked him into a coma a hundred percent
Nate knocked his hat off and cow,
he's a nice guy.
Like if you see cowboy when he
was lining up to fight Kobe,
like the weigh ins,
they're real friendly.
Cowboy's a real friendly guy.
He's a really,
really good guy.
He's a really good guy.
So he doesn't want,
he doesn't need or want to hate.
You didn't need animosity.
But I think Nate,
Nate really got in his head
with that shit and it was like,
wow,
a lot emotional.
I
mean this guy was like,
Nate,
Nate's super disrespectful
when he's gonna fight you.
And it's part of the strategy.
It makes it personal.
Yup.
And to make you think about it because
it makes your emotions ramp up and makes
you tight.
Mentioned me making mistakes.
It makes you make mistakes.
Brilliant.
Very smart.
They're brilliant at it.
Well it Connor,
we get caught that,
you know,
he's great at that.
Do you like that?
Cause I,
I go back and forth man,
because I've seen you like
do I like well Joe's a Aldo.
I love shit talking when
it's done really well.
But you know what I don't like is it seems
like a lot of people are trying to do
that now that weren't doing
or you know why though?
Because the guys who do it or make it
more money and they're getting more fame.
So now guys,
it's not in the personality.
It's on their demeanor
and their trying to do it.
It's like God damn that is fake.
This is not good.
But that's what you,
that's what you get when you award that.
Yeah.
Cause everyone mimics
the same as NFL mimics.
Everyone mimics willing
to trade off like the Tan,
uh,
support for,
for cash.
That's what it really is.
Cause,
why don't you start talking,
but if it's not your channel,
generally guys,
people aren't into that.
Generally it turns people off and
they generally like it makes it,
makes headlines about that headache.
Conor never turned anybody off nail named
the most famous fighters in the world.
Floyd Mayweather,
the most biggest shit.
Talk about time.
Conor Mcgregor Shit talker Brock
Lesnar Shit Tacos and think about it.
Connor put everything together.
He had incredible performances and he
talked match combination on who's great at
talking shit.
Not that great of a fighter,
a good fighter,
but he wasn't good enough
to be a world champion.
Came so close against Anderson.
I know Joe,
but what got me to the point,
that shit talking the shit talking but
also the performance is getting Nate,
Nate Marquardt,
you can't,
you can't say that.
That was [inaudible] with his shit.
Talking bout some dudes.
Definitely no chills.
Phenomenal.
Phenomenal athlete.
Great fighter.
I'm just saying that with his
personnel and his shit talking,
it elevated him.
But yeah,
I think when a guy like
Conor does something that he
did knock out Josie Aldo in
13 seconds,
hold it.
He's a different,
it's a different thing.
I agree.
Like his performances,
he,
his,
his wins were a different thing,
but then it backfires
because when you lose,
he'll get look at Rhonda and full.
Yeah.
So that brightened up,
that's the price.
But you know what?
Fuck it.
You make that money in your bank account.
Guys like Randy couture,
when he loses,
people are like,
fuck,
you're still a bad motherfucker.
Like no one true.
No one hates him.
You don't.
Those Randy couture days are over.
My brother Connor changed the entire game.
There's a lot of guys
fighting anymore.
But if he was,
but do you understand that if George St
Jersey appears is a beautiful man who's
a great fighter,
doesn't catch so much spot on,
he's respectful,
he wears nice suits.
He would still sell like crazy today.
I still sell like crazy.
He came up today and he was,
cause he was a huge star before onsite
named someone right now who's currently
fighting UFC who's quiet
and as a superstar.
That's interesting.
Well,
you really,
there's the superstars
are Randa Kahn and tough.
Jon Jones is like on the
brink of superstardom.
If Jon Jones can you get past [inaudible]
and they get record numbers for UFC
200 and becomes a gigantic event.
John Jones at the door because he,
because he has great talent but he's
also in the headlines for bat shit.
He's making headlines.
But sometimes that,
I mean if you want to talk about like
what makes someone a famous person,
sometimes that's almost as important
and it's goofy societal agree as someone
being a shit talker or look at a guy
like couldn't remake your headline.
Is Uriah Faber Shit talker or not?
I don't think he is.
I think he's super honest.
He's an old school.
He's an old school guy.
Uriah faber talking
about an upcoming fight.
He never,
he's an old school guy.
That's not huge drawl anymore.
Eddie,
he's an old school guy.
He's from the old [inaudible] right
favors still right up there and there's a
reason why they had Uriah versus Dominick
Cruz and it wasn't just cause your
rise been doing really well.
It was also because they know you're Ryan
can sell some fucking hundred percent
California.
Super Nice.
His name or a superstar
who doesn't talk shit.
That's all I'm saying is
your I have favorites.
Yeah,
but he's old now.
He's been doing it.
You're out of favor.
And let's define superstar.
Is it a UFC champion paper?
Paper paper.
Who's been a paper?
Could you draw besides your riot?
That's not a world champion in the UFC.
Anderson Silva don't talk shit.
No,
but everybody who was ever
been a paper view star,
that's never been a world
champion in the UFC.
Is there one McGregor?
No.
Conor McGregor knocked out.
Although he's,
but when he fought in the ideas in the
world champ at one 70 but it doesn't
matter.
He's a world champion.
One 45 he was,
he had beaten Josie.
Oh,
there's one of the best,
say one 70 was all but 170170170
that's the waterworld chat the answer.
But he won the world championship.
It's the wrong answer.
But here's the co,
doesn't matter Bro.
He won the heavyweight title.
St currently hasn't been,
hasn't,
hasn't been.
There's not one.
So you're wife favors the
only guy in consideration.
If you think about a guy who like a
legit star who's never won a UFC title,
who can sell paper views,
you're Ryan might be the only guy here.
I want to WEC title it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but never the UFC.
Nobody in the UFC that like has come along
in these years who's not like a giant
crazy fight pass fan
has likely seen those.
True.
You know it's,
it's hard because you,
you don't see those when they
show those a UFC countdown shows,
you see highlights from him and shit.
But you don't really see w he sees on TV.
True.
Well,
I mean a lot of dudes do talk shit,
but it's fighting.
It's natural.
It's a puddle.
The drawl,
not a wheelchair.
So Ronnie's a good,
good call.
He doesn't really talk shit.
He's gotten close a couple
of times this fighting shit.
But you know,
he doesn't get the kind of like numbers
he's actually talking about that.
He did an interview recently where he's
talking about how he'd rather fight Nate
Diaz,
Nate Diaz rather than Conor because
it doesn't matter to whether
it's for the world title.
Nice.
So I gets the same amount of money,
like whether he's fighting,
he doesn't get paper view because
they're a piece of paper champion.
Just wants to fight the
best guy and wants a fight.
Like who?
A guy who he wants to fight and I guess
he wants to get back at Nate because he
fought day before.
It makes it neat,
beat him and he doesn't feel
like he fought his best.
That's also why cowboys such a bad
ass because he just wants challenges.
Like that's what he gravitates towards.
That's why,
I mean he's a small one 70 dude.
Paul Felder looked bigger
than him the other day.
We were hanging out at the comedy store.
I like by like a few pounds.
That's true.
Maybe 10 well he was,
it fell.
Felder was not high eighties when we
saw him and Donald was Max Holloway.
When nine in a row doesn't
talk an ounce of Shit.
You don't,
nobody knows who he is.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
But he also is the bad part to it.
But he also is the UK.
He could,
he could headline a UK show.
Right.
Max Holloway.
Thoughts?
You Mean Hawaii?
Mother,
bugger.
Oh,
is he?
I thought he was from the UK.
No,
John Holloway.
Thinking of John Hallway.
Okay.
Filming give John Hathaway.
John Hathaway.
I made up one of those [inaudible]
fuck and he's won nine in a row.
Give him a fucking total
shock to Max Holloway.
He's so fucking good.
Max Holloway.
So Ghanaian and they'll fucking row and
beat the WHO's who is Hawaiian accent is
so fucking pick out there that no,
get the fuck out of here though.
If you pay attention to flags,
they're confusing because a lot of
people don't realize Hawaii is all fuck
anymore.
Hawaiian Hawaii comes into the frag flag.
It looks like a British flag flag,
which in a weird way because like no
one in South Dakota comes in with the
fucking South Dakota flag because that
is one of the promote more proof positive
things that Hawaii is
like an occupied country.
We have taken over Hawaii and decided,
you know what,
you motherfuckers are
just a little too close.
We would like to control you since
you're in the middle of the ocean.
And you know,
I don't,
it's not a good idea to let an enemy
tribe live here five hours by plane from
fucking Los Angeles.
So we're just going to own you.
So that's what Hawaii is,
man.
That's how I know there's a
lot of Hawaiians that want
Hawaiian independence to
that.
I would say settle down.
Settle down.
Everyone said Max Holloway will
respect you deeply as your own nation.
Just wait.
God,
the new,
let's just keep this one to you.
Love yourself from Hawaii.
I Love Hawaii.
I'm going to go on vacation.
I'm probably going to die.
There it in the sense that
like when I'm an old man,
I'm going to move there.
I never been there.
I love it.
I love it best.
And you know what tells me,
why don't we all go to tell me that they
go there and the Hawaiians treat them
bad and that the Hawaiians are racist.
They're all cash back.
I've never had that issue.
They couldn't be any friends.
I be any nicer.
I went,
they take me in like I'm fucking legal.
And did you ever heard it's the best?
Um,
I went to for a wedding.
Uh,
um,
we went to,
me and my wife went to
a wedding out there.
One of her friends got
married on the big island.
There was like the Hilo side
and then there's another side,
there's a Hilo side that
Bj is very popular in.
And then the other side,
they're like rivals,
you know,
they're like,
and we were on the side that
was like rivaling Bj and the,
you know,
we were out there.
We had the,
I was watching the UFC on,
on,
uh,
on my phone and during the wedding I
didn't know anybody and everybody that
lived there was like white
people that move there.
They all said do not go out at night.
Do not go out because yeah,
if you go out at night
locally to any of these bars,
you're going to get fucked.
Oh yeah.
You don't go to a bar.
Well,
you also know studio city.
Would you go to the bars?
And I did.
I went to the bars and Hawaii.
They're close.
Fuck Tall.
How I am,
Bro.
You're a beast inside your ears.
You've got a
tank top on
point.
The local said don't you don't
want to go certainly bar,
but let me tell you some one thing cause
you get a lot of heat online sometimes.
I do.
Yeah man.
Like people think because you
talk a lot of shit on the podcast,
people who understand that this
is like elevated conversation.
Like in real life you
got along with everybody.
Everyone Brendon here.
So I mean you're one of those
guys like everybody you meet,
everyone's hugging
everybody everywhere I go.
He's also,
he's also very
compassionate to all people.
Like he's,
he's kind of,
he's a soft,
he's a soft day.
You just talk mad shit and
you've got to settle down.
I settled down but do you hate,
okay.
[inaudible] Cowboy Donald looks
ready to take down by Donald.
Good wrestling dude and cat.
Patrick Cote task,
good Jujitsu man.
He's very sneaky off his back.
Serone has really good Jujitsu Shit,
right submissions.
Ronnie's been top five for 10 years.
Teen triangles,
some ridiculous,
ridiculous.
He shows it's so fucking fast.
He's probably,
he probably has more triangles
and anybody in the UFC ever.
Well,
if you think about it,
all the fights in the WEC,
one of,
one of the things that you
and I talked about a lot eddy,
that he was a great example of a guy.
Why it's important if you're a
good kicker to have a nasty guard.
Cause he didn't give a
fuck if you took him down.
So he would throw these nasty as
head kicks and if you took him down,
oh shit.
Where that triangle come from until well
and then he talked about when he fought
Diaz,
he was saying how he was embarrassed
because he's so afraid to go to the ground
with them.
I was like,
what the Fuck's wrong with you?
You're believing his Jitsu man.
What the fuck is he?
His digits is pretty fucking high level.
It is and I'm telling him how boys,
it's fucking good man buddy.
Anyway,
should be worried but you shouldn't knock.
Go down.
Here's the deal.
A guy like DHEAS could tap cowboy.
He's one of the few guys
that get tab cargo and I'm
not saying that
stove a very glued posey
is cowboy so bad.
We're just standing there
token in a scramble.
Fuck you ain't did.
That's the perfect scrambled
tomboy just came up.
It's a beautiful sweet or you stand
up and you or you get to soc controls,
beautiful works out.
It's going to have a speed advantage.
But the power scares cowboy shines
is with his fucking leg kicks,
man.
Hell he where he ate up Eddie Alvarez
and that's where he started to turn the
tide on.
Nate Diaz.
He started tacking that
heavy fucking fucked up.
He started fucking up that front
foot cowboy has nasty leg kicks mass.
Just the power of,
and it scares the fuck
out of me with Donald.
Oh God.
Cowboy with the tape out.
What's killing the power
of Coty because when,
when Donald gets comfortable,
he stands upright and it
doesn't move his head.
You got to worry about,
everybody's got to worry about
Cota expected take downs.
And I think he,
that was the last thing on his mind.
I'm telling very prepared
cause it comes prepared.
Tony Cowboy for three,
four years moved basically the Denver
for six months and just train with or
bowling or arm wrestling nonstop.
Russell,
every single good there,
man.
I'm telling you.
I'm telling you can fucking wrestle.
Damn his Jujitsu,
it leaves no space.
He's got a real tight by God.
He doesn't get dangerous Jujitsu.
Yeah,
you very,
very much.
It's so,
it's so explosive.
It's hard to train for him.
That dam and rustling helps your Jujitsu,
so goddamn hundred percent Dan,
you know this,
the wrestling rooms,
it's about the base,
the stability,
the balance,
all that shit into your Jujitsu.
Just they just got so much.
Brendan,
would you train with Donald?
Does he just pick up things very quickly?
Is that what
he trains?
He like,
he's literally all he does.
Just trap you.
Just trains all fucking time.
That jump off boats and cows and shit.
Dude,
he's going to call God Donald's Rhoda.
You bad motherfucker.
God Damn,
he's a back massage.
I can throw my underwear and he's got the
fucking body triangle locked down that
body triangle,
so God damn long to controls
your kids yourself and good,
good under hook by the way.
He looks.
He looks pretty much as
big as coke to actually no,
he does.
All right.
Talk to you.
It's more shredded than is pretty safe
unless you've got something funny to say.
He's pretty good.
He's also was also caught shit.
He's taking a shit saving.
Ah Nah.
He's not a Kielbasa.
He's not bossy.
10 he's not whole coke and hot dog skin.
You see like a roasted?
Yeah,
he's like abroad.
He's relaxed.
He's got his back just like a thick,
I'm going to shut up.
Fucking brought.
Come on up.
Come on.
Broths in the summer.
Kind of get up.
You Man.
Looking for it again.
It's special peppers and onions.
I'm so fucking hungry now.
Me Too.
Let's go get it.
I was eating cheese and
pickles in the back room.
That's not good enough.
I mean I need meat.
Me Too.
I need,
I'm sure we got some buffalo.
Oh really?
Stand up Dan.
Patrick coattails.
So game man.
He's so God damn game.
God Eddie in inside that shell hole.
I don't know
why he's kicking the fuck out of
homeboy from San Diego on the ground.
You know what I'm talking about?
No,
no,
no.
What the fuck?
That kid's name?
Black belt from Syria Jujitsu.
He said,
yeah,
I know it's weird.
It's,
we sent Jerry,
I'm not doing anymore.
He'd sent Jerry [inaudible] media.
I'm just trying to bait
everything we say because some
God damn fake news title story.
Can they do.
I understand.
I'm not hating though.
I'm friends with a lot of
them are really good guys.
There's a lot of them that are good.
Got Them Suck Dick.
A lot of them are pretty cool.
But you know when I feel
like I really do feel like,
but I really do feel like this,
a lot of the,
the animosity between MMA
media and you and I and,
and a lot of other people would probably
be solved if we were actually talking,
cause we would probably have a
conversation that wasn't as one side of is
someone writing something
shitty about you,
you responding in a shitty way.
Someone writes something to you on Twitter
or they was baseless communication.
It's face.
That's right.
Well it's also like you're
not reading people's faces.
And so an issue with writing something,
right?
Cause you write something about
someone's opinion and there's a lot of
assumptions.
There's a lot of you,
you,
you're not communicating with them.
But like if you and I have
a dispute about something,
we,
oh we've,
we've had arguments before,
but we are always resolved them cause
we're both reasonable and we're friends
and we'd talk and we'd be friendly.
But if you just wrote a blog about me
and I responded with a blog about you
here,
we know each other forever and I love you,
but we'd probably be managed.
But the issue becomes if
Serrano,
he's not playing around,
he's not here and fun.
Oh,
he's not hearing it.
Who he's ever about defense.
Nice.
Kick to the bigger than he normally does.
He was very good with the articles.
The thing is,
what gets clicks is
negativity or headlights.
He is point,
right?
But it's not,
I understand in some ways,
but because it's their job,
but I feel like it does as much damage
to them as it does to the person they're
misrepresenting.
So if they write a story
about you and they just,
Oh my God,
those kicks are o and p Co Tej has
to come back with one of his own man.
That's him.
You know he's,
he's a fucking game dues super game.
He
said Donald loves his size.
We shut the fuck.
I know I changed my mind.
It's the angle of fucking camera.
He can put her on these cameras.
Hey takes also a piece of an analyst too.
He does a lot of work.
Just be careful of Michael J.
White.
That's all I ask from you.
You hey man drinks and I
respect him because a spa,
you've got a spear respect
and for a sidekick roundhouse,
you know who needs some fucking props?
Who is an awesome analyst for Eve Edwards?
God Damn,
he's good.
I think Tyra.
I Love E.
Dot.
Very good.
They're both good.
Lee Weekly's kill the game.
He could be good as well.
No,
I have to know.
Agree with me and bring up another black
guy cause I have my black black duck.
You guys,
you guys a little respect
for Donald Right now.
Oh,
I pick up,
I go count that power scares
me with Donald Donald.
A Jab Tom.
I like Donald Better at one 70 because
he doesn't have to fucking dry himself
out.
He looks,
he does it great.
Great.
And he also has a speed advantage,
like a sham.
Whoa.
You mentioned dogs.
Roni verse Robbie Lawler.
Fuck.
Oh boy.
Okay,
let's not get crazy.
What do you mean knock your crazy?
Watch this though.
This is Oh,
Nasty Jab.
Oh,
I wouldn't mind another
take down for Donald.
I mean Donald and he's
taking it by not get crazy.
It's like you would have to like,
he would have copied a bunch of
guys before that could happen.
Hey,
what?
Seventies
Jad it's almost crazy
talking about somebody else.
Finding Robbie when
Robbie is about to fight.
Nah,
that's the way the world works.
That's our sport.
100% I'm talking shit.
Oh Donald.
Because Donald's such a big name.
I could see him jump into number three.
We get Patrick Cote timber
trying so fucking Tony,
Josh Shit.
Oh,
now we're doing jumping shit.
Oh.
He's on point.
He's doing a quick going,
a big bully.
Kids coming in.
I had a keeps coming and
keeps coming in quotation.
Still dangerous.
He has so much power.
It's so dangerous.
Keep it down over there Brendan.
You keep it down to thing about
Kowtow to fight the weight coach.
Hey fights
God maple maples,
shit about the flag missile
system says God damn Serone
shit on the whole country man.
Look at him.
Oh
No,
no.
Don't,
don't get a brawling match.
Don't do that.
Shoot in La.
That jabs smooth though.
Donald has a ride.
Excuse me.
I'll just go ahead.
Copper 3000 please.
Head kick for 3000 now that heart coats,
hey,
holy.
Okay,
so let's,
let's let this play out.
I'll step away.
If you try that.
I'm fucking stepping away.
I'll take a kick for 3000 please.
All right,
crazy.
I'm looking for that step and knee.
I can't wait for this head kick.
I like how Donald defends
would that left knee.
He does a real good job of catching
guys as they come in cause he throws all
that fractures and use on Jim Miller.
So good and throws that that need of the
body very sparing just keeps coming in
for effect.
Keeps coming in,
man.
Oh,
oh man.
Coattails.
Tough coatings like bring it on.
These Canadians are built
from different stuff.
Don't get me wrong.
Match Cowboy.
Oh Donald,
with the quick switch.
Kick high.
I love that switch cake.
It's got that Nice.
He's going to say day left.
Switch,
kick fuck sweater.
I can't say I want to say
something while everybody leaves.
Okay,
listen,
relax.
Brendan's are really Nice Guy.
This is like fun.
This is fun.
You understand he's the best player is
broadcasting during the fire and the kid
when he's doing this show.
It's fun folks.
Of course.
It's fun.
Dang.
I know there's a lot of nerds
out there that are freaking out.
They're angry,
man.
He's the best.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
I'll tell you the defense.
Bernard's please Brenton shop.
He's a very nice guy.
If you,
if you were,
if,
if you're a nerd and
you're getting picked on,
Brenda's job is going to
punch the guy in the face.
He's not fighting anymore,
folks.
Just trying to make some hype.
Zoe does it.
That's okay.
Just relax.
Everybody realizes a special guy,
everybody relaxed and
enjoy coattail versus Roni.
You're allowed to disagree and agree.
It's all good.
But I guarantee you if
you met him in real life,
you'd go music.
Yes.
And if you see him on stage
of Brian cow and you're like,
hey,
look,
so know a little nervous up there.
Yeah,
of course.
He's nervous.
Never fucking done this before.
Do you understand a weird it is.
These guys are feeling a thousand people.
The Wilbur Theater in Boston sold
out show and I got the report.
I you guys sold out the
Wilbur is crazy for a podcast.
Crazy.
I don't even know what to say about it.
It's just amazing.
It's fun.
I mean a lot to me and Brennan shop,
my whole life changes.
I've been in the business forever.
I'm so happy.
Well,
you know,
you were the one that
told me to do a podcast.
I'm so happy and it's been amazing
what I miss when we're talking about
crocodiles just talking about you guys.
You guys have.
Oh my God.
He just wants to track just round one
this round there and shut the fuck up.
Just started.
I know Brian,
me the drink like a woman.
Fuck.
I'm not going to cocky.
Oh,
look at this.
He'll get out.
He just gets out.
Get Out.
I just want to point out in my house,
I do all the cooking,
so just it's just job.
Boy,
this is crazy.
Look at this.
What's a healthy glass?
You're obviously not gender.
They go,
oh,
should I look?
It is true.
I don't know what I'm saying.
I got sharp guys,
doll smell driving for me.
I'm going to keep forgetting
your brothers behind me.
I love him.
Bet your sweet as he is.
All right.
This side is very exciting man.
Come on down.
I like how Donald Switches stances too.
There are men and there's Donald's,
Donald's Serone switches stances
and it's not because he's injured.
He's just,
because he's got so many
variables in is a task.
Look at this kid can do all
kinds of shit as attack.
He's a bass drum,
head hunting.
I know what you're saying.
No,
you're definitely right.
And it's interesting seeing him do that
at 70 I think this is a good example of
a guy.
First of all,
let's bring up Patrick Otay fought Tito,
would tease at two oh five and his UFC
light heavyweight yen dropped him and
dropped an all time great
light heavyweight in Chemo rts.
So,
oh my God.
Donald Donald's Serone looks this is an
argument for the point of diminishing
returns and weight cutting.
Yep.
Correct.
Donald looks fun.
We'll also drop them twice.
Argument for Donald's Raleigh
being a bad mother fucker,
but we already knew that
that was bad at anyway.
I think he's at home.
He's both from the looks.
Exactly.
Thanks.
Asked cardio can take a shot and yeah,
just get run healthy man.
He's healthy.
He was one 76 when I was talking to him.
He's saying,
I'm the only six pound weight cut.
It was.
I'm not telling you that's the move.
That's really the move.
It really hurts them.
Connor can't make 45 anymore.
It's going to tell for goods,
so let it go,
man.
He's a superstar.
He doesn't need a fucking fight.
Dos Anjos at 55 sons,
he wins,
maybe loses everybody makes money.
He gives a fuck.
Oh my
[inaudible]
your
I'm texting him right now.
I'm saying there are men in there done.
There's Thomas Rauner.
That's the kind of beaten down though.
You have [inaudible]
that's the kind of sounds.
My boyfriend,
I don't think anybody's ever beat
down your coattail like damn,
he's a bad mother.
Think everybody's at.
Anybody's ever beat down Patrick
Hotel like that petro quota is lost.
He broke his hand versus Donald,
uh,
Alan Belcher and Alan Belcher caught
them in a rear naked Anderson Silva.
He blew his knee out.
Who the fuck has ever beaten him down?
He dropped them three times.
Who has ever beaten him down like that?
How about nobody?
No one,
no one.
And he's coming in on us when
stress and he's coming in.
Fantastic.
Jesus Christ.
He has a granite chin.
He's known for his chin,
known for his chin.
Got Damn Donald's running.
Look good.
God.
He's a bad man.
Look at that left hook.
Left Hook was landing in the
pocket and not taking any shots.
What hard punches did
he take in this fight?
He's just too quick.
Too quick for these candidates.
Not just two quick fucking healthy bro.
He's fucking hell.
I am going to be that fucking form guy.
Can you imagine Donald versus
Wonderboy and Donald's?
Donald's our friends.
So it's fucking
jacking off to him.
Brian has sent him the way you yet there.
It's probably not in your best interest.
I just like no did.
It's like one of the,
what's that guy that Howard
Dean's like the Howard Dean?
Yeah.
What did I do?
One drink.
Too many mistakes.
It sounds like he's watching
somebody fucking going.
Yeah.
No,
it's like he's got an audition and he's
never had an audition before and they go
action and he goes,
yeah.
And then the guy goes a great stuff.
Brendan,
you've got your info.
Oh by the way,
that's not Johnny Depp.
You thought that was Johnny Depp me.
But the other guy,
snoop Dogg,
I was barely paid attention for sure.
Some high as fuck
Jon Jones.
Speaking of high as fuck John
Fucking Jones was pulled up better.
Well,
here's the thing for the main event,
Joe,
for the main event,
here's a out of respect.
Here's the thing about this.
Um,
this UFC 200 things,
the mock lesson or thing,
you know,
this is the thing,
because MMA media loves to
write stories about this stuff.
I'm a fan of aerial.
Hawaii's,
I'd like Ariel Helwani when
I was telling him that,
what was told to me about the UFC,
about the leak,
I don't,
I don't like,
I don't not like Ariel Helwani.
He's always been a nice guy to me.
I liked him.
I was just simply stating what I was told,
you know,
I mean,
I don't,
I don't give a fuck
about these big promos.
You know what I care that Brock
Lesnar is gonna Fight Mark Hunt.
I don't care if I heard it from my mom.
My mom called me up,
but I worked for the UFC.
I didn't find out until I was sitting
there doing commentary and I didn't give a
shit.
If I had found out because of Ariel
Helwani story instead of the UFC,
I wouldn't have given a fuck.
It wouldn't have been
any less valuable to me.
Can I ask you something as a,
as a guy who's on the inside,
why would Brock Lesnar take a guy
like Mark Hunt on his first fight?
I'll think get a choice.
Doesn't make any sense.
Choice.
That's a good question.
In some going to give them Josh Barnett
won the fight and you'd fucking wrap
them into could,
it could be that,
well Jesus Christ,
I would,
I would almost like to see Josh
Barnett more pro wrestling that barn.
It wanted to fight,
promoted for the fight.
Did he give it to it?
Is the many of reasons.
Ah,
man,
I don't know man.
I would,
if I'm talking to Dana has pressed,
I'd be hard pressed.
I'd be hard pressed to pass.
Josh Barnett's offer
hunt is going to like,
hey bitch,
I ain't the undertaker fucking
uppercut and second row,
suck it up.
Let me tell you something,
man.
Josh Barnett is not a fucking easy fight
for saying he is Barnett's a fucking
monster.
I'm saying hunt isn't a cakewalk.
No,
no,
no.
Neither guy that can wrestle.
Exactly.
Exactly what cut can't.
Yeah,
but Bob Brock Lesnar is a fucking genuine
NCAA two times 96 but he's still a
fucking gorilla wrestler.
He hasn't fought and how long?
It's a good point.
That's a huge point.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know our cousin from,
we're going to get too weird hunt.
This has some weird Goddamn Donaldson.
Ronin yeah,
Donald's up.
He's a bad motherfucker
to do this to Patrick.
You never see passionate about take turns
to 70 think about the cool fight to 70
for Donald.
Ever see Patrick Otay Turtle.
I'd love it.
I love him at seven.
I love it.
Even get scratched now.
Good as it gets.
I'll be on the boat tomorrow morning.
Yeah,
he'll be doing some jet skiing or
fucking riding a bull or some shit.
Fucking a bear for sure.
Relaxed on it.
He's a different kind of guy,
man.
I mean,
this is what makes him happy.
He likes doing crazy shit.
I'm a big fan.
Shaved my head just like him as a person.
Good Fun,
Warren Dude.
You know what Donald said to me wants,
man,
I only met him like maybe twice.
You know?
I was like early on the day and I said,
hey man,
what's up?
And I rent to give him a handshake.
Goes all.
Come on man.
We hug around here.
Yeah,
that's good.
It gives you a hug,
but it's a genuine hug.
It's not,
it's not political or he's not.
Now he's really starting.
Podcasts are now Jackson's gym.
Subscribing.
Yes.
I'll take it.
Yeah.
Everybody should podcast.
He calls it the companion for sure.
It's the same way.
You have a fucking,
why not call it the campaign?
I'm just kidding.
He gives a shit.
Know what you'd call it?
The same way.
[inaudible] companion.
I think that's a show.
Something like this
bad motherfuckers.
He calls a bad motherfucker ranch.
Well,
it's like a,
what was that?
A Garren Keeler sir.
Sekai prairie home companion guy.
Oh yeah,
garrison Keillor.
Is that his name?
Well,
there was a radio show that
was like a really famous,
his name is called,
I don't remember his name,
but he a garrison.
He had a,
he had it on NPR every Sunday.
I've never fucking,
it's one of those things that people
listen to when you're inconsistent,
was completely shut down.
You're no longer interested in fuck that.
All
guys joking.
The prairie home companion,
is it,
is it part of the public's radio path?
I don't remember fucking heard of them.
Well,
it's a famous thing and I don't believe
I've ever listened to a whole one.
But,
uh,
I know that it's a big piece.
Was still doing the damn thing this to be,
this would be the main event gentleman.
Yeah.
It's,
I hope you guys are
ready to fucking fight.
Okay,
let's break this down.
Brendan Shop,
Eddie Bravo and Brian.
Model Oregon crone.
What do you guys think?
Let's start with Brian.
What?
Maine,
what do I say?
What do you think?
I mean,
look it.
Here's the problem.
There's no problems.
Rory.
He's trained,
trained with Wonderboy.
He alive.
I'm not [inaudible] let me finish.
If Rory Rory gives him space,
it's going to be a
disaster.
If Rory stays in boxing
wrestling distance,
he's going to be,
he's going to win this fight.
But I don't know if you can do that now.
I don't know if you
can do that with Kevin,
with Wonderboy.
Wonderboy may have figured
out distance you want to be,
may have figured out how to keep a gun
in a way to close to close back here.
Let me hear what Brendan,
thanks.
I'll take here what,
Brendan,
thanks.
I'll get to you next.
I want to hear what your
employee has too many tools.
He's too smart and he's a,
they've trained together before
it Tristar and for us help,
uh,
Wonderboy out a bunch.
So they know his tricks and I think Roy
wins this fight and it's good for the
sport because he's a free agent and
he'd go test the free market waters.
So it changes the sport for the good.
Interesting.
Eddie,
probably you think it's too close to call?
That's why we should bet.
But if I had a,
if I had a gun to my head,
I would go with,
you're right on paper.
You're right Roy,
you make too many tools,
but because he can just strike in Russell,
Stephen Thompson,
he's just so quick coming in and out.
I'm gonna just,
just with that kind of shit,
this is explosive.
So difficult cause [inaudible]
go with that just for a goof.
Volta analysts picked
Wonderboy on UFC tonight.
By the way,
here's the thing.
Stuff like wonder boy has been hit before.
It didn't Ellenberger tag him.
Yes he did.
Right?
He,
Matt and Matt Brown.
Yeah.
Matt Brown.
Well Matt Brown was a,
but,
but in his words,
he said that he was overtrained going
into that fight and then he made some
mistakes or we all and uh,
it,
it's totally possible that's truth.
But he also fought Matt motherfucking
Brown and you might feel like you got
overtrained if you fight Matt Motherfuck,
that pressure son Matt Brown,
we'll put some pressure on you and you'd
be looking for solutions is a mortal.
He takes you to a dark place and
dark place before you might think,
man,
it's,
I'm going to poison my
fucking soup 100% not bitch.
That's not Matt Brown Cardio Cardio,
beating that ass and draining in a way
that only a dude who's died and been
brought back to life by emps can do for
Ruby size clothes because to him and
Donald came that pain.
Besides Carl's comment,
when he was really young,
the only person Rory Macdonald's
lost who I believe is Robbie Lawler.
Am I right?
Call callers conduct
you list Robbie Lawler.
That's it.
That I can,
and he was beating.
Who else can call his conduct?
Bring that kind of darkness.
Court McGee coordinate well,
yeah,
he brings,
she brings that same dark.
He's talking about that touch
of death done was such a death.
There's data,
there's fucking this mortal Matt
Brown and there's Court Mcgee.
Mcgee might lose some
fights and he's a very,
very tough guy,
but he's in a very,
very difficult division with
a lot of very tough guys,
but there's a darkness to court brings
when he starts beating that ass dark too.
He beats that ass in a very
fucking animalistic clinical way,
like a technical clinical way where
he's seen the edge because he has a
technique from the grim reaper he's got,
he's been to the edge of time for real.
They both have come back.
Him and Matt Brown.
It's not,
they carry with them
some Harry Potter Shit.
Yup.
Frighteners in this bitch.
This is why this could
never be on television.
Ever understand folks?
Never,
I haven't made a call yet.
I'm going to go.
Okay,
let me,
can I say,
yeah,
I think I agree with you guys
that if you looked at it on paper,
brewery is a,
he's a more difficult challenge because
he has more tools and he can knock guys
out that are legit.
Strikers like Terex happening.
He's not going to tech staff.
And he was big because
Safa deans or like a very,
very skillful striker and Safford Dean
ran a clinic on Nate Marquardt to when
the Strikeforce welterweight title is a
clinic clinic of leg kicks and technique
and footwork.
He's really good striker.
So for Rory did not came out the way he
did is pretty stunning and it's Roy's
interchanges between wrestling and
striking the can make a big difference in
this fight because Roy's fluid in that
where as Stephen Wonderboy Thompson,
unless he figures out a way to put Roy
on his back early and shake him up the
way boats he tried to do.
But the danger with that is
Rory has a wicked fucking guard.
He's fast off of his back.
He moves quick and he tries to set
up sweeps and all my plot this,
we went to draw meditech.
Right.
And you might not have seen it before,
but it is legit as fuck.
He went to a draw with JT Torres.
He did.
Well.
Do you understand folks?
I mean don't understand like this is
like the top of the food chain Brazilian
Jujitsu competitors.
He's a killer.
He's in that breed.
So homeland,
exactly.
So Roy McDonald can go to the ground at
that high of a level and survive without
getting tapped.
They're really close.
Kin tapped his arm,
got jacked up,
but he didn't get in trouble
or his arm is fucked.
He was saying we're fucked and he
had a fight like three weeks later.
He's a mad band.
He's also the Canadian serial killer.
But Dude,
I'm telling you,
man,
one of the things that came about him
being on my podcast is people got to
really understand your
only CNM in his game face.
Oh,
he's,
course.
He seems like he's a psycho.
But when he was on the podcast,
Larry's,
when he was on this podcast,
people got a chance to see him like
as an actual person and they're like,
oh,
I've only been seeing you
when you're competing now.
He's the bad dude.
What do some great,
nice sense of humor.
This is a perfect example.
What we were talking about.
We're talking about with Connor.
This is the guy that should be applauded.
He is a fucking intelligent,
savvy.
There's a superstar,
has number one,
a bell,
exact face of cancer.
Exact number one close still.
Then when the bell
say dicker down,
that came from him at
the time I was single.
She was single.
There's a bunch of girls in Vegas.
He goes,
it's time to separate that mother hand
from the goose and take them down.
Oh,
he's tall,
tall
and I had to write it into
my phone to remember the
next morning.
He's an animal that's other hands.
There was one girl like taking Google.
That's a funny piece of advice.
He's good.
He's the best.
He's his nose looks different.
He sold,
he's talking to a lot of shots,
man.
Robbie Lawler fight.
He got his nose destroyed.
You mean wonder man?
He's 33 he's a really good dude,
man.
He's a really good dude.
I'm a big fan.
They're both great guys.
Good guys.
You know both of them pretty well,
right?
Really,
really well trained
partners for a long time,
but Roy McDonald,
just for the good of the sport.
If he rent and testis free agency,
it helps to grow the sport.
But let me just say this about Wonderboy.
Wonderboy is extraordinary and in his
ability to close the distance and land
these like thunderous shots out of
nowhere of the best in the world.
These combinations are so fluid that
they're enough for him to land one or two
hard shots every exchange.
And if he does that,
if he somehow or another can tempt
Rory into some hypnotic dance,
Jude,
some high level shit on him,
it's all in his ability to have stuff
to take down if he feels super confident
in his ability stuff,
takedown.
Cause he'd been training
with Weidman so much,
he hasn't been training with
fire but it may,
but it made a big difference.
Wonderboy,
Wonderboy is going to win this fight.
His understanding of how to
stuff takedowns his stuff,
his takedowns stuffing
is at a very high level.
It absolutely has something
to do a training with Weidman.
But it's not saying that he's so silly
that he would substitute that and not
have a high level wrestler test him.
He's not dumb.
He's a smart guy.
So is his dad,
if I can call it.
I think Roy eats his lunch.
I think I love 100% I am
100% 50 50 on this fight.
100% just for just to be controversial
because you know how I am guys.
I'm calling me.
Are you a rebel Wonderboy?
Wonderboy by knocked out
Brian kick knock out.
Well Roy and if there's any,
if there's anybody can knock him out.
It's roaring and keeps its Wonderboy.
If people get mad at
me being noncommittal,
it's not because I like both of these
gentlemen and it's really honestly because
this sport is so fucking crazy
being knocked out.
Luke Rockhold on my first,
my baby fell asleep.
I finally pumps it first.
I remember I put them asleep.
Mike knocks him out.
I love my good buddy.
I went,
Oh shit are crying.
Fuck mine.
I even texted him that you woke up my kid,
but it's worth it.
That's how I fucking crying when when
Bisbing one I felt like crying 10 fucking
years.
It was happy for him.
I wish he had.
I wish she hadn't gotten on on top
of the fence and gotten fuck you.
That was whatever the guy he
was on a roller coaster ride
him winning the fight and winning
the world title like that.
You can't fault him for that.
Talk to him when the dust settles.
Talked to him on Monday and he's barely,
yes,
back to Michael Bisping
Dennison to UFC title.
They both walk.
It's the best story of all time.
I never seen a knockout like that.
Look at this.
Oh my God.
Here we go.
Now here's the question.
Here's the question.
Can Rory threaten him enough?
We'd take towns to get him
off of his game of strike.
You can kick too.
I don't like how course Wonderboy is
coming to them or does Roy decide that all
that training with Raymond Daniels has
made him comfortable enough with it,
a legit high level karate striker that
he thinks he can look at the sideways.
He's just sideways.
Rory smart.
The haunt.
He's,
well,
he's Daniel's fight sideways too,
which is one of the interesting things
because Thompson is one of the few guys
that can pull off that stance.
It's a total front leg side kick.
You know where in front
of like Brown and na,
but Liotta doesn't do it as good as him.
She used to back in the day.
Justin Scoggins does it very well.
That flyway kid.
Yeah,
he does it very well.
very well.
He's one of the maybe the best at it.
Be the best next to him.
Better moves.
Fantastic moves like a fucking,
he's a high level kid.
That's got a lot of potential,
but if you can pull that stance off and
control with that front leg like a jab,
there's a lot of guys that
aren't ready for that.
That fucking left leg is wound up for
him to see when Valtellina fought Raymond
Daniels,
what do [inaudible] fuck?
Oh my sneaky fucker.
Introduction of danger.
Introduction with danger.
He's so smart.
I roll.
It's like being in the very,
very important.
He's a killer man.
Tristar.
Tristar is heavy,
deep into leg Rasa.
Done for us.
Donna Harris comes up there.
So those guys are all about like,
oh guys for us a hobby apparently
is not down with the ketogenic diet.
He feels it.
Yeah.
I would love to talk to him about
that because I'm an atheist,
so smart and he's smarter than me.
It worries me.
I like you look good bro.
I like it.
I'm very happy with your
kid or let me know about it.
He might not be correct.
I don't know who's correct.
I mean,
and it might not be Whoa,
nice.
How fast.
He's also so confident.
We're always throwing head
kicks man and he dies,
he can kick and also it keeps him at a
distance where he can head kick Thompson
but Thompson has to move forward
to counter with that punch.
So He,
if he can get that head kick
off as quick as he just did,
it gives Wonderboy
something to think about it.
Guess what?
All of a sudden,
hold on a second dude.
Cause Wonderboy is always used
to fighting on the outside.
So if Rory can be the guy on the outside
because he threatens with that head
kick,
it changes the whole cause
I ain't gonna us Zack.
It looks like he's fighting.
He's mirroring uh,
Wonderboy style.
Right.
That's what it looks like.
He also has the best job
at one 70 in the world.
Yeah.
He's got a very good job.
He looks like he's mirroring
his exact style though.
Stamps,
stance,
everything.
Well,
it's interesting if he can,
if he can threaten more
with the head kick,
that's really interesting.
If he can hide it behind those punches.
Damn.
Not really right now.
Hey,
look like rocks.
One Guy South Park.
But days looks like,
yeah,
that's,
that's accurate.
But they look like,
no,
no.
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
He's mirroring him in terms of he's
standing much more sideways and easily.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well he's done a lot of sparring with
Daniels and he understands how to negate
that front leg kick.
See that front leg kick is way
more effective if you're slightly,
slightly square because you
fight like a tie fighter.
You expose that front and tie fighters.
They throw a lot of tips,
but they don't necessarily throw the
same kind of sidekicks unless they have
some sort of other backgrounds as well.
Roy's biggest advantage.
He's so smart and put it all together.
George Saint Pierre is,
Oh yeah man.
No,
he's legit.
He's luck.
The switch.
Some spinning back kick.
Yeah,
he's got it.
Well that's the thing.
See Training with us.
20 with Raymond Daniels.
Well,
I'd like both of these nerves
but trainer with Raymond Daniels,
but tires you for that.
You know you're,
you're okay.
No,
I'm just kidding.
I love both these guys.
See that front leg side
kick style like Balta.
Leni beat that down.
Hands down.
Oh sidekick.
It's a nice sidekick.
So slick.
Hey Brandon,
you keep it down.
All right.
That's the benefit of,
Oh,
here we are.
Here we go.
Hobos and the clinch rough.
Oh please.
Rory tries to get you back,
man.
When you hit Rory,
even if you hit him with
that front lake side cat,
he gets back.
We'll serve gets boy listen,
he's fucking Canadian banks
as a bad motherfucker.
This kid that maple syrup gets
boiling about fucking talking about.
You know what's interesting when you
see a kid like worry or you see someone
like my shop says you're
the first frame shop.
Cracks me up.
He'll say some.
You know what's interesting about
both of these guys isn't it?
They're going to get better is if they
don't get physically injured in his fight
to the point where it incapacitates
them and stop their training.
These guys are going to get
better because this fight,
because they're in that prime period.
Roy has to get going.
What you're looking at right here is like
some of the best movement and striking
in one 70 that you're going to find today.
Yeah.
One verse two son.
Yeah,
and as far as like MMA
striking like these guys are,
Goddamn is legitimate
guess elite of the elite.
There'll be a leader.
The echelon,
you'll get the 1% there's 1% right
now and that's what we get any better.
That's what's fascinating to like
standing on the outside watching that.
I'm watching that.
I'm going,
these guys are gonna get better.
It's a chess match for Roy.
I'm a little scared if he loses this one.
It's a little tough.
What is the fighter of
2025 going to look like?
I mean how good the matrix.
Oh God damn good.
Are these like the Matrix
break dancer slash I don't know
karate skills.
It might hit saturation point.
Look at boxing my boxes from
the 19 hundreds to his dive son.
Danger,
danger will Robinson.
And how about Thompson
with a slick getaway?
Like not
professional defense,
right?
You don't have to standard
pros and that's his buddy Raymond.
He said get off and
sun dance stream other.
Look at that corner.
Raymond Daniels for us.
What?
What is Raymond Daniels?
Roddy champion champion
also ignites the glory.
You have to acknowledge me.
I can't believe you don't know who he is.
Who makes good tick off like a chimpanzee.
If you guys,
it makes my asshole,
my Dick went narrow one guy.
Sorry cause I was running hard for this.
I clenched step like say please God.
Let me not have heard that curry.
Who's running with dance?
My fucking heart hurts.
He says top one of the top
kickbox walks in the world.
I know,
there you go.
I can know what he is.
And he was asking,
you guys need skin.
Nikki holds skin and um,
who?
Joseph,
What's his last name?
Thoughts.
Laney.
You Fuck fucking false fossil.
It goes to the only guys
that beat and I'm like,
I had to beat him and uh,
if they both feed them the same way,
remember that boy ty.
Hi.
Hi Guard leg kicks.
Thompson's not dawn or not.
There's a lot of pro wrestling
fans like there's sure shoot.
I saw
telling him shut up and
let Joe and Brendan Talk.
You will never get to fight for
the title cause I have a pen.
Oh,
little sneaky need of the body.
Feel credit.
Need to take a break.
Well I always feel like Rory brings
a queasiness either guy here.
I don't want either go to lose
worries at terrifying individual.
But Wonderboy,
he so fucking whip smart.
There's more pressure.
Sharp.
There's just a lot of pressure
on Roy man face of Canada.
He's going to free agency.
Wonderboy is going to be fine even though
he's 33 and I don't think that affects
Rory at the same way.
It affects a regular person.
I disagree.
I think he fights harder.
That Robbie Lawler
fight was goddamn chaos.
I rewatched that best fight
of the fucking century.
Oh much shit.
I rewatched that today.
It's amazing.
I can't even tell high am
time dressing all the fuck.
I'm talking to him that we watched.
By the way,
I was going through my DVR because I was
running out of space and I came across,
uh,
this fight,
the pluck the Rory Macdonald,
Robbie Lawler fight,
and I had to watch it.
A little bit of it again.
It was just like Jesus Christ.
How he told me when he got hit,
it went white.
It just all went white.
He couldn't see.
So he just had to sit down.
Terrible fight was chaos.
He goes,
he goes,
my nose was jamming into,
it felt like it was
jamming in my eye sockets.
She's moving just,
Oh,
just the right amount
away from wonder boys.
He's so calculated.
It's really interesting.
And he's the first guy to give Wonderboy
like real problems with his timing.
Yeah.
Cause Matt Brown said,
I don't give a fuck I've been
dead and just walk through it.
Well maybe it was a
different Wonderboy too.
Obviously wonder boys gotten better at
stuff and take downs and training with
wrestlers.
Matt Brown still got hit and
she just walked through it.
Roy's not getting really hit.
He stayed true that outside.
Yeah.
No longer at work.
Unquestionably man.
And glories threatening him everywhere.
He's,
he does something different.
Every fight to Rory comes
up with a new bag of tricks.
Every fight.
Well he does that.
Wow.
That front leg side kick is legit son.
Yeah,
they slot.
If Rory can like slide back with it,
if he sees the leg come up and
he lets his body go with it,
it's not as bad.
The serious weapon,
right.
God Damn Fun Foot High Egg.
That's the,
that's a,
the benefits of leaving
your leg out there.
Do you remember us talking
about this like 10 15 years ago?
Oh good.
That's a great shot.
Members talking about those karate guys.
I'm like,
they're coming man.
And Roy can wrestle guys that
can throw these fucking kicks.
I've seen them.
I've seen these gangs.
Right elbow.
They're going to learn
how to do everything else.
Sure Dude,
Wonderboy and I owe to,
the buys is blocking it though.
But the shots,
the body suck that up.
It's like a investing and it
pays off in the frown fight man.
It's a long fight.
Oh that didn't go more.
This fight goes on.
The more those body shots
are going to mean something.
Dude,
I've made want to buy and multiple
cards cause we had the same manager.
So that's the way sometimes
it lines up and wonder.
Boy's dad trains him and he'd be in
the back crying and I'm like this guy's
about to get his ass whooped.
And he'd go out there and starched
dude's fucking starched dose.
Cause whenever I see a guy crime,
like you're fucked bro.
He'd go out there and fuck dudes up.
Yeah,
he can handle it.
He just going through it,
gets it out of system and it
goes out there and perform.
So I feel like a man.
I feel like crying.
How often to guys quit from leg kicks
to the arms like very other fighters.
They're just like,
fuck that.
I'm done.
What's his name?
Had that guy quite well.
Frank shamrock with Kang Lee recently.
What was his name to go?
Got Arm barred by Jacques Hurray.
Who just fought recently?
Yeah,
he,
he was his knees broke down.
He did it to other people out
there that quit from leg kicks APP.
There's some fire kicks.
Remember?
Remember it more one of
the arms or legs or bands?
Man,
it really depends dude.
Remember when it's on the arm too.
Like if you kick someone here,
like right here,
it's significantly easier for you to
absorb than if you get kicked here.
Dude,
who's,
who's homeboy?
The Dutch kickboxer and spot in the UFC.
Did I make sense with that?
No idea.
Anthony made a guy quit liking is here
to block a kick here than it is a block
kick.
Yes.
As you,
if you're blocking the kick higher
towards your hands and your arms,
your arm gets real weak.
I'll give you get kicked in the middle.
Like up here,
he's probably going to get
your arm broken chains here.
You might be okay.
The same kick here like might
hurt the other guy shin.
It's a difference.
A big difference between
catching an elbow,
like catching a shin,
but you still don't want it now.
Right?
Want to,
you can definitely break you guys foot.
Like if a guy throws,
see one of the things about wonder boys,
he throws in step kicks,
which is really interesting
because his distance is way better.
It's might not be like the
best thing for leg kicks,
like leg kicks.
You want to use shit.
That's why with the leg kicks you wanna
you shinbones but with he can throw in
step kicks that are super powerful.
Him Traditional Thai kicks,
he boy,
he does those two.
He didn't do those too.
But what I'm saying is
there's a difference when a
guy's really good with the
instep that gives you almost an
extra foot of area where you,
where you're impacting except a lot of
the really good Dutch kickboxers like an
airshow.
Hoost he would wrap that foot
around the back of your head.
Who would blam so he would
really tuck you into like,
like when you like flex your foot,
he would tuck you to sleep right in
there cause it hit the back back,
back,
back.
He'd Punch,
hit jab paunch and then just throw it,
throw it over the top of
your shoulder and chop.
How tall is he?
Six.
Four at least.
He's a very tall man and I met up a bunch.
That's,
it's a very nice guy too.
And so skillful.
What a great kick boxer.
He was
right hand.
But what I'm saying is like Wonderboy
offers like a lot of weird shit that if
you don't prepare for him,
which Roy clearly did bring it in.
Raymond Daniels,
he could be a real problem to you
because his distance is so much good.
More hooked by then.
You think it should be?
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Closing that distance really?
Well God want to push it away.
Fuck cancer's back with speed.
He said he does what?
Look were Maury sheet
moving very well here.
But,
but the thing about Wonderboy
is you've got a mind.
Oh,
your p's and q's.
You get a fucking dot your i's and cross
25 minutes just like medical j white.
You're writing for 25 minutes.
Are you going to sleep?
I'm just saying [inaudible]
Smith Smith's slash why?
When you watch your fucking p's and q's,
bro.
Hey,
buy him a drink and thank him for his
work and shop to lock up the spawn.
It ends this beautiful kickback.
Don't get fraud.
Wonderboy.
Wonderboy just miss changed to wonder,
man.
Oh,
how many times something,
man,
I'm so impressed with the controlling
of distance by Roy as well.
You should weigh uses that high left hand,
that guard.
Look how he does this.
He like leans forward with his arms
straight up in the air on the left side,
and that's something he
used against Tyron Woodley.
He shutdown Woodley's right hand.
Well,
he just jumped.
He just jumped.
He just jumped a half dog.
He's looking for that.
They're just going right to the legs.
He's got a ride if he Sweetser and
gets on top of this to be brilliant.
Oh my goodness.
It's gone after.
Hammer fist.
Look at this shit.
Oh my goodness.
Who's lippy gentlemen?
We have a very even fight here.
Racy,
but gets right back up to his feet.
Yep.
Wonderboy slick as fuck.
Beautiful fucking technique
by Wonderboy,
right?
Hey wanna fucking chess match,
man.
This is no different than Steph
curry versus Lebron James.
It's just brilliant.
That left hand Wonderboy
just landed moving away.
Very slick.
Dammit.
You don't wonder why
fights to total hands down,
man.
It's fine.
Total hands down.
Total hands down in these punches
are coming up from the hips.
Look at us.
You got to Mexico and
he will blitzkrieg on.
Dude,
it's not landing.
Notice it.
But Roy is doing a great
job minimizing the damage.
Great shop and constant pressure.
So again,
wonderful.
As we were saying before,
he's got to move back more,
causes more.
It's a little bit less natural.
The moving back and jumping in.
Whereas Rory Rory,
he's just started plotting forward.
Just keeping the distance with that long,
straight left hand and threatening
every time they engage.
Hey,
good luck judging this fight down.
Oh Gosh.
Jamie.
Jamie is the man and he sent me
sweet baby.
Fuck you.
Fuck you somebody.
Track TV.
Fuck you.
America.
Who's the Donald Trump who did this?
Ted Cruz.
Fuck you.
Fuck everybody.
They finally got those.
Wow.
Oh the,
Oh yeah.
Come on God.
Good luck judging this fight.
God mastery.
It's mastery.
This is an interesting man.
Oh,
that's a bit of someone's
gonna land something major.
Maybe not,
man.
This could be a a five round it fair.
That's very similar to what
we're seeing right now.
If both guys keep their fitness,
they're going to realize is an imminent
threat and any kind of like any opening
and he'd taken chances.
Roy's going to have to grapple
to test the fitness at Thompson.
He's comfortable.
He's been trying to really,
not really that fucking,
that right hand and he's
putting in front of his film.
My very,
very,
very nice.
I got wonder boy at this point.
Well,
both guys look really good,
dude.
This is a tough fight to jug.
Absolutely.
Who the fuck fights like wonder boy man,
look at this guy switching stances.
Hands down low.
I feel like he's,
he's sitting in his
house though right now.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you're not going to get tired.
He could do this for 10 rounds.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
Has to force a grappling.
Well,
if he starts to feel like Rory slowing
down a little bit and he can relax,
he can do more of this shit.
This just chill man.
God linking with sandstone.
All right,
and you're making,
you should like open up one
of those psychic places.
I'm telling you how to feeling,
Bro.
I had a feeling.
I'm telling you,
I'm telling you it's
going to win this fight.
He's going to win this fight.
You know the odds are I know,
but I just do.
I have an overwhelming feeling
that he's going to win.
And you and a shitload other people.
You're a crazy person.
Mama cleaned up for the fight.
I'll tell up people did not
the way I did it though.
And that was my conviction.
New crazy person.
Brian,
I don't know how you're going to judge us.
Fire crazy.
You can say Roy's winning
cause the octagon control.
I don't know.
Listen,
this is an office also in Canada.
You,
I don't care.
They're fuckers.
Seriously.
This is a fucking awesome fight is an
interesting fight and this is on chess.
Match is a super high level,
a fair between that two of the
most dangerous guys on the planet,
Gaia and Royce Corner
looks like Roy in 20 years.
They looked very similar.
The same,
same oblong face could be his brother.
Yeah.
It might be his dad.
His Dad speaks trainer,
Wonderboy Thompson,
Cutie Pie.
By the way,
if you're talking about like top,
don't lie no more that
we can't do that anymore.
Yeah,
just to match.
They get mad.
Too much gay stuff that's not gay.
I'm just saying.
I understand you're
trying to get auditions.
If you were looking at,
if you were aesthetically looking at
fighters and you had to choose models,
he'd be in your top five.
Fuck you.
Boy.
I don't want to do this anymore.
We've been on Alan Jobe and number line.
Yeah,
and one divorce in the top five.
No,
this makes me wonder,
man.
He's 33 there's no 33
there's been natural.
Robert Redford?
Yes.
No,
it has Wonderboy.
That's where the name came from.
It has to be wonder,
man.
He's three.
No,
no,
no.
Robert Redford was like 50 came back.
If I'm the kid,
he's a boy.
Runs that's embarrassed.
You look great.
It looks great.
Skin was a little loose,
but could bomb stretch.
Oh,
look at that one.
If I can catch,
he can catch it from every angle.
I like saying obvious things.
Oh,
sorry.
Sidekicks.
You know what?
If I was a feminist writer,
I'd be really mad at that movie.
The natural plus.
I'm like evil woman,
and it just took away the genius
of some very masculine man.
How old is that?
Moves me.
Is Old as fuck.
So they did.
It wasn't even a photograph.
There's all just cartoons.
I have never heard of it.
Why?
It's a great movie with Brendan.
It's a really good mood and natural.
I'll check it out.
It's about baseball in the early days.
Oh yeah.
I'll check it out for black people figured
out how to play it until black people
are keeping it said hello.
How are you doing that
with a blind make money?
We have,
let me see this way better genetics.
Wait til they fucking
find out about hockey.
We're all fucked and we live on an island.
This is a crazy fun.
We play baseball better
than you and we're coming.
We're coming,
man.
What the fuck?
You guys are fucked.
Randy Johnson.
He's fucked you Steve Garvey.
He had four arms.
It didn't even look like
they belonged on a person.
It's like who shaved down that
gorilla gave it a baseball bat.
This forearms.
It was almost like his forums.
Like someone saw it off the last,
Reggie Jackson is five inches.
Really?
He was so thick.
It was retarded.
Hey Brennan,
such as you grew up a baseball fan.
Yeah.
Did you ever play like charades?
Like guess who I am and he like,
yeah,
like a Guy
Steve Garvey Garvey.
I still got some things
you'll never forget it.
It was like,
and people her live.
Brian Downing.
Brian,
Brian down.
If from the angels a
no,
I'm talking like Ryan Sandberg.
Oh,
we talked about is you look at
Wonderboy and catch him fight compasses.
Crazy.
The shark.
We just jumped the shark when Eddie
starts on baseball and fucking him,
he met Wonderboy just
landed a sled combination.
Yes,
he did.
He's,
he's,
I think I started as baseball
thing and I apologize.
No,
I dig it.
Look your Wonderboy,
Mr. Short,
shorter watch baseball takes
too long board about soccer.
I've been trying to watch soccer lately.
Soccer Fund,
right.
Especially now with the Copa America Cup.
Yeah.
It's been interesting,
man.
Americans,
I'm not really like trying
to do this by nationality.
You try to do this?
Nope.
Nope,
nope,
nope.
I'll give up u s and this is the first
time ever in my life I've had a chance to
acknowledge athletes from other
countries as if the countries that,
uh,
we all enjoy watching performed.
They don't,
I,
I'm not a part of this competition.
Sham American.
Joe,
I'm enjoying watching you
cheer for Chris Weidman.
INSTRUC gray.
I would not.
I know.
I'm just kidding.
Can't do it.
I don't allow myself job,
but it's,
I don't allow myself
like for whatever,
whether it's bullshit or you,
right.
It's like whatever.
Let's have a reason to unite.
Let's just,
let's fucking start USAID Columbia.
Fuck you.
Columbia on this day.
Fucking Columbia,
right?
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that,
but agents,
there's nothing wrong with,
I have a USA Soccer Jersey and I,
where'd brow naked?
Just a hard on soccer jerseys
for Elton John Sunglasses.
Blue Raccoon hat out of a real record
that he caught eating out of his garbage.
Killed it with a rock.
Wonder why is impossible it
tachy can't touch Wonderboy.
The owner.
What am I talking about?
The any idea at all?
Sorry Buddy.
I'm so into this fight.
I can't help it.
Oh,
good level.
Good Jab.
By golly,
I heard tiger or something
from one of your,
I know tigers.
Don't worry about it,
bro.
I saying I love soccer.
We talking about Charlie
Sheen and I can't.
Now I'm watching this thing of beauty,
this poetry in motion,
both of them,
but one of the boys you can't touch.
Wonder boy.
He's got a hickey on his neck.
Hickeys sidekick is beautiful.
He's eight.
He's winning this fight and
he's winning decisively.
Who's winning this fight?
I wonder.
Boy Keeps.
She keeps hitting control.
No,
he keeps hitting worry.
Keeps hitting this.
Let's all be honest.
We haven't been paying attention.
He's been breaking on USA hockey keepers,
Columbia.
I was watching the wonder
boy hasn't been touched in.
Might be lying.
He's,
he's punching Rory.
I'm over and over again.
Not Hard,
but he's connected with Brian.
You might want to stay
offline for a couple of days.
Definitely don't check.
Oh,
definitely.
Stay away from Facebook.
Brian Cowen care.
I'll be in Florida.
I'll be an off the academy in Naples.
June 23rd 24th 25th it's like sometimes
it's better to just watch it and greed.
You don't have to talk.
Listen,
I get excited.
Look at this.
I've made mistakes.
Didn't land be Ted.
Let him know that.
Didn't
foresee talking a little
fights.
I get excited,
Bro.
I can't help it.
I view more as you do it.
Accent best.
Least make it entertaining.
You want to say something?
Say only accurate.
So we just trying to say is 10 years some
ridiculous person that we don't know.
Instead of our friend Brian
was saying retarded shit.
All right.
I like the Brazilian.
You're Brazilian voice,
so if you're going to say
civil about the fight,
just give me an,
I'll do him as an Englishman.
Rough.
Have you done to get hopeless?
Oh,
that was terrible.
On a second.
Have we ever gotten him
w together with Hanako?
How's that?
We'll be talking to
talk about that forever.
How's that possible exactly.
Oh my God.
This week around this week on the
farm when you leaving for Florida,
I'll be leaving for the off
the hook comedy club in Naples,
June,
June 22nd to perform June 23rd 24th
and 25th what's in your fucking mouth?
Pickles.
Don't chew into the microphone.
Not you know many goddamn
complaints I get about you choose.
If you smack into the mic,
you just did.
US Son of a bitch.
Stay off Twitter.
I'm telling you guys,
hey Melanie,
lay low.
I want to lay low for a Dallas.
Do I always do?
Anyway,
I got to step up my Twitter game guys.
Let's watch four minutes.
35 second front leg side kick is nasty
because when it different sheet Wonderboy
and anybody will Raymond Daniels for sure,
but between one point and a
lot of guys that you'll spark,
he said he could hurt you with that
front leg side kick to the body,
the front lake sacks to the body.
It's got like a real snap to it.
Whereas a lot of guys who just,
they do it a lot of times they touch
you with the ball of the foot more than
they're hitting you with like
the side blade or the heel,
but Wonderboy is stuffing it in there.
He's too hard.
Good toe.
Very nice.
Roary caught him with that left hand that
that right arm across the face in that
left arm extended.
Very interesting.
Almost like the George Foreman fight.
Aren't she more style?
I mean come on.
Wonder Boys catching a horse.
You got to think about
Octagon Control Brian.
It factors into it.
Does it matter when you're getting at
he's punching him those kind of with the
left.
She landing stuff too though.
Really Baba.
I disagree.
Honestly.
This is a very good fight.
It's a great fun with
these guys are just caught
him with a left hook hard.
I know it's true,
but I know you want her to win
and I love Rory and I love,
I fucking love him.
Just shut the fuck up.
Hey,
can I have to say that Brian was a judge?
We'd have to kill him.
Just watch the fight.
I'm quiet.
Look guys,
I think I'm being accurate here.
I'm being fair.
It's a very good fight.
Look at Rory sneakers would
agree with you brother.
[inaudible] he's sneaky ass.
Right hand copy strike
would agree with you Brian.
I'm just saying an octagon
control and significant strikes.
Roy might be winning.
Yeah,
I don't know man.
It's in fucking Canada is not
not coming close to winning bub.
He's just not,
I'm sorry he's not watching this.
Stop worrying about the end of the
goddamn fight and enjoy the fucking fight,
which is playing.
You guys are talking about
you guys talking about soccer.
Stopped thinking about who won
while it's actually happening.
You fuck heads.
I'm not really mad shit.
You Go.
I'm so mad.
You're just [inaudible] to stop.
It needs to stop.
You're passionate,
well controlled without
doesn't make say Jamie,
listen man,
I'll you this Roy pulling to
the ground home like this.
But again,
the judges when you get
pulled to the ground,
they're viewing it as one.
The boy getting Tory is trying
to attack him from his back.
He felt like that was a good idea.
Right?
Is that what happened or what did,
yeah,
he pulled them down.
Right.
I'm not imagining that.
I'm no fucking happen.
That was hard.
Who's,
we can't pull side control.
I mean you want to post card?
Yep.
Do this might lose up Roy.
The fight and these Wonderboy
almost are pretty fucking white.
So close.
And then when you pull
fucking site control,
you know Eddie,
you like one of the first guys to
say that it was before one a cro,
cop's fights.
You and I were talking and you were saying
like when you get a guy who's like a
real experience,
Stryker,
they can generate some power
and like a real close area.
Like you were noticing that if there was
guys who could do ground and pound from
inside the guard,
even where you see what vandalling
pride back in the pride days,
you see ventilated.
He wanted me to stay standing,
but he was rarely in the gold,
but Oh,
you heard him?
Oh No.
Oh.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
he hurt Roy's.
Hi.
Oh,
I don't know what he hit him with the,
I think he hit him in the nose,
but I think he hit with
the left hand nightmare.
He's covering up.
What did he hit him with?
Oh yeah,
he's bleeding heavy.
Snow.
Snow sucked up that same
knows that he broke it to rob.
Look at wonder boys cardio and I
really just say that's the same nose.
He broke in the Robbie Lawler fight.
2042 seconds.
If I was UFC had fire me,
they
call me up right now.
I'll give you a bonus.
I give you a fucking promotion.
That's enough.
We've seen enough.
Brian Stann,
right?
Family seven,
whichever.
Say this.
Let's say Roy,
he's bleeding bad or that knows man,
that does not look good.
All jokes aside,
let's say knows that that he used
to breed that up when he was fine.
No,
no,
no zebra out.
But he was too.
He broke that same note.
That's a note that knows,
you knows locking first.
Wonderboy came members,
mamas smell the fresh sanitize area
of the hospital that says he knows.
They know son.
Wah.
Okay,
so Brian,
since you are paying attention so closely,
much more than any of us,
you really do judge a
fine 100% without a doubt.
Wonderboy and buy without a doubt.
Without a doubt.
The strengths are.
What do you think?
It definitely looks like
Thompson when the phone,
what do you think as you,
but you think Roy McDonald might've got
the nod because of a black helicopters
and chem trails because the tower
seven don't start with that shit again.
So if that's scary,
I'm scared.
Please.
Were you paying attention enough to,
to really give an honest
reading of who won the fight?
Yes.
Wonderboy,
definitely one.
Thank you.
I have to say way too hard.
Too many drinks.
I was super impressed with two things.
One.
I was super impressed with Roy's that
the weird defense is using what that high
left hand and that right
hand almost across his face
like Archie Moore Style and
definitely like he was really
good at controlling the distance.
But I think like as the rounds went on,
you started to see Wonderboy getting a
little more comfortable and relaxing into
that sniping,
jumping back and forth style.
And that's when uh,
that's when the tide started to change.
It looked like to me where it started
to establish that Wonderboy was getting
slightly better in each exchange.
And that's what we talked about
actually before the fight started.
I was saying if Wonderboy can land
one or more punches and eats exchange,
then Rory can pick it.
And that adds up over time.
That's exactly what happened.
50 45,
50 45 Wonderboy,
Wonderboy,
54 boys,
I've got to go do some standup comedy.
I love all three of you
and love you too baby.
I love you Jay.
I love you and love you
to see your boys later.
And you were a hundred percent
correct on the scoring Colby.
You nailed it.
And now
finding is my secret garden guys.
So please treat me really,
really high level fight,
man.
I think we can all agree this.
Sit down,
sit down,
blah blah.
For one second.
Let's wrap this up.
Go ahead.
You don't have a show
until you have a half hour.
Sit down.
Have a fuck those people.
I know this.
There's a guy,
there's always a guy.
But um,
this was like a,
this is a super interesting style fight,
right?
As well as yes,
it's almost a new blood,
right?
I mean Wonderboy is the new blood.
He just is Roy Roy's younger,
more dynamic.
You have to give Wonderboy
the title shot here for Rory.
It's a tough road because
now he goes into free agency.
I make a call.
I called Robbie.
Lawler is the baddest
motherfucker on the planet one.
A boy will beat him.
I beat him the same way
he beat Johnny Hendricks.
It's a very tight group.
I agree 100% with Brian on that content.
Yeah,
but you gotta you can't
dismiss Tyron Woodley.
Yes,
you can buy same thing and do
the same thing with giant hands,
Robbie and Tyron Woodley or funny.
You can't pretend that you know what's
going to happen and I will and I will.
That's what we're doing as usual.
What do you think's going to
happen in that fight with Tyron?
Well,
Robbie Lawler,
you think you know what's going to happen?
I think,
I think that rock and bar,
I think Robbie Lawler and pills,
no.
Listen,
one red bike thing and then
I'm going to get out of here.
Listen,
let me drop this.
I think Robbie,
Robbie Lawler has something that,
that I've never seen a fighter and
that is in round five and I'm not
exaggerating.
He's more pumped,
has more energy than it doesn't round one.
And on top of that,
that doesn't hear something indestructable
about that guy either major.
Yes I am.
And so as Paul Felder
off the Comedy 23rd 28 r y
a n c a l l e n at Twitter,
that fucking such a savage.
So funny.
He's such a fucking savage.
So finally he called
to show just stand up.
It's got a show.
I don't know where to show.
So this is like exactly what
we said before the fight out.
You know what I was saying
that if Wonderboy can just
get a couple extra punches
in each exchange or one every now and
again those are going to accumulate.
Ooh,
I don't like that.
That open hand shit.
He landed a palm to the face first.
Rory is young,
but he's had some miles on
him while he's had that.
Robbie Lawler fight was absolutely
brutal and this was a less brutal fight.
But yeah,
definitely took some water.
Boy for sure.
He just the next title shot.
That was the thing about beat the
number one guy in the world watching the
Robbie Lawler fight again.
Oh,
I almost forgot.
Not really forgot,
but I had to be reminded a little
bit of how primal that fight was.
Oh,
barbaric.
Close guys,
Baird at all.
I like,
but the thing is I like
wonder boys chances against
Woodley or a fucking Robbie
Lawler.
He's super like his chances
against both of them.
He's super dangerous,
especially if they'd take a
chance to try to hurt him.
Ooh.
See the thing about open up,
it's not going to decision.
If you take a chance,
he's going to capitalize on it.
He can do that little slide back.
Counter lefthand can nasty man
and he can fight from southpaw
or Orthodox too,
man.
You know,
40 fights from southpaw.
A lot of it is those sidekicks,
his front leg side case,
but God damn man,
he can do that from the left side too.
He get through those front legs.
He's been doing karate since he was three.
He's literally that guy
that you always joke about.
Eddie Brown would always joke about it.
He goes,
he goes,
if you took a dude who was doing like
karate from the time he was three,
one was like Super Ninja.
There was like 52.0 and you taught him
how to stand up and avoid take downs.
How good would he do against
most of the strikers?
There you go.
We used to,
you and I used to have these
conversation title next.
It's almost like you created
this dude with your imagination.
You know what other conversations we
used to have his back in the dark days of
the UFC when it was underground on,
on direct TV,
only,
only on satellite is the days are over.
We have shows like this,
you know what an networks with baseball
scores on the bottom and they're in
these big ESPN type studios that like
one of these days that's going to happen.
And it's,
it's like nothing now everywhere.
What do you,
what do you do?
Where does Roy McDonald go from here?
Starts to fray and see,
well,
you know what,
it was a very close fight,
but he,
he lost a decision to Wonderboy.
Who Right now is the best in the fucking
world that standing up and doing this
doesn't matter that slides in a outside.
No,
no,
no.
But I'm saying is he still a few years
younger than Wonderboy and I think he
learns from this fight
and gets even better.
But I think this is a Goddamn wake
up call to the rest of the division.
This Wonderboy dude is legit as fuck.
And his angles and all this shit.
We're seeing this creativity,
this ability to stay in the pocket
and not get hit nearly as much.
Throw a lot of dangerous shit.
Look at these angles man,
and take shots.
Tagged him there with that left hand.
All all I'm saying is if
you're wearing Mcdonald,
he lost the number one guide and I less
than number two guy would go back to the
drawing board.
He keeps swaying and you're 26
years was signed with UFC game.
You don't test for agents.
Who knows?
Dude,
it's no.
When you say free agency,
no one is saying that the UFC isn't going
to counter the offer and they're going
to come to a nice,
I'm saying if you're already just signed
with the UFC and try fighting for the
kid,
I think he could absolutely
be a world champion.
Either saying Bella tour or in the UFC
world champion in any organization.
It's,
he's 26 man,
like he has like four or five
years before he hits his prime.
But what are you looking at with the,
with Wonderboy right now it's one
of the slickest sneakiest strikers,
one of the best guys at
moving back and calendaring.
I don't see anyone them and tall.
I thought Wonderboy was
this toughest style.
A style wise matchup possible.
I think it'd be too willing.
I think you'd be to Robbie Lawler.
I think he smokes Robbie Lawler.
Be Honest.
That's so crazy.
I know.
It's crazy.
I don't know.
You can be so competent.
I agree.
I just think if he,
if he,
if he got past Rory,
that was his biggest test.
I thought,
man,
there's not a worse match up
guy who can grapple strike,
do everything and he's smart.
He's not.
You can take chances.
You beat him.
You're off to the races.
Robbie Lawler's apart burying dude
straight by bearing buddy brawls and brawl
brought with Wonderboy Thompson.
That doesn't end well.
Maybe calculated maybe or maybe
Robbie Cass's US seven opponents.
Maybe Robbie catches in the way.
Jake Ellenberger caught
him and he puts them away.
That's entirely possible.
Yeah,
but what'd he do to make a hamburger?
Maybe catch some bad case,
the midnight totally to look
totally possible as well.
What I'm saying is nobody knows what's
really going to happen until they get
into it,
but when I see a guy like Robbie Lawler,
I see a guy that's like,
it's less like the physical punishment
that he's taken in these chaotic wars
with Hendrix catches.
Sorry.
Unless that catches up with them.
You're looking at a God damn
barbarian straight by Robbie Lawler.
It goes to war.
He goes to war with every
Adam in his big picture.
He has blood on his arm for coming today
and you know who's the most dangerous
fucking fight for him?
That dude right to the right Maya.
Fuck yeah.
Not fighting him though.
He's nothing,
but if he ever does Damien Maia
is dangerous to everybody fucker.
When does he get the title shot?
It's going to be a well,
well,
you know what,
man,
here's the thing.
I don't understand ratings.
It's all subjective.
It seems like there's some
by the decisions that get
B done that get done rather
when one guy beats another guy and this
guy agreed this guy was number three and
this guy,
the greasiest cards number two.
But you know,
you might have a different agreement than,
or different opinion rather than I do.
And I think,
uh,
it's,
it's a subjective thing.
So I,
I've tried to reserve,
but the UFC also Trump's
rankings cause VLC goes well.
We want Damien had to fight and get flight
drinking him for three wheel to fight
to the title next.
They're going to make it happen.
Well Damien's an interesting
guy because he's older for sure.
Fought for the title 85.
And what he's been doing,
the guys when he gets them on
the ground is nothing short,
hard.
Mauling Gunnar Nelson,
they keep tossing these young lines,
these starches.
Gunnar Nelson,
Neil Magnuson,
Neil Magni.
In that sense,
I'm,
uh,
almost like them.
The enemy of two different types of people
here on the enemy of the people that
want to respect the rankings because I
sometimes just want to see what happens.
I want to see what happens when guys
fight certain guys and it's one of the
things that I don't necessarily
like about the idea titles.
Oh can I see a guy like Robbie Lawler?
Like I understand that he's the world
champion are specked that and it's fucking
amazing.
But really what I care
is that Robbie Lawler's,
Robbie Lawler,
which he is exactly what she is and I
want to see Robbie Lawler fight other guys
that are intriguing.
Like in to me,
Robbie Lawler was Thompson.
Oh you told you it's completely 100% a
hundred percent a hundred percent I'm
with you 100% I mean like
I'd like that fight as well.
I'm telling you.
I also like Tyron Woodley.
I like Tyron Woodley
for the Oh shit factor.
I like Tyrone Woodley for his ability to
close the distance and restaurants and
wrestle like a motherfucker and
it's serious knockout power.
I like Tyron Woodley
against almost anybody.
He's dangerous man.
Just striking to me.
Trouble against these top guys.
I think there's a lot of fucking high
level guys in the one 70 division.
And what interesting.
What's interesting to me about
Damien Maia is I see the,
what he does to guys like Rick Story and
I see what you guys had it does to guys
like Neil Howe magnate and I go
with elite daily and Maya all.
Luckily Damien Maia,
well,
we see this time and going,
oh,
we see Tyron Woodley with some
ridiculous Nate Marquardt asked one punch
knockout.
I want fuck knows man.
But I think that's a super
powerful fighting a guy
like Woodley ain't so fun to
try to take down either because
he closed the distance on him.
He hits hard and fast
like Rory did here.
Like with doe from those legs.
It didn't pay off really.
It looked good.
Or in the first round though,
didn't it?
It'll look cool,
but you know,
did someone give
Wonderboy the first round?
Yeah.
Fed Up to judges had it 40 40 45 what
did you think about the first round?
A few.
If you had to guess,
I would have gave a sudden
you're shadowing memory,
right?
Based on this fucking
peanut Nawara amendment.
I give the first round to Roy and then
after it appeared that he lost the rest
of them.
God Damn,
I love the way Wonderboy slides
in and out of these shots.
He's,
I'd love how he stays in the
pocket to and throws all these,
these angles there and there.
He realized it hurt him.
Did y'all talk about a guy who realizes
his standup potential but he's worked on
his grappling and take
down the fence so much?
He was so comfortable training out of
his gym and South Carolina and went,
ah,
who's the best?
Well,
let's go to Weidman's camp and get
annihilated for months and months.
A month so I can get better
at one 70 that's not,
that's how many guys do that.
I know.
He figured it out.
It's cool man.
Well,
and he's also trained by
his dad and now it's crazy.
Most most of us,
father,
son relationships are tough to
bring someone else into men.
They figured it out.
Yeah,
they must have figured it out.
But he's a,
he's an interesting thing
because he brings a totally
new sort of a style to the
top of the heap.
Like there's no on the top of the heap
that mimics that we've had the wrestlers
before and you know,
the Matt Hughes,
Johnny Hunter and Johnny Hendricks,
like really powerful wrestlers.
You know,
Matt Hughes would get more submissions
and a lot of ground and pound victories.
And Johnny Hendricks got a
lot of standup victories,
a lot of standup chaos like that crazy
Fitch Kayo and the Martin Kampmann Kale.
Johnny had some ridiculous one
lefthand the bomb Kaos Jesus.
So there's,
they're different in that way,
but um,
it's,
it's real interesting.
We see a guy that you
haven't seen before really,
and a karate guy like wonder boy with his
crazy undefeated kickboxing record and
you can't figure it out because
no one's figured it out.
Really.
George Saint Pierre told me he's the
best tracker that he's ever sparred one.
Ha Ha.
I'm telling you,
man,
towards St Pier brought him
to Denver and we were like,
who's this skinny kid?
And like,
oh all he's going to do.
Cause at the time he was
even thinking about MMA,
he's just striking.
How have you seen rush hour where Chris
Tucker eats kicked in the face of guy?
Which one?
Y'All did it.
I'm telling you when he's sparred with us,
I was like,
ah,
I don't know shit.
I wasn't the only one that felt like that.
George St Pier,
Nate,
Shane and Neymar car,
all of us went in and just got raw,
wracked,
wracked.
Well he's looked like amateurs.
He's the best example of someone that
knows that other style and implements it
in an MMA fight because that's style
is always been a question mark.
I was like,
how come some of these
national karate champion Dudes,
I haven't gotten into
MMA because if they do,
they'll sport karate guys
and the sport taekwondo guys,
more of this poor karate guys on a lot
of ways because some of their matches a
concentrate more on punches.
A lot of them are swift
punches to the face,
like even a sport punch.
Uh,
you know,
one point karate guys,
the point crying,
we can tag a guy,
they stop,
they'd still concentrate more on punches
to the face then the taekwondo guys.
So,
but you can get like a really good
combination of the two of those techniques
and if those guys get into MMA,
man they,
they're so hard to hit because they'll
sport karate guys are used to just
jumping back and forth on each
other and the judge Calloway.
Yeah,
that's their whole shit.
I think waterboy is going to
sit the blueprint for some
of those guys because he
and golfed himself into
grappling to Conor.
Mcgregor is considered one of those guys.
Right.
I mean any other background?
When I was,
when I was really good at taekwondo,
when I was winning state championships,
I had a karate match.
I took a fight,
a tournament,
a point karate tournament and I fought
this dude named mafia Holloway who was
like this big time point karate
guy and this guy fuck me up.
I couldn't,
I couldn't get ahold of them because I
was used to like continuous style kicking
this.
It wasn't used to this,
this Darden's smashed start
in with a punch to the face.
They big would Darden on you.
Then everything would stop and you go,
Oh,
okay,
I'm way behind on this.
Like I should have trained for this.
I think I trained for like kickboxing
or for taekwondo and this guy had this
totally different thing.
And I remember um,
from that one match,
which uh,
you know,
it didn't last very long and I didn't,
I didn't get hurt in it,
but I definitely got tagged.
He tagged me with the front leg side
kick to the body and a couple of other
things.
But I remember thinking like,
man,
I got to rethink my whole approach to
darting in and out because they don't like
taekwondo guys don't necessarily do that
to the same with the same explosion,
the same distance covering.
And then I remember thinking those guys
are really hard to catch and those guys
to get really good at that thing.
And you've seen it with that kid in,
in Beltour Michael Page,
Michael Page,
Michael Fan page,
same thing.
You're seeing the same thing.
Like to see him against
tougher competition.
Did you grow up doing karate is yes.
He's a bad motherfucker dude.
He says karate champion in his last
fight he got fucking do put up his
highlights is,
is um,
Wikipedia so we can find out
what his actual credentials are.
The Herald tonight cowboy.
Yes,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
But you know what man,
that Michael Van and page,
I don't want to break
from him because he's no,
no,
it's okay.
But he's,
he's something new.
He's a unique guy,
man.
No one can figure him out.
Well he's,
he's like way,
way above the guys.
He's fought so far.
They just cool.
You don't law.
I understand,
but they don't belong in there with them.
New Ideas.
Amazing man.
That's how it guys should be built.
What are you looking at looking at it?
It says Wikipedia a record.
Well,
let's go to the what?
He's um,
his,
uh,
credentials are,
go back to what it said,
but just karate.
It's good.
He's not fighting criminal creme because
right now he's building his experience
and he's you,
he's getting his style down.
It's just does it say here?
Timing.
Hi.
Can we get larger?
What does it say?
It says page describes the
discipline is not karate,
not talk window.
It's a hands down kickboxing style that
likens himself to a matter of don't fuck
wrote this.
We can't have fans.
Right.
Wikipedia.
I movement based fighter as game plans.
This is weird.
It's terrible.
Regularly karate.
His own style have credentials.
They have like something like
like awards or some shit.
Like does he have any kick round?
There you go.
Point karate background
clicking kickbox in her career.
Wow.
Am I really wrong about his um,
point karate background.
Did he never have kickboxing?
Kickboxing.
Okay.
I knew he had that too,
but I thought he was like a condition.
I may have thought he was too.
I might've made it up.
Maybe you told me.
Maybe I told you as an English kickboxer
Rod Credit Karthika what does it say?
Sport crowd.
A teacup.
Okay.
He did?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
Hell that's exactly it.
Sport Karate Guy.
Weird.
Yeah.
I thought,
well,
I don't know what,
what he accomplished.
I thought it was like a
very high level guy friends.
Like he's just a guy who
took a taekwondo class.
I don't think so.
Rex Quando it just fucking
karate that grow into that.
I think he hates taekwondo
according to that one.
Carrot Tika,
right?
Is that what it turned Tika?
I think it said watch
eastbound and down in
and then just fucking
kick box on the weekend it down.
It was um,
what was the fucking
what the fuck's it called Eddie?
He wants the best thing.
Got His black belt.
That fucking,
what was that?
He was working with uh,
an a,
an association called the points fighting
League where it was a team points
league.
Oh whoa.
Team points league.
Look at this cowboy with no shirt on,
but the cowboy hat on powerful
allowed that to happen.
How many gang guys are
jerking off to this right now?
1 million.
Seven more than seven.
Well,
I met 7 million
cobble Brennan job.
What was the other question that we had?
I forgot.
Hey,
I'll tell you what was fun.
Is Calorie.
Seriously.
I took him on Abbot Kinney and took him
to creation and he's just fucking so
raw.
I didn't know the green juice over here.
I'm like,
hey bro.
Fucking relaxed,
man.
How about you stop selling them out on TV?
Nah,
that's cowboy man.
He's the best.
He's the best cowboy and Abbot
Kinney mixed together like water,
noise.
He's fucking combinations by law.
I have to God,
he was the highlight of the night.
He dismantled coatings,
man,
it's too quick,
man.
Well,
some calculating how good his angles are,
man.
I agree.
It was those two right
hands and and get touched.
Either dangerous fight dude.
He beat him down.
That was ferocious.
I really liked Donald Cerrone at one
seven do you remember the first fight when
that girl kicked the other girl in
the titty and she turned around?
That's not what happened.
What she did want down and
she pulled her bra or titty.
Got Breast.
It's illegal.
Illegal.
It is illegal.
I think what happened was,
it's coming down was she
kicked her in the face,
but as her footwork was coming down,
the foot caught the bra,
the Bra pulled down the Teddy and um,
you know what happened folks.
But then she did it again and
kicked her right in the solar plex.
Well,
that was a different one.
Girl turned around and ran.
She smashed her.
I still to this day,
I want to pretend that I remember a
kick before that kick to the body.
I don't know if I'm right or not,
but either way there's three kids.
There was a base of a fight.
It was awesome.
Good night of fights.
Fuck yeah,
it was
Callin.
Watched every single one
called the other one.
He was into every single one.
He was on fire.
He was,
he was in the zone.
We tried to get him to shut the fuck up.
[inaudible] times.
We did many times we tried to get
them into talking fucking alligator.
Get Joey to make a phone
call during the main event,
like in the third round,
the fourth round,
like a Howard Harold Letterman giving his
greatest idea,
but that's a great idea.
That's a fantastic,
oh my God.
Let's stand up.
Eddie Bravo with the home run.
Yeah,
that's a great idea.
What would he say?
He called it in the,
in the fourth round is the fucking man.
That's an old school game
of debt type of shit.
Going to the corner.
He's going to pull out four knives
and cut his own fucking chat.
Come out and make foot to face bitch.
Well,
it's a great ice.
One of them.
North Carolina Christians dog ain't
never seen those people before.
That's on site.
South Carolina,
Carolina,
North Carolina,
East Carolina.
Shut the fuck up.
I'm trying to drop science.
Those people,
they're eating that fucking gumbo
that the crawfish in it dog.
It's something about the crawfish,
some about that hot spice dog.
It's a great fucking call.
Ready to live in the fucking swamps.
C'Mon man.
You ever see that fucking
swamp people show?
He would just go on some swamp
people show rant and you'd be like,
yes.
Where do start?
What
do I,
what do I,
where do I donate?
I'm going to try calling him right now.
Say
Yes.
Culture.
Oh my God.
These are really interesting man.
I enjoyed this.
I was watching this earlier,
but yeah,
it was working out and that
was watching these guys do.
There are different,
uh,
point of view.
It's like what one guy has to do to win,
but another guy has to
do to win there could.
Very interesting.
Very good.
I liked that a lot of the best.
If you watch him on ESPN,
I think he's just fucking
keep breaking them down.
Fantastic.
Got It.
You know,
I think who might have a slight edge?
Dominick Cruz,
I think Dominick Cruz is the best at it.
it's like fucking,
I think he's the best at it.
I think they're,
I think they're both fantastic.
Oh.
You haven't even seen without
chaos.
Joey Diaz.
Diaz.
Yeah.
Okay.
Negotiate the contract.
He's going to have to find
those shiny shoes on again.
Rolling.
You know,
I know he had a magical day.
That dude is great.
I mean,
you know what do you want him to me?
He's a fucking,
and he's in there.
He just can't beat those aren't.
Yep.
Do you think that Donald Cerrone
is better at one 70 Joey?
I didn't really watch him throw.
He fights so much.
It's like us doing stand up.
True.
That's true.
You know he loses water every five.
One of the every six he's
doing something right.
I don't know if he's in
Greg Jackson's camp anymore.
He does.
He still is.
He still does.
He does.
He has his own camp too.
He's got this thing called
bad motherfucker ranch.
He's got a ranch in New Mexico.
It's close to Jackson,
so yeah.
No I didn't.
I'm sorry man.
I had to do a benefit.
It was a nightmare.
They had no air conditioning.
That's the requirement.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
You can't have hot comedy.
You can have hot yoga,
hot comedy.
Oh,
we fucked.
It was like doing comedy and Philly.
He has always done that.
No,
I never noticed really helium,
the fucking hair is always last week.
It was working with,
sorry,
so it was fucking hot dog.
I'm happy I'm done.
I tell him
everything.
All right up there.
Everything's beautiful,
man.
We must your brother
then.
Right now what happened was some fucked
up because it taped and the auto racing
instead.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Are
Racing and I'm catching the
flight now with wood one before.
Yeah.
Joey really surprised me.
There was some crazy thing that happened
when Fox sports one at Fox sports two
Jamie nailed it.
It changed over while we were watching it.
That's what happened
to cause saw the girl.
Yeah,
I'll shut up.
What's your fucking car started coming in?
I don't give a fuck.
You know why?
Cause I also trade
fucking brilliant.
Joey.
Where's that on?
How do you take that?
Is that on 30 for 30 on ESPN?
You know what the beauty is about?
Oh,
Jane made the Americans.
Brian cows aren't even here.
This is Brendan and Sean.
Joey.
Oh,
how you doing Mr [inaudible]?
What's up bro?
What's beautiful about this show
is please explain it to Joe Rogan.
I'm right here.
That could've been Oj.
That could have been Brad Pitt.
That could have been Justin Bieber.
You gotta Watch your Joe Rogan because
it breaks it down all the way to,
he was at USC and the
most interesting part,
Brendan shop him when fucking Muhammad,
I leave put that thing together
for the black athletes.
Yeah.
And he said,
fuck that.
I'm not black.
I'm Oj and separate himself on blacks.
You but you know,
grow.
I think John,
uh,
the,
the uh,
the cop has the best analogy.
The old check,
big John McCarthy.
He's got the best analogy
because in one of the,
in one of the things Mark Burman went to
his house before he had a baseball bat
in his hand and mark for him and told
him twice to put the fucking back down.
And the third time he had to take out
his stick and that whole chain was just
glaring at him.
And then he came back and they said
that when that guy dies that to take his
brain because he's definitely got the
same shit that all these other things.
What CTE,
if,
if the trial was today,
they would argue CT clinically insane.
That motherfucker is crazy.
He's crazy.
What does it,
what does CTE stands for?
Chronic traumatic encephalopathy
or something like that.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
they break down.
It's tough to
chronic traumatic
encephalopathy punch.
Okay.
What that is,
and nobody could have done something.
Brendan shops,
you bet your sweet ass.
I did Jelly.
They broke it down.
Joe Rogan.
How's animalistic what he did to
the rule of biscuits?
No fade or rush.
Oh,
that old Russian track team.
No,
Bro.
That was,
went to him and got him in a
choke hold and just drawn it.
Slammed his bro
allegedly.
Oh,
they broke it down.
How do they know he did it?
100%
well,
it's not him that he did it.
How,
how anybody would do it.
This is what they said.
How can anybody would do it?
Okay.
No Way.
So they went through everything.
Yeah.
Right.
Then he went and choked him.
Caught him.
He was on the floor,
I guess two fences,
Bro.
I'm not doubting that.
I'm not doubting that
they figured this out.
He did it 100% I'm not
downing and he can't hear me.
I'm not doubting that
they figured this out.
But you know the one
thing that perplexes me,
is it a dummy?
How do,
how do they figure that out by looking
at where the bodies are like by the marks
on the ground?
Like how did they figure
that a blood at his house.
At her house,
right.
Joe Rogan.
Oh,
his hands were all fucked.
Debbie cut his leg or something.
Yeah.
And also Joey,
they're saying it was such a hate crime
that when he hit her in the throat,
it basically decapitated or,
so they're saying that it would
have to be such a passion of crime.
Like you had such a love for when you
hit someone that hard to sever their math
and almost cut her head off.
It had to been a passion of crime.
Could you imagine?
Let's assume,
let's assume that you did it.
Wow.
He was fucking making 3.5 million.
Holy Shit.
Hey Joey.
How about most of that defense team?
The how about most of
the defense team is dead.
Tara was a motherfucker.
Yeah,
but you know what
and that was the baddest
motherfucker have,
his name is Barry Scheck.
They got him on the show.
Joe Rogan.
I haven't seen puff par five brother.
I haven't seen.
I've only seen for,
hey,
is there a way to,
why I haven't seen any of these episodes?
Is there a way,
assuming I've lost my mind
and I want to be terrified.
No,
it's a brilliant song up on there.
That's the only guy.
That guy,
wow.
Come on.
It was a fucking sign.
Hey Joey.
Even to the way they dress,
they had a whole game plan.
I mean until their ties,
their suits.
They had a whole game plan.
Wow.
Fucking,
it's a,
it's brilliant.
This is the best documentary ever seen to
him.
It's amazing.
It did.
It paints a different story
on how how Oj Simpson,
he went associate himself as being black.
He didn't view himself as black.
He view himself as Oj.
So we always thought he
was bigger than the race.
It's so crazy the way they
painted the picture too.
But is that editorial choice or is
that based on his friends or family?
Mm,
but you know what,
they left out.
They only mentioned it one time,
guys.
They left doctor cocaine.
Okay.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
That's a big red flag there.
Hey,
there's a documentary
you can watch on Youtube.
Oh,
Jay,
the untold story
on youtube or Netflix.
Oh No,
it's at the library,
Bro.
[inaudible] in America on the tomato.
Right.
he had CTE.
But then you sprinkle that cocaine.
Why didn't they talk about the cocaine?
Hmm.
That's interesting.
Bring it up.
And that's a suspect.
Well,
you know,
it's interesting,
Joe.
Hello?
I said what's interesting is,
uh,
one of the doctors that
was somehow involved in the
case back in the day was on
TV recently and he was talking
about the new discoveries about CTE.
What would the new
understanding about CTE.
And they said that it is very possible
that they might have actually introduced
that into the trial back then
if they knew what they knew now,
which is crazy.
Right?
Absolutely.
It's just makes sense because
John would mark me on that.
He goes back,
guy had the different CTE,
the shit that you know you don't fuck it.
It just comes and goes,
comes and goes.
It is completely different dog.
He was an American hero
that kills a white woman.
You kind of see this Joe Rogan,
how they break it down.
It's just a long documentary.
It's 15 fucking hours.
Hey Joey,
let me ask you this man.
How much do you know about
t?
E
I don't know.
I all,
I feel I saw the movie and
he's talking.
Question.
You saw concussion?
No.
Yeah,
sure.
I showed the movie aren't you?
Started thinking about things and they
made a lot of sense to me now saying
this,
that happened over the years of
people I knew who plays football.
It just made sense to me.
Like I didn't even know about
the Pittsburgh Steelers,
all that stuff with the center
and the other guy had no idea.
But it makes sense.
That makes sense available.
It'll happen to one of my
friends when he was younger,
he was a senator
and he was also a note and he
was awesome when nose guard,
so they get hit in the head
of all the fucking time.
Wow.
So I'm looking at the kids and
how that played college ball,
they're not that solid light.
The kids I grew up with
that played college ball,
you can see that something's not,
I think the pro ball really puts it
all to you because it puts the stress
combined with the hitch and
now you're making money.
You know?
I think that really
pushes it over the end.
That's just too many years ago.
They hit in the head.
Right,
which should become a pro when
you add three or four years,
you know,
I don't know much about
it until Joe Rogan.
I know that right now I could see it
from the beginning is of it and some
fighters.
And if you don't see the beginning of it,
some fighters that you're not looking,
you could tell that they're a little box,
you know?
Well,
it's interesting because it's like when,
when do you make a decision when
you're a fighter and Brendan,
you're the only one that
could talk about this.
What do you make a decision like Gwen,
when your good friend
Joe Rogan fucking suck.
I never said you suck,
except that once you tap that button,
you keep getting knocked out.
And I can guarantee you that those people
that had more than 400 accounts over
the years,
they'll start to experience headaches
or something with that vision.
That needs to be a way with that memory.
If people listening to this,
Joey Diaz is on
speakerphone on Eddie Bravo,
his phone,
and he can't hear Brendan,
who's on the other side of the table,
cause ed,
he's got the speaker phone.
I'm just like,
it's real hard to hear.
So you've gone judge?
Yeah,
no,
no.
Joey,
I think you're dead,
right?
Yeah,
he's right.
Joey.
I think you'd dead right.
I think you're dead right?
We all do.
We all agree with you.
I was just telling people that
you couldn't hear Brendan.
Um,
I,
yeah,
it's,
um,
it's one of those things where
you've got a wonder as a fighter.
Like where do you draw the line?
Because you'll get a guy
like Alistair Overeem.
He's been stopped a bunch of times,
but Alice is about the
fight for the title,
you know,
so when do you make that call?
Because Alistair's as good as
he's ever been knocked out.
You know,
he knocked out a junior dos Santos
and a spectacular Spec type note.
Rothwell knocked him out.
Correct.
Take Ben knocked him
out in the first round.
He,
here's the question,
Joe.
What other options do they have?
That's why I stopped that.
Other options.
Most guys don't,
but he's,
yeah,
I,
that's a good point
because people can say,
well,
you've taken too many fights.
You need to stop and
do what the workforce,
fuck you.
Right.
I make six figures fighting.
I'm get punched on shitting
my pants in front of my kids.
But that's also don't you think that
there's an important point where you have
to decide like whether or not it's,
it's what you actually want to do and you
had the option to do other shit and it
was a perfect time for you to
just step back and do other shit.
But some people,
I also have Joe Rogan,
Brian Cowen who helped me
out and gave me a platform.
You're also an entertaining,
there's a lot of dudes with the,
they would do podcasts.
You'd be like,
shut that shit fucking suck.
I'm just saying the jelly.
I had other options.
Joey's snores.
Guys have to fight you still there,
Joey.
Hey,
we're gonna.
We're gonna wrap this podcast up.
Joey,
we love you man.
I you brother.
I love you.
I love you guys.
That's always the best.
He's a national treasure.
A world treasure.
He won't drive and do fine in the kit
cause it's too far to broad dark company.
Me,
I'm 51 years old.
Let me tell you something,
mother.
The fuck,
I'm 49 years old.
Let me tell you something,
bitch.
He goes,
[inaudible] 11 fuck you cock sucker.
Fuck man.
He's so fun.
He looked as the right
shit to say about it.
We're not going to get them over there
on the west side like Marina del Rey or
listen dog.
He knows and you know what?
He doesn't text.
I'll text him.
Hey Man,
can you do 11 or call me?
He'll,
he only calls.
I never text.
You run.
No danger of me and driving down to
fucking Laguna Niguel here with no danger.
Want eat?
What?
Four o'clock on a Tuesday.
How about you suck my Dick.
All right man.
You asked me to do the show
and he's in the had a mass.
Listen,
dog would make it nice and simple.
Come to my house,
Bro.
He's got his own studio now.
I know.
I went to the studio,
need to set up a student to
a studio and he was so high.
We got nothing done.
That's perfect.
Hey,
talk to me about,
hey,
you know I go on there and he goes,
talk to me about boulder.
What you weren't going to say.
Let me tell you about my story
about boulder and he's so hot,
so y'all nothing done.
I'm going to take a nap.
I want you to talk to
me about mountains and
he does he goals and ferrets.
Exactly.
Come on dog.
Dog.
Come back.
Better than ever.
Spark up the bong.
Tell me about your time in Mexico.
What do you mean you got
nothing done where you guys,
didn't you do a podcast or something?
We did a podcast.
He was just so high and we're talking
about cu boulder for two hours.
Six perfect.
Let it roll the back and he is what he is,
man.
He's perfect.
He's the best.
It's fucking hilarious.
Talk to you about some places.
He's never even been.
Those North Dakota people.
Dirty white
fucking shoes.
They want these Chinese women at sucked
at Dicks and they'd come over and
fucking old World War
Two snoopy airplanes.
They dropped them out of the sky.
They just suck your Dick and they just
fucking shoot right back off in a space.
He'll make some shit up.
He's fucking crying.
It's a total unique individual.
When are you gonna meet
another Joey d as in your life?
Never.
He calls and checks on me.
I know.
It's beautiful,
right?
It's great wonder boy nasty in this fight,
man.
These highlights were watching
wonder boys loss was
to Matt fucking bound.
Other than that needs starched everybody.
Well,
he just fought real smart.
I wish were shot with stop.
I think he probably will
eventually for sure,
but one of my favorite people
on the planet and stuff.
Well that Glover fight is going to be
hard for a proud former champion like him
to go out on if he decides to
end it on the groper fight.
Fight for him.
Who's Glover fight now?
It's a good question.
When you said Gustin in the
beginning I liked Gustafson.
I think that's a great fight,
but Gustafson already has
a fight scheduled and it
might be a reason why they
scheduled the guy against him.
Do you know who it is?
Who is a gun?
They just announced it like yesterday.
Right?
It's like I'm not ranked
in the top 10 I know that.
That's a weird fight to make,
right?
What's the name?
Starts with a B block coach.
Yon Blocker,
which is a good fighter.
He's a very good fighter,
but good enough to fight gusts when right.
Number three or 400 you can find a
highlight reel for young yon blocks of it
honestly.
But the only thing is
it's gusting is gone.
You know,
he almost beat John Jones a decision.
He'll SPDC and decision.
Then you're fighting this guy.
Well I think he,
cause he said time off.
It's almost a welcome back.
I don't like [inaudible]
had mental problems.
Welcome back.
I don't like to say almost beat.
I like to say lost a close fight too.
That's fair.
Yeah.
Can't say almost covered.
Did it really well,
he was beating John.
Who's going to beat John Jones?
Fuck had some moments.
Some good moments.
But you never had John Johnson trouble.
Jon Jones always came back.
John John's gritty as fuck.
Right.
But he came back.
You know what I'm saying?
I just won that fight.
Jon Jones won that fight,
but it was good fight.
It was a very,
very good fighter.
Close fight.
Yeah.
See like the fight where
he was in like trouble.
That's like the rumble Johnson
fight when he fought rumble.
When customers that's in trouble,
that's in trouble losing right.
That's losing the fight.
Right.
Jon Jones has never been in trouble.
Never been in trouble.
Gus Fring gave him his toughest test.
It's interesting.
Right.
You know and that's how John
or had him in an arm bar.
It's true.
That's what I'm up and slammed
him and then submitted them.
Yup.
That might be one of the most dangerous
times in his career because his arm was
completely hyper extended.
Snap does.
He showed what a bad mother fucker he is.
He did not.
He snapped his arm.
Yes.
He said he hyperextended his elbow.
It's one of the reasons why he took that
job on the ultimate fighter with Chael
Sonnen because he wasn't going
to fight for quite a long time.
So they knew that.
So they scheduled that fight next
and then if you remember correctly,
he has that fight.
He beats the shit out of jail son.
And he breaks his toe in the process.
He was pushing off the mat so fucking
hard trying to kill [inaudible] son and
then he broke his own
toe and spun it around.
You remember that Shit.
He's a fucking monster.
Even realize it until he looked
down on for pound number.
He was standing there
after the fight was over.
I was talking to him and then he looked
down and realized that he had twisted
his toe upside down.
Fucking nightmare.
Good luck had motherfucker
and if DC done beat them,
it's all where everyone's motherfucker.
But here's the thing,
and I don't know if he's right,
but Greg Jackson was saying that he
thought that one of the things about John
being,
I didn't think you was sluggish.
I thought he took a lot of time off any,
a lot of pressure.
I thought he fought very creatively
and I thought he thought,
well us,
yes,
bad chick.
No,
I didn't.
I did.
I definitely don't
think he fired his best.
But I think considering the fact that
he was off for a long time and all that
personal problems that he went through
and he fought a real tough guy and OSP
that was in a fairly defensive
position and a lot of the fight,
he didn't risk anything.
It's more else.
Very John.
Well,
Osp photo smart fight.
You're far a smart fight.
Camp tested the water he did the
best is Billy took some chances,
but he got out of the fight
ultimately in pretty good shape.
We set bruise on his arm,
got broke,
come to win.
Really?
Another guy who his arm got broke by kick.
Yeah,
John broke his arm.
Probably significantly slowed him down.
Yeah,
so I didn't think it was
a bad performance at all.
I think osps fucking good man and getting
better and a dangerous eats a tricky
fight for anybody.
He's a super powerful guy.
So South Paul,
I thought,
I just thought John Look
kind of lackadaisical.
He didn't risk anything,
get too much to lose.
Just a lot of factors,
a lot of factors and also getting that
off of his chest and then getting back in
there and fighting.
Daniel is going to be like a
warmup fight against a top six guy.
Cause that's the OSP was I'm pretty
sure it was ranked number six.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a great thing for John.
He also didn't show anything.
He didn't,
he,
he really didn't show DC anything.
But what I was gonna say is it Greg
Jackson seem to think allegedly after that
fight that the weightlifting might've
played a part in him look tight.
That's fair.
You think so?
Because when you're in the weight room,
you put on more muscle,
you know,
you're slower,
you're a little more,
the more you know you're not as fluid.
You know.
It's interesting cause he didn't fight
for a while and you went through the
shit.
He was in jail.
Hey Greg Jackson.
I think it's more,
I think it's more that he t boned
a pregnant lady ran from the scene.
He had some time in jail.
You didn't find,
not gone forever.
It's called doc gun rusk and they thought
it very talented south Paul who is
tricky to deal with.
That's more what it is.
It's not,
it ain't the weight lifting well,
yeah.
It's interesting that you
would like it immediately,
like blame one aspect because one of the
things it was after I talked to John or
while I was talking to
John after the fight,
one of the things that he said was
that he felt physically felt great.
He just wasn't,
he wasn't engaging enough or it wasn't
pulling the trigger and you wanted to,
this was probably like
just a comfort thing.
You know?
He hadn't been fighting in a long time.
All the pressure,
all,
he's like probably quite a few factors
and maybe even it's not either or.
Maybe even the weightlifting might
have slowed him down a little bit.
Like you said,
I think it's the number of things,
but look at Gusto when
he's been out for a while.
They gave him a pretty,
I'm not saying it's a warm up fight,
but he's not finding a top 10 guy.
John's warmup fight was against the number
six guy in the world where the South
Paul,
who's explosives as fuck,
he's supposed to fight
for the world title.
So John was being a little hesitant,
safe.
He knows what's on the line.
Is there some sort of
history between Gustafson,
the guys fighting?
Is there a reason why
they're going to file things?
I think remember Gastrin was like,
I don't know if I want to do this anymore.
So I think it's more of like,
text me water against,
let's see if this is for you.
Go through a 12 week training camp.
Let's see what happens.
Cause you're phenomenal fighter.
Really?
Yeah.
That's interesting man.
Because I'm like you as a fighter,
when a fighter starts entertaining
those thoughts of stopping,
it's game over.
It's game over.
It's game over you and it,
it's game over.
It really is B.
And this has come from a guy who
didn't think that way for a long time.
Even when he told them,
I'm like,
what's he talking about?
One flooded in one for that.
And then when it finally the dust cell,
I'm like,
it's kind of fucking right.
Cause then when you're fighting guys
who it's all they have good life being a
glow overtake share who's
in fucking Connecticut in
the snow running sprints and
all he gives a fuck about
is knocking you out.
Or Anthony Johnson,
who all he cares about his knock,
you know,
he doesn't care about anything else.
And when you're one foot in,
one foot out,
you just can't compete at that level.
You just can't.
You can be a guy and still fight,
win some,
lose some.
But you should.
You should leave.
I think you're right.
And I'm glad you said that you should
leave 100% because I'm telling you,
there's guys out there who they
live and die for this shit.
They don't care about anything else.
Literally nothing more.
Mcdonald's Pete with them.
Good luck man.
Good luck.
Good luck while you're doing a
fucking radio show telling Dick Jokes,
this guy's hitting mitts are
getting better at the craft.
You just can't compete,
man.
Yup.
And it's his paycheck because how you
feed this family [inaudible] you're going
to get hurt.
See this time to record,
knock on,
he got knocked out by this cat
Christoph junk toe Jocko fucking name,
clean lefthand.
He was,
he was pressuring pressing the action,
looking to establish a his range
and everything is like a minute in.
This dude hit him with a perfectly time
lefthand like right on the eye socket.
Just jarred him and went down.
Then he finished him off
with some sick Hammerfest.
Check this out,
watch he's moving forward and this guy
had been like threatened with the left
hand.
We couldn't find his range.
Watch how he just slides
back and then back in.
Oh God damn.
I mean that is just thunderous hairline
difference up than heroin is dope as
fuck.
If you win,
it ain't good in the movie.
If you see gt back,
a man who unconscious on a bathroom
floor as he's way worse to Jason,
Jason,
Steve,
he's tall,
he's tapped out.
Type Tandon is holding off some weird
shit on the side of the here area and
stayed the man.
Celebrities.
There are the better for all of us.
Trust me,
says Mr. Full head of
hair with the [inaudible].
You have thick hair privilege.
You have super my hair falling out.
I'm getting old.
We can't listen to you.
I'm going to shave my head.
I'm going to join the bowl.
Well you know Tim didn't McCrory.
It looked really good and his last fight
man and he won by a quick knockout in
the first round and you know this is,
this is just the nature of the beast,
man.
Really good guy.
Strike.
Meanwhile a cow fucking
goddamn good cowboy.
Look tonight I text you the
best I saw last weekend.
I text you was lemme Chanko yeah,
he has six fucking,
this is boxing.
He has six fights.
He was a gold medalist in the Olympics.
His first pro fight.
He goes,
I won a world championship fight.
They go,
we can't give it to
you on the first fight.
So he gets on a second fight once
a world championship now to six,
five he went to another
world championship.
I'm telling you,
man,
this is the best pound for pound
fighter in the world right now.
He's bad motherfucker.
I'm like,
God,
you're a bad mother.
Those are fucking nuts.
If you like Dominick Cruz,
this guy's doing unboxing Islamic Chanko,
right?
Well with Chanko.
Yeah,
that's how you say his last name.
Oh,
it's fucking,
and he's a an artist in their mouth.
Beautiful.
Fun to watch.
But he lost to a solar lease,
right?
He did.
They fight again.
Eat fucking smoking.
What happened in the first fight?
I didn't see it.
It was a decision and some
people even gave to Loma Genco.
Well,
Sally's is a really good,
a brawling man is a tough,
tough dude,
man.
He's one of those bad
ass Mexican fighters.
You know,
if you go look at like bad ads,
blood and guts fighters,
if you had a look at like one nation that
continually produces bad ass blood and
guts fighters,
Mexico,
look at Canelo Alvarez shot man.
Julio,
Cesar Chavez,
Mexico has had some bad mother fuckers,
evil Oscar de la Hoya.
They don't want to give it to
him cause he's good looking.
God Damn.
And he's Mexican.
He's a bad motherfucker.
I rewatch Oscar de la Hoya vs
Julio Cesar Chavez last week.
God Dang,
I forgot who it was.
Golden boy was the best.
I saw that at the La sports
arena on close circuit.
Like you gotta let took a basketball
arena and you get to see it on,
he knows better than all of them
to me and one for Dell Marquez.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck.
You's amongst Marcus show a
shirt on the podcast that day.
Did you really are today where
Jim was a route to fight?
It's shot.
Oh,
no,
no.
It was a fight.
I saw him fight at the,
um,
at the forum with my
friend Terry Claiborne.
I saw him fight,
uh,
Marco Antonio Berrera.
Oh fuck man.
Okay.
Oh,
the fuck Marquez was a fucking monster.
So tobacco garble hall.
No south.
Who fought?
Who the fuck?
Fuck no,
no.
That wasn't the fight that went on.
The God damn it too much weight.
Chocolate seat.
They'll blow your fucking mind to,
Schwab's has never been
better than right now.
It's amazing.
Well,
he had that epic one.
Memo Marquez.
Hi.
Dot Manny Marco Antonio Barrera.
Marco Antonio Borough had
that Prince Ahmed fight.
It was Marco Antonio Barrera.
And who's fighting someone else?
Arturo Gotti.
No damn dog.
Gimme Marketing.
Antonio Barrera was a Wikipedia so I
could figure out which fight it was,
but I still wasn't sure how long ago.
Just were born to New York
or here from New York.
Oh Wow.
With my friend Terry Clay bond who
is still a boxing trainer in La.
Where what Jim?
I don't know.
Where is Jim is man,
I think he's got a on labrea somewhere.
I haven't seen him in a long time.
It's a really cool dude.
I went with him,
but we went to,
uh,
to watch it is when Marco Antonio Barrera,
before he even fought
prince not seem Hammad.
Let's see what we got here.
Damn side of Mexico.
Wisco rolled up.
Scroll up a little jammy.
Keep going.
Oh,
it was Kennedy McKinney.
That's who it was.
Oh,
there you go.
Yeah.
That's 2003 son.
Yeah,
it was in Anaheim.
See?
Yup.
Inglewood.
Is that what it was?
Yeah,
that's what it was.
Kennedy McKinney.
Yeah.
Is that before or is that 1996
Benevidez was in 1996 on February,
1986 February 3rd I got the days wrong,
but that was when I was a working out at
the Hollywood gym is that 24 hour gym.
They used to be on a dude forever,
forever in a week.
Um,
that Jim that is still there,
that Hollywood gym is 24
hour gym still to this day.
It's on labrea right across the street
from where our old legends used to be.
That.
Yep.
I used to work out there and he was,
when he was training John David Jackson,
when John David Jackson was
a middleweight champion.
Damn.
Back in the day,
some old school and this one sugar
Shane Mosley was just coming up,
dude.
So you're seeing Mosley,
there was posters of him.
He had won the Olympics and it was just
coming up as a pro boxer and everybody
was like,
God damn,
keep your eyes on sugar.
Shane Mosley pound for pound best
in the world for a long time.
Dude that dude had the
lightening fast hands.
Whoa.
Put some combinations on people,
man.
Man.
What was it like fighting,
what was it like doing
commentary on his fight,
uh,
to be,
you did it for,
what would you do for cvs?
CBS Sports.
He's a,
he's a buddy.
It's tough man,
because
it's tough because
obviously past his time,
you know,
it's like he fought a lot,
young line and he did well,
but he definitely,
you know,
he probably lost the fight.
He definitely lost the fight,
but it's like,
where do you go from here?
Here's like the,
where that fight fights.
Thurman.
Thurman or border.
Yeah,
both guys.
What are you going to do with that?
Right.
You can do with that.
Well,
you know,
here's my question.
I don't know thing.
We know each other where I can say,
hey brother,
what are you doing?
How do you distinguish a guy
like Shane Mosley from a garlic,
Bernard Hopkins like Gag Bernard Hopkins.
If he thinks that he can fight somebody,
I want to see him see if
he can fight that guy.
Even if it,
even though he's 49 or
almost 50 I mean that guy,
the only guy that really kind of
dismantled his defense was Kovalev Kavala.
Put them in some real trouble.
Real trouble.
Kovalev to me might be
the best in the world.
Pound for pound.
He's one of them.
He's done top three could article Lufkin.
Him apparently had some
wars and some boxing wars.
That's the rumors are they're both nasty,
nasty fucking knockout.
Russia's own combat sports.
Really think about it.
Not really named one UFC Russian champion
Nigga,
Nigga Madoff.
Do I get him?
He'll be
jumping to conclusions.
He might have some good shit.
Habib's on defeated.
Just injuries.
Stopped him here.
He beat the champion of Santos.
He's 55
he's the outlier and fuck,
goddamn.
He's a fucking,
there's a lot of them bud.
Some fury fury just
beat Vladimir Klitschko.
They're fighting again.
Yeah,
but Tyson fury just beat Bladimir.
Klitschko correct.
Okay.
Coville off.
Good luck.
But Andre Ward might be able to beat him.
I don't think so.
He better fight more than fracking.
So confident Brendan,
Brendan and boxing right now.
Is there an African
American heavy weight boxer?
Fucking vicious,
nasty,
wilder.
Oh,
Anthony Joshua from England's.
I'll fucking look.
Joshua [inaudible].
Joshua,
when he looks like he'd win the Olympia,
right.
Look at this poll about who
they want Wonderboy to fight.
63% of the people said Wonderboy.
9% of Damien Maia like past our good.
It's just cause people won't see Nakia.
That gigantic killer praying that this
world champion Jiu Jitsu straggler.
Fuck that Damien Maia
puts the chuck two people.
My friend love watching
dude and line right now.
This fight was interesting,
man.
I was watching,
this is Chris Beall was tagging Joe Soto,
but Joe Soto was moving with Shit.
He was constantly pressuring him and he
got him to the ground and took his back.
This he's fighting the next CDI.
He's getting lit up cost Soto Joseph.
He's a David [inaudible] Guy,
right?
Yeah.
He's a brown belt and gave it to the
finals against Eddie Cummings and Ebi for
the last time.
Yeah.
You don't want to enter the fine.
He yelled something to me and I wanted
to talk to you about this because he
yelled something to me during the fall,
after he won his last fight.
He was like,
I didn't grease up.
I didn't grease up dude.
I don't know what you're,
I dunno what y'all are like as if I
knew it because of him telling any,
I didn't grease up.
So it was about misunderstanding.
Um,
well if you're totally,
totally well either way,
man.
Super suspect.
Ooh.
Well he was just trying to clarify to
me because he knew that they were on
commercial,
but it was um,
whatever.
That doesn't matter.
What he did tonight was beautiful,
beautiful grappling.
You take them.
He took us back to why I
said a real strong way.
It took us back in the second
and the third and I was like,
man,
he can threaten.
Cause once he gets to the,
once he got to the ground,
he was taking his back like really quick.
Oh,
super quick.
Like knife through butter.
Yeah.
It wasn't like he was in danger issues.
First off,
it's more of like how quickly would
he be able to progress to the back.
It was just a matter of time.
Forget his neck.
He's a very good grappler,
man.
Very good grappler.
Amazing.
I wasn't aware of how
good he was to be honest.
David.
Tarell guys are fucking animals.
Everyone I know says David trail is in
the training room is the biggest fucking
freak of all time.
It'll all the like the
legendary stories I hear.
They,
everyone tells me David
[inaudible] a mother fucker dude.
We saw her legendary stories from everyone
grapple in his prime in Abu Dhabi in
2003 back when uh,
Eddie went down there.
I saw him like in his prime.
He got some really high level guys.
See I heard,
I heard eating that I heard even then,
he never lived up to his potential.
I heard in the trains.
I'm telling you,
I've heard like it at,
I've never grabbed the guy.
I don't know.
I think I've met him
once passing through UFC.
He's like a Centaur.
Like he's the stories I hear from
other people and legit people are nuts.
One thing that was clear with Joe Soto
and Ebi for was his leg locks were really
good in his leg lock
defense hasn't trail enough.
Yeah,
and it was because of Dave truck.
He's been all about leg locks for the
last 10 15 years and he got to the finals
against Eddie Cummings who just
leg locked three dudes in a row.
And you would think nobody ever
sits on their ass in place.
Footsies with any Cummins.
They genuinely don't that.
Yeah.
That's like,
okay,
let's,
let's try to get around those
legs and try to play smash.
That's what everyone's trying to do.
They don't want to go like for
legs with no Eddie Cummins.
But Joe Soto did in the
fucking Tony and no,
no,
no.
But Eddie Cummings is,
he's the champion.
He's coming back to defend the belt.
That's a Saturday,
July 16th on fight pass.
Boom.
Ebi On fucking five pounds.
So good.
It's going well.
So good and Fucker,
it's took best grappling format that's
ever been created far which is such a
smart move,
man.
Have Fun when you guys went fucking.
But it's fights moving wheel fucking white
about five shows.
Is that the one thing that king of the
cage had that no one else had is they
would have to 13 fights,
but there would be no waiting.
As soon as one fight was done,
boom,
they start the next fight.
Bam.
As that.
That's a bad idea.
But I hear you for Judah to for well,
for anything it's great because it
just moves the show along and you know,
uh,
we were,
behind schedule because we've had to do
everything in a three hour block because
of paper view and we're behind.
So we weren't even showing replace.
People thought that that was our style.
We don't show replays.
Like we didn't even have
time for replaced go.
We were just go,
go,
go.
Is that little girl
still ripping heels off?
Which one?
He turned my grace.
You know what I'm talking about?
The only one ripping heels off.
Oh Riley,
she's gonna fight soul
snatcher in September.
You're better.
Yeah,
we gotta find a,
an opponent for,
we don't have an opponent for it,
but grace is fighting
and Ebi seven as well.
I'm super curious to see how this is
received because as a person who loves
Jujitsu,
and I think we could all agree on this,
like one of the big problems that
you've been involved in these kinds of
matches,
they go to draw and it's like a lot
of them go to draw and you'll have a
professional matches four five
six in a row and nothing happened.
Super Boring and nothing happened.
The,
the draws are boring though.
Some are amazing
on 100% peritoneum versus who said mark
behind the great draw for the public.
They're not trying to see that
joy.
The mouth finishes.
Yeah,
but they still enjoy them.
Not just saying if you out
ratings you need finishes or none.
That's what you mean sort of.
But I see your point too because there's
something interesting about a fight
that gets that close to being finished
several times with a guy escapes and you
don't know exactly what's going to
happen and there's a lot of drama.
And then it gets to the
end and it still drama,
but it would be infinitely better
if then they moved into your format.
That's what they went to draw was pretty
good because it was a technical jujitsu
battle,
but your format makes that draw one of
the best fights in the history of the
world
because all of a sudden the has got
Jake shields back and he starts,
he starts with the over under or Jake's
got his back and he starts to go over
under,
that's all I'm saying.
Any your format proves that we want to
see people try and finish because if you
have the metamor style though,
it proves that that
thing's not working styles.
Is that your style?
That could work the metamor style.
If there was more incentive
to win instead of a draw,
there's men an incentive.
People were like,
you don't want to lose weight set up off.
The problem is,
the problem with the
draws is when you have,
when it's clear that the
one of the fighters are,
both of the fighters are
totally satisfied with the draw.
They're like,
fuck it.
Who you tell him.
You know what I mean?
As long as there's then,
then it's a problem,
you know?
But if two guys are really going after it,
then it's not a problem.
So how do you make guys
to really go after it?
You got to make it up.
Finance Bi.
Well there you go.
What are we talking about?
I'm trying.
You have to do Ebi rules.
Otherwise you from saying it's all good.
It's a beautiful Porsche just wiped out.
It was so depressing.
Got Destroyed.
Some crazy race and for gt GTVs fried.
I don't know what the races
but some of them on social,
just scorched teen hybrid.
What hybrid on my phone guys
are all experts aren't too.
These people are nuts.
Who knows more about cars all day?
Joel question for sure.
You're like a blue belt
and he's like a black belt,
right?
Yeah.
I'd say I'm a junk car.
Magazines for the last 20 Saul,
he's in a car wreck since I've known him.
He's balls deep and like fixing the cars.
I'm a fan.
I'm a fascinated person.
I'm easily fascinated by
engineering discipline.
You know the ins and outs of it,
like like archery shooting.
You're going to spend 20 hours on it.
I'll spend an hour on it and
I'll move on to something else.
Then I'll come back the next day.
Another hour.
Not everything though,
ma'am.
You're into it though.
You show us the ring.
Yeah.
You're selling into it.
It's a mental problem.
There's something wrong with me.
You had that NSF.
Jesus Christ.
It's a corvette wiped out,
but that's a beautiful car to Jesus.
Fucking,
oh my God.
Asian Nascar drivers.
First Asian Nascar drivers.
So recessed we're setting.
I would protest against sense.
Jesus got one job.
You drive in a psalm and you
know those things break dude.
Shit goes wrong.
All of that in a corvette.
Now that's a different one.
Oh,
I guess they have a bunch
of fucking accidents.
That one's on fire,
Yo.
That's no big deal.
What is that?
That's like a Batmobile you
have to run at this point.
Yeah,
you should.
Oh Shit.
Oh my God.
Damn.
This car racing.
Just got
any movies.
What happens at that point that you've
got to get the fuck out of dodge before
you become a part of the problem.
I want them to look like
actual cars that are dope.
I think racing is fucking
probably so unbelievably exciting,
but the consequences are
absolutely devastated.
You Die.
How crazy do you have to
be to race a car like that?
They all crazy.
No,
they develop a real good sense
of how to control the car.
And then at a high level you're around
a lot of other people with a really good
sense of how to control car and
then you got to mind each other.
And that was like one of the things about,
um,
that fucking dude,
uh,
Ayrton Senna.
If you ever seen that
documentary on Ayrton Senna,
he's a Brazilian guy who was a formula
one racer who was extremely aggressive.
I think it's Formula One.
He's a race car driver.
I don't know much about this stuff.
I believe that he was Formula One,
but if they had a documentary
on him and was fucking genius,
man,
it's brilliant.
He was just this dude who just felt
where the car was going at a level,
like at an understanding that very few
people ever get to and he would push it
to that fucking limit.
He like had this feeling for what
a car could and couldn't do and he,
he better than almost anybody of his
era could get the car to that limit and
everybody was scared of him.
That's pretty cool.
Super Dangerous.
You got a Porsche nine 11 g r s
you need to step your game up.
Joe.
Look your gt three C I
don't want to do those.
Yeah,
he do.
He do.
I definitely don't.
I like going [inaudible] damn.
One step below this.
It is,
but I like to go through a canyon and
a slightly unreasonable race rate of
speed.
That's it.
Just slightly.
I,
Hey,
hey,
slow down.
Let's take it easy.
I or hear a rumble shift.
I like to feel a car
pulling into a corner.
I don't need to break the law that deep.
These motherfuckers are crazy,
dude.
I love me.
How often do you guys die in this racing?
Oh,
they die all the time.
Not so much.
And how often they had a bunch of
regulations put in place after like Dale
Earnhardt died for
one.
You're talking about Nascar over
f what I'm thinking about this,
what kind of sport other
than race car driving,
there's like one of the number one guys
die on the job and everybody's like,
well
they can get really bad now.
And there's the walk away from it.
Is it because of the new technology?
They barely are moving
in those little cockpits.
Their heads are.
That's actually really good news,
man.
I wish I knew that.
I do know that.
Thank you Jamie.
Thank you.
Well that's awesome that they figured
that out and it definitely is a comfort,
but it's still a dangerous sport but
dangerous endeavor and these guys are
athletes for sure.
Right?
I would agree.
It takes a lot of fucking,
you gotta be tuned in.
It's exhausting.
Some of these guys are great
man to physical activity.
It's arguable.
It's not athletes in the same extent.
It's not an athlete to the same extent
as like an MMA fighter or a basketball
player or someone who relies on
endurance as well as explosive ability.
This my thing just as a physical,
how is this any different?
Well yet,
how's it any different?
If I play a race car game
on my couch in a Sauna,
oh,
we can't die.
You fuck.
Okay,
so kind of question is
that this is real shit.
If you play a game on your day,
barely,
they barely ever die.
Come on man.
It's still the,
the terror of getting an an,
an,
an accident.
Even if you don't think
you're going to die.
So he jumps through a plaintiff's
through a plaintiff's work.
Jumping through a plane,
jumping off a plane,
sorry.
Oh,
hang gliding.
In sport,
I think competitions about hang gliding.
That's your sweet ass.
That's a physical activity.
See,
I think the problem is,
or the definition,
the definition is just,
you know,
trying to put this in.
We know what this is.
This is car racing.
It's quiet.
But why does it have to be a
sport or a game or an endeavor?
This is fucking car racing.
This is what it is like.
There's no need to categorize it and
decide whether or not it's a sport,
but be more joy it for whatever the fuck.
Hey man,
it's on Fox sports one bro.
I mean it's not on fucking CNN.
Money's involved.
Money,
sport,
professional,
professional poker.
A sport.
It's on ESPN.
It's poker
poker on Fox sports one
yes.
Okay.
That gets weird.
Right,
and they do it for hours or takes
a lot of focus is on ESPN two okay,
well then it's chess.
A sport because chess is
like a more complicated,
what about go?
It's more complicated than chess.
Very good.
Chess boxing.
Do you ever see that?
Oh,
that's retarded.
That's ridiculous.
Don't do that anymore.
Grass.
That's tough.
Yeah,
let's stop it.
Let's do it.
Let's hit him on the hook and
then make them do complex move.
Stop.
Don't do that anymore.
That's a gimmick,
man.
These fucking cars are so
God damn capable today.
It's amazing.
When you look at cars
just a few decades ago,
like car engineering,
he's had an amazing level right now.
Some sort of a really strange place.
The point of this kind of at a standstill.
The what point does it go away when you
have fucking Tesla's driving themselves.
Then you have [inaudible] wood
oven has a horse race cars.
He baiting here in round one.
Not Fuck.
Are you doing man?
Standstill.
The wheels,
the wheels.
The frames are the one and we
got two headlights steer away.
Can we restart it?
I have to stop it and restart.
Restart it.
We're going to keep going.
I want to stop.
All right.
We're going to take a leak folks.
We run out of our files
killing and be like so long,
so I don't know what's going on with that.
This is like some shit.
They're going to laugh
about one day a second.
I just got,
I live at
to fun and we'll be right back.
You're really going to take a break.
Fuck it,
dude.
We're rolling.
It's like one of the greatest podcast.